GET STARTED- WE HAVE MEMBERS OF
THE WANDERING IN AND ATTENDING
AND THEN WANDERING BACK OUT TO
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES AT THEIR
END- WE HAVE WITH US- FROM SOME
OF OUR MAP THIS IS PART OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE- HERE FOR THE
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS. BUT
BEFORE WE START I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE LAND THAT WE'RE
ON THAT ME WHAT LISTEN ON AND
PART OF AN PEOPLE FROM THIS AREA
SO I RECOGNIZE THEM. AND LET ME
BEGIN BY THANKING THOSE OF YOU
IN THE AUDIENCE- AND WATCHING ON
THE ASSEMBLY TELEVISION- PAGE AS
WELL AS OUR PRESENTERS THAT ARE
HERE IN PERSON AND THOSE THAT
WILL JOIN US ON ZOOM- YOUR TIME.
AND THE SHARING OF YOUR THOUGHTS
AND KNOWLEDGE TODAY. ARE ARE
MOST APPRECIATED APPRECIATED BY
THE SELECT COMMITTEE. AND BY THE
STATE LEGISLATURE BECAUSE THE
TOPICS THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING.
FIRM FOR MANY TIMES THESE TYPES
OF DISCUSSIONS ARE THE FIRST
TIME THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY BEING
HELD. HERE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. SO TODAY'S HEARING
IS FOCUSED ON HOW THE
HISTORICAL. EXPERIENCES OF
NATIVE AMERICANS HAVE SHAPED
THEIR ATTITUDES TOWARDS
EDUCATION. AND WHAT IT MEANS FOR
THE EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT- ON
THE PANELS THAT WE HAVE WITH US
THERE WILL BE GOING THROUGH- OUR
FIRST PANEL IS THE EVOLUTION OF
NATIVE AMERICANS IN EDUCATION.
THE ROLE OF BOARDING SCHOOLS AND
THE EFFORT TO STRIP NATIVE
AMERICANS OF THEIR LANGUAGE. THE
PRESENTERS ON THAT PANEL WILL
BE- PROFESSOR PATRICIA DIXON-
AMANDA KAY WIXEN. AND DR ROSE SO
WAR SOLDIER. PANEL TWO WILL BE
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAW
DISCUSSION. AND THOSE ON THAT
PANEL WILL BE MONA ON ADULTS IN
THE UK TRAVEL REPRESENTATIVE.
PRESIDENT AROUND VALLEY- TRIBES
TRIBAL COUNCIL PRESIDENT JAMES
RUSS. AND DEAN DEAN FAGAN FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF THE HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF LAW AND CHANCELLOR
AND DEAN. PANEL THREE WILL BE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN NATIONS
COLLEGES WHY WE NEED OUR OWN
COLLEGE TAKING BACK OUR POWER.
THAT WILL BE- ON THE PANEL TO
RESET MIKE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
NATIONS AND CELESTE TOWNSEND
THE- CALIFORNIA INDIAN NATIONS
COLLEGE PRESIDENT SO THOSE WILL
BE THE PANELS OF DISCUSSION AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. AND IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
COME TOGETHER AND TALK ABOUT
EACH ONE OF THESE PANELS IN EACH
ONE OF THESE- ISSUES THAT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE- OUR
PANELIST- WILL BE ABLE TO SHED
SOME LIGHT. FROM THE VIEW OF
THE- CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL AS HAVE
INSIGHT FROM- THE LAW SCHOOL AT
HASTINGS WITH THE DEAN FAGAN-
PARTICIPATING IN THAT TO SHOW
HOW WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER TO
TRY TO. CREATE SOME SOLUTIONS TO
THE HISTORY AND MANY TIMES THESE
TOPICS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE TODAY- THE GENERAL PUBLIC
HAS NO IDEA THAT THESE TYPES OF
ATROCITIES THESE TYPES OF STRIP.
OF ASSIMILATION AND CULTURE EVEN
TOOK PLACE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THE IGNORANCE-
CONTRIBUTES TO A LOT OF THE
HURDLES THAT WE STILL SEE GOING
ON IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEMS IN
MANY AREAS SO THIS WILL SHED A
LIGHT. TO TALK ABOUT THOSE
ISSUES SO THAT WE CAN TRULY MOVE
FORWARD AND CORRECT- THE PAST
HISTORIES INFLICTED UPON OUR
PEOPLE AND I SAY OUR PEOPLE
BECAUSE WE SIT HERE AS THE CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY NATIVE AMERICAN
SELECT COMMITTEE AND THE ONLY
CALIFORNIA INDIAN ELECTED IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. AND THIS IS
ALSO- THOSE ARE WATCHING AND
THOSE IN THE AUDIENCE- OF. THE
TIME FOR OTHER CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO RUN
FOR OFFICE TO BE ABLE TO BE IN
THE SEATS SO THAT WE CAN FURTHER
THESE DISCUSSIONS. THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
YOU KNOW WE CONTINUE TO. LIVE
THROUGH. THE TOPICS THAT WE
STILL FACE HERE TODAY AS-
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICANS.
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE- OF
SERRANO GOUVEIA AND I LIVE ON
THE SEMI WHY DID RESERVATIONS SO
I GREW UP. WITH A LOT OF THE-
STEREOTYPES THAT WERE INFLICTED
UPON US IN THE EARLY. DAYS OF
SCHOOL RIGHT WE HAD A DIFFERENT-
CULTURAL TIMES ON THE
RESERVATION. AND YET NO ONE IN
THE COMMUNITY WAS WILLING TO
COME AND LEARN ABOUT THE TRUE
FACTUAL HISTORY OF WHO WE ARE.
IN OUR AREA SURROUNDED WITH
PEOPLE SO MUCH SO THAT WHEN WE
WENT TO THE AREA LOCAL I.
MENTERI SCHOOL. THEY HAD A
DISCUSSION ON INDIAN PEOPLE AND
THEY PLAYED A DRUM SONG AND-
IMMEDIATELY THEY ASK WHO'S
NATIVE AMERICAN WOULD YOU STAND
UP WE STOOD UP. AND THEY ASKED
US WHAT THAT SONG MEANT. AND WE
SAID WE DON'T KNOW BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT OUR CULTURE. AND
IMMEDIATELY WE WERE ASKED TO SIT
DOWN BECAUSE WE MUST NOT BE
INDIAN ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND THAT
DRUM SONG. SO THEN THAT STARTED
THE WHOLE PLATE OF TRYING TO
CORRECT RIGHT THE HISTORY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ENGAGE
PEOPLE TO OUR CULTURE. NOW IN
SAN MARINO COUNTY THEY TRULY DO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE SING
TRADITIONAL CLEAVER SONGS IN
BIGHORN SHEEP SONGS. WE DON'T
USE THE DROP. WHAT IS THAT
OPENNESS AND THAT WILLINGNESS TO
LEARN FROM ONE ANOTHER WE SART
TO BREAK DOWN THOSE
MISCONCEPTIONS AND STEREOTYPES.
SO THE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS ON
THE PANELS TODAY- WILL BE
HISTORIC IN BRINGING THOSE
ISSUES FORWARD. AND AGAIN THIS
THIS- HEARING IS RECORDED AND
LIVE STREAM THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY
SO A LOT OF THE TESTIMONY. AND
THE WORDS THAT YOU SAY WILL BE
RECORDED SO THAT WE COULD
ACTUALLY GO BACK AND- RESEARCH
THOSE AND ALLOW OTHERS. TO COME
IN RESEARCH THE WORDS THAT WE
SPOKE IN HERE TODAY-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS. DID YOU
HAVE ANY OPENING COMMENTS.
ALWAYS MAKE SURE SHARE IS.
BETWEEN THE VIOLENCE LOOK AT THE
RICH HERITAGE AND HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PEOPLE WHICH
ONE THANK YOU. SOMEBODY THAT
REPRESENTS- DRIVES. DOING THIS
READING THIS COMMUNITY TOGETHER
A PARTNERSHIP OF YOURSELF THE
OTHER MEMBERS ARE. BUSY DAY.
ESPECIALLY THE TRIAL ALL OF THIS
HISTORY IS. AND AS WE SAID
BEFORE WHEN WE WERE WORKING ON A
MONUMENT LAST YEAR. DO I NEED TO
GET A LITTLE OUT OF HERE ON. I
DON'T EVEN WANT THE ARMY FIX
THAT FOR ME ALL THESE. IT'S GOOD
TO BE HERE IN THE BEAUTIFUL WHY
AND AS I WAS SAYING BEFORE FOR
KAREN ROSS. TO THE UNIVERSE WITH
THIS COMMUNITY TOGETHER FOR THE
HOUR WORK. FORCE AT THE RIDGE.
EARLY HISTORY. AND AS WE WERE
SAYING LAST YEAR WE WERE PUSHING
FOR A MONUMENT. TO RECOGNIZE THE
TRUTH IS. YEAH THIS IS BRUTAL
AND DISTURBING AS IT MAY BE.
THAT IS HOW I MAKE SURE THIS NOT
REPEAT ITSELF. AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SHARE THESE STORIES
YOU NEED TO BRING BACK. THESE
NATIVE LANGUAGES IF YOU RESPECT-
TYPE POLISH. TO OUR ANCESTORS
THANK YOU ALL FOR PARTICIPATING
IN AFTER GERMAN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND DEDICATION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS AND-
ALWAYS WORKING TOGETHER ON A LOT
OF ISSUES THAT IMPACT ON THE
NATIVE AMERICANS HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- AND
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES-
AND WE PARTNERED ON MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN. THOSE
TYPES OF AREAS AND SO WE
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR THESE
AREAS- SO THIS IS MORE OF A-
HEARING TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
INFORMATIONAL OUT OF WHAT'S
TRULY HAPPENING I'M HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ITH THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT ARE GOING ON-
THEY WILL HAVE TO SERVE
PATIENTS. VIRTUAL AND WE'LL HAVE
THOSE THAT ARE HERE IN PERSON.
WE ALSO WILL HAVE SOME TIME FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND THE NUMBER
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IF- MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISH TO MAKE
COMMENTS THEY MAY CALL- EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE ONE TWO SIX. AGAIN WE'LL
HAVE TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END OF THE HEARING. BUT IF
YOU WANT TO- WRITE DOWN THE
NUMBER AND YOU'RE WATCHING BY
VIDEO. OR IF YOU WANT TO CALL
IN. THE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE ONE
TWO SIX. WE ARE PRACTICING
COLVIN- RESTRICTIONS SO PLEASE
KEEP YOUR MASS- COVERED. AS YOU
COME UP TO- SPEAK IF YOU'RE HERE
IN PERSON- TO THE DIETS AND
WE'LL CALL YOU UP FOR THAT. AND
NOW WE WILL START TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH OUR FIRST PANEL
DISCUSSION- JOIN IN THIS VIRTUAL
WILL BE PURSUED PROFESSOR
PATRICIA DIXON. CHAIR OF
DEPARTMENT OF AMERICAN INDIAN
STUDIES AT PAULA MARK COLLEGE
PROFESSOR DIXON IS A MEMBER OF
THE PALM ABANDON THE SANYA
INDIANS AND RESIDES ON THE
POMMEL INDIAN RESERVATION. SHE
ALSO TAUGHT AT SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY FOR TWENTY YEARS AND
HAS WORKED WITH A NUMBER OF
NATIVE AMERICAN ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING SERVING ON THE SHERMAN
INDIAN HIGH SCHOOL BOARD. DO WE
HAVE HER READY TO GO ON THE
VIRTUAL. I THINK SO. ARE YOU
THERE. I'M HERE ALL RIGHT. WE
GOT AUDIO AND WE GOT YOU ON
SCREEN IN THE- YES I CAN SEE
YOUR POINT. I USED. AND DO YOU
KNOW WHAT. I'LL LET YOU SEE MY
MESSY OFFICE BECAUSE I TRY SOME
OF THE BACKGROUNDS I HE FELT
FLOATING PICTURE OF YOUR FACE
YOU KNOW WAS LIKE YOU DON'T DARE
MOVE SO YOU GET TO SEE MY MESSY
OFFICE. SO IT'S ONLY YOU KNOW
KNOCKED ON MY I'M JUST SAYING
HELLO MY NAME IS PATRICIA DIXON
AND- I DO HAVE A POWER POINT- IF
YOU WANT. TO SHOW IT R. I CAN
JUST TALK FROM IT BECAUSE I I'M
I KNOW WE HAVE LIMITED TIME. SO
WHATEVER WORKS FOR YOU- CAN I
SHARE MY SCREEN. DO YOU SHARE
YES WE COULD TRY THAT THE POWER
POINT OF IT COMES UP ON YOUR
SCREEN. WELL I HIT SHARE AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO NEXT ON
YOUR THING SO IT DOESN'T LIKE
TELL ME WHAT. USUALLY WOULD COME
UP ON THE SCREEN WHERE YOU'RE ON
BUT- OKAY THEN I WILL JUST GO
AHEAD AND TALK TO. I HAD A VERY
LOVELY PICTURE OF WHERE I LIVE
OUT IN THE FOOTHILLS OF PALMER
MOUNTAIN RANGE TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF JUST SOME WHERE I COME
FROM. BUT THERE ARE SEVERAL
THINGS I WANTED TO DO THAT WE'RE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENED IN CALIFORNIA BUT
ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW ARE
ULTIMATELY. AND EVEN THOUGH I AM
A PROFESSOR I DON'T WANT TO
REALLY LECTURE LECTURES SO I AM
GOING TO JUST TRY TO HIGHLIGHT
IT FOR YOU IF I CAN. AND WE
TODAY ARE THE BENEFICIARIES OF-
FOR THE LOT A LACK OF BETTER
WORDS SOMETHING CALLED THE
DOCTRINE OF DISCOVERY. AND THE
DOCTOR DISCOVERY WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS CREATED IN THE LATE
FOURTEEN HUNDREDS. TO BASICALLY
SOLIDIFIED THE RIGHT OF
EUROPEANS AND THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH AT THAT POINT IN TIME TO
LAY CLAIM TO WHAT WAS ON. THE
DISCOVER IT LANDS IN THE
AMERICAS. AND THE ONLY WAY THAT
THOSE EUROPEAN POWERS WHICH WERE
ORIGINALLY SPAIN AND PORTUGAL
COULD. EXERCISE DOMINION WOULD
BE TO ALSO GET WHAT ARE CALLED
THE GIFTS AND IN QUOTATION MARKS
OF CONVERSION IN CIVILIZATION.
AND IT WAS- THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE
YOU DO THAT. THE COOKIES THE
DOORS DOWN DID NOT ENGAGE IN
THAT RESPONSIBILITY QUICKLY
BECAUSE THEIR GOAL WAS. TO LAY
CLAIM TO THE LAND INTO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ITS RESOURCES AND
THE PEOPLE THAT LIVED IN IT
OFTENTIMES YOU- WARFARE- AND
CRUELTY. BUT EVENTUALLY THEY'RE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WHO. DEMANDED
THAT THEY. DO IT BECAUSE THEY
THEY HAD TO STAND BEFORE OD AT
ONCE THE ONE PARTICULAR DAY. SO
THE PRINCIPLES OF THAT DOCTOR
BASICALLY WAS A LEGAL AND MORAL
JUSTIFICATION BUT ALLOW THE
PRESENCE OF EUROPEANS IN THAT.
IN THE UNDISCOVERED AMERICA'S AT
THAT POINT TIME. AND WHAT IS
INTERESTING IS THAT THE OTHER
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES WILL JOIN A
HUNDRED YEARS LATER I WILL
CHOOSE TO FOLLOW THOSE
PRINCIPLES IT'S NOT A LAW BUT
THEIR PRINCIPLES. AND THEY ARE
MORE INTERESTED IN SECURING THE
RIGHT TO THE AMERICAS AGAINST
EACH OTHER. AND THERE IS AN
IMPLICIT RECOGNITION AS THE
INDIANS WERE THERE FOR THE
SIMPLE REASON THAT THEY WERE
PHYSICALLY THERE YOU HAD TO
COUNT FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
HOW YOU'RE DOING IT. SO THERE
THE RECOGNITION OF THEIR LACK
RIGHT TO THE LAND WAS PRESENT
BUT IS INFERIOR BECAUSE THEY
WERE CHRISTIAN. AND BECAUSE HE
ALSO DIDN'T HAVE THE GOOD SENSE
TO DEVELOP THE LAND LIKE IT
SHOULD BE LET SHOULD BE
DEVELOPED ACCORDING TO EUROPEAN
IDEAS. AND THERE WAS A VERY
BLATANT- IGNORING OF THE FACT OF
OTHER PARTS OF THE AMERICAS THAT
HAD VERY ELABORATE CIVILIZATION
IS AN AGRICULTURAL DEVELOPMENT.
IF THE NATIVES REFUSED YES OF
CONVERSION AND CIVILIZATION. IT
WOULD ALLOW FOR WARFARE END OF
THE CALL JUST WARFARE. BECAUSE
OF THE TYPE OF HISTORY WITH
PEOPLE. FEARED FOR THEIR SOULS
AND TO ENGAGE IN ON JUST WAR
WOULD BE TO SUFFER YOUR REST OF
YOUR LIFE AFTER DEATH IN A IN A
HELL. THERE WAS ALSO A VERY
SMALL PART IN THAT DOCTOR
DISCOVERY THAT- SAID IF. THE
CONVERSION OF CIVILIZATION WENT
WELL. THEN OF COURSE IS THE LAND
THAT BELONGED TO THE INDIANS
ORIGINALLY WAS STILL RE RE BEING
RETAINED BY THEM. BUT THERE WAS
THIS BELIEF THAT CONVERSION OF
CIVILIZATION WOULD BE DONE SO
WELL THAT THEY SIMPLY BECOME A
PROBLEM. AND BE A PART OF THE
SYSTEM USUALLY AS A P. ON IF YOU
WILL GET AS A VERY SIMPLE FARMER
AND THEN THEY WOULD SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE- OF THE
CIVILIZATION THAT THE
ESTABLISHED. WHILE THIS WAS
BEING DECIDED- AND SLOWLY
IMPLEMENTED THERE'S TWO MEN AND
ONE WAS A MAN CALLED BARTOLOME
DE LAS CASAS. HE WAS A SPANIARD
WHO BECAME A DOMINICAN PRIEST
LATER IN LIFE AND THEN ONCE THEY
PULL THE WHO IS ALSO A SPANIARD
AND ISSUE A LITTLE AND NOT A
THEOLOGIAN SURPRISING ENOUGH
HE'S A LAYMEN WHO DID STUDY
THEOLOGY. AS THERE WAS A
DISCUSSION. ALL BETWEEN THE
RELIGIOUS AUTHORITIES THE CHURCH
AND THE EUROPEAN MONARCHS. THE
INDIANS HAVE SOULS. BECAUSE IF
THEY HAVE SOULS WE CAN'T LEAVE
THEM. IN FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS
EARLIER THERE WAS A DECISION
MADE THAT PEOPLES OF AFRICA DO
NOT HAVE SOULS THERE FOR
JUSTIFICATION WAS ALLOW FOR
THERE IS LATE. SO THEY HAD A BIG
DEBATE IN A TOWN IN SPAIN. AND
THERE WAS NO CLEAR WIN FROM A
LEGAL PERSPECTIVE- ON. THOSE
CLASSES SAID THE NATIVES HAD
INDIGENOUS RIGHT TO THEIR LANDS
AND TO BE TREATED AS FULLY
CAPABLE HUMAN BEINGS. AND THAT
THE ACTIONS OF THE CONQUISTADORS
WERE ON CALL FOR UNJUSTIFIED.
AWESOME SUPPORTERS SAID THAT
THEY DID NOT HAVE SOULS AND THEY
ARE HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE SAFE
BUT THEY HAD BE TREATED WELL AS
SLAVES. AND THE OUTCOME OF THAT
DEBATE WAS I'M NOT A CLEAR WIN.
ALL ACROSS THIS ONE FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE FACT THAT
THEY BELIEVE THE INDIA'S COULD
NOT BE ENSLAVED THAT THEY DID IN
FACT HAVE SOULS. BUT SIMPLE WITH
THE SET ALSO PROVED TO THEM THAT
THE INDIANS WERE LIKE CHILDREN.
HE DID NOT KNOW HOW TO UTILIZE
OUR RESOURCES ARE THEIR LANDS
AND THEY NEED TO BE TAUGHT HOW
TO BE CIVILIZED PEOPLE. DO THE
CONVERSION PROCESS AS WELL. SO
THAT THE ROLE OF THE CHURCH AND
THE STATE WOULD BE TO BE THEIR
PARENTS. AS THOUGH THEY WERE
CHILDREN AND THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
THEN TO TAKE OVER THE PROPERTY
NEAR RESOURCES FOR THEIR BENEFIT
. AND SO SPAIN THEN WE'LL
DEVELOP A SERIES OF. METHODS TO
DO THE CONVERSION IS
CIVILIZATION IN US ARE WE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE WILL FALL
UNDERNEATH THE LAST OF THREE
HUNDRED YEARS OF EXPERIMENTATION
CALL THE MISSION PROCEEDING-
PUBLIC COMPLEX MISSIONS WERE
CREATED TO GIVE THE STORY OF
RELIGION. AND THEN TO GET THE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE CAUGHT THE
PRESIDIO WAS FOR IT THAT WOULD
GIVE GLORY TO THE STATE AND THE
PUBLIC VIEW THAT HOME WHICH
WOULD BE THE BENEFIT OF THESE
CONVERTERS CIVILIZED INDIA'S.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SEE IN FLORIDA
PARTS OF THE SOUTHWEST AND IN
CALIFORNIA. YEAH SINCE WHICH TO
THEENGLISH SIDE VERY QUICKLY
BECAUSE THEY- WILL CHOOSE TO
FOLLOW CONVERGENCE OF ALLIES WAS
ALWAYS QUESTIONABLE DUCATION
CALIFORNIA. V. BECAUSE THEY WERE
NOT MONOLITHIC MEDIAN ALL
CATHOLIC COUNTRIES IN EUROPE AND
ENGLAND WAS SPLIT BETWEEN- THE
PURITAN MOVEMENT SPLIT BETWEEN
THE REF- THE CHURCH OF ENGLAND
THE REMNANTS OF THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH THAT WAS TRYING TO
SURVIVE THERE. THERE IS SO EACH
OF THE COMPANIES WILL HAVE A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT TAKE ON IT
BECAUSE OF WHATEVER THE
RELATIONSHIP IS TO THE
PARTICULAR PROTESTANT VERSION
THAT THEY BELIEVE YEAH. BUT WHAT
IS INTERESTING IS THE- THOSE WHO
AT THE NEW ENGLAND AREA. THEY
WILL IMPACT QUICKLY UPON THE
TRIBAL PEOPLES THERE THIS ONE IN
PARTICULAR WHO'S REALLY FAMOUS
HE'S FROM THE MOHEGAN TRIBE HIS
NAME WAS SAMPSON WELCOME. AND HE
WILL CHOOSE TO CONVERT TO
PRESBYTERIANISM HE'LL GO TO A
SCHOOL ESTABLISHED BY THE CHURCH
THERE BECOME AN ORDAINED
PRESBYTERIAN MINISTER ALL BECOME
AN EXCELLENT- BE A LOADED AS
SCHOLAR OF THE BIBLE HE WILL HE
WILL WRITE PARTS OF THE BIBLE IN
HIS NATIVE LANGUAGE HE WILL ON.
PREACH THE GOODNESS OF
CHRISTIANITY. AND THEN HE SLOWLY
LEARNS THAT IF HE ALTHOUGH HE
HAS OPTED TO BECOME CIVILIZED
AND CONVERTED. O ENGLISH
PERSPECTIVES. THAT HE IS NOT ONE
OF THEM HE IS NOT REALLY AS
CHILD A SON OF GOD THAT HE IS
SOMEONE WHO IS. ON THE VERY
SECONDARY IN INCONSEQUENTIAL.
AND HE- WANTS TO CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE IN THE GOODNESS OF THE
CHRISTIAN GOD BUT HE CONDEMNS.
THAT PRACTICES OF CHRISTIANITY
BY HIS FELLOW CHRISTIAN
MINISTERS AND THEIR
CONGREGATIONS AND HE WILL MOVE
WITH HIS PEOPLE IN OTHER INDIANS
TO CREATE A FREE TOWN WHERE THEY
CAN PRACTICE CHRISTIAN
PRINCIPLES BUT ALSO CONVERT TO
OUR LAND TO RETURN TO THEIR
TRADITIONAL WAYS OF. COMMON LAND
HOLDING FOR EXAMPLE OF COMMUNAL
SHARING IS. AND SO YOU HAVE TO
HELP ME WITH THAT ENGLISH. THEIR
CONVERGENCE OF ALLIES IS TO GO
OUT AND SELECT KEEP PEOPLE.
AMONG THE OF. LEADERSHIP OF THE
TRIBES TO COVER CIVILIZE THEM
AND TO BRING BACK THEIR ELEMENTS
OF CHRISTIANITY BUT THEY HAD
ALSO THINK THEY WERE WORTHY YET
BECAUSE WE ALSO HAVE THE FAMOUS
LANGUAGE OF THE INDIANS WERE
THE- HISPANA SATAN THAT COMES
FROM SOME OF THE PURITAN METHOD.
LEADERS AS WELL. SO THERE'S BEEN
A VERY SO WHERE DO WE GET THIS I
DO NEED TO CONVERT THE CIVILIZED
INDIANS EDUCATE INDIA'S IS IT IS
GOING TO COME FROM THE DOCTOR
DISCOVERY. IS GOING TO COME THIS
IDEA THAT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
JUSTIFY BEFORE THE EYES OF GOD.
THAT WE HAVE A RIGHT TO BE HERE
AND BECAUSE- WE ARE HERE. WILL
BRING THESE ISSUES TO THE POINT
WHERE WE ARE SO FAR AHEAD OF
THEM IN CIVILIZATION CAN BRING
THEM. MORE FURRY ROCKS- DISEASE
TAKES ITS TOLL. EVENTUALLY WE
HAVE THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
BOARDING SCHOOLS. NOW BOARDING
SCHOOLS AS WE UNDERSTAND THEM
TODAY DIDN'T EXIST PRIOR TO
THEIR ACTUAL ESTABLISHMENT BUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE FOREMOST
ALBERTA BOARDING SCHOOLS UNDER
THE FEDERAL SYSTEM. A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THAT- SOME OF
THE IVY LEAGUE SCHOOLS ON THE
EAST COAST HARBOR IS ONE
EXAMPLE. HAS PART OF THEIR
CHARTER TO YOU KNOW CONVERT IN
TO EDUCATE INDIA AND SEND THE
DISSEMINATE RIGHT AND ONE OF THE
EARLIEST AUDITORIUMS IS OF THEIR
GRADUATE DO YOU FEEL THE OLOGY
SCHOOL STUDENTS WOULD BE AMERICA
WOULD BE AN AMERICAN INDIAN I
THINK FROM. MARTHA'S VINEYARD IF
I REMEMBER CORRECTLY. BUT WHAT
WE'RE ABOUT HERE TODAY IS VERY
UNIVERSAL APPROACH TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO. BRING
INDIANS TO THE POINT OF
CONVERSION IN CIVILIZATION AT
THIS POINT TIME OUR COUNTRY IS
PRIMARILY WHITE ABLE SAXON
PROTESTANT. SO THE VERSIONS OF
CHRISTIANITY FOR US ARE GOING TO
BE PROSTITUTES AND FOR A VERY
BRIEF PERIOD OF TIME- CHURCHES
COULD ACTUALLY PETITION IT
BECOME FEDERAL BOARDING SCHOOLS
BUT THERE WAS A WILD CRAZY
OUTCRY AGAINST THIS THE MIXING
OF CHURCH AND STATE SO THEY
SEPARATED IT. BUT THE PRINCIPLES
THE TENNIS OF PROTESTANT
CHRISTIANITY WERE VERY
FOUNDATIONAL TO THE RUNNING OF
THE SCHOOLS. AND THE VERY SIMPLE
PURPOSE IS TO CONVERT SYMBOLIZES
INDIA'S TURN AMERICAN WAY OF
LIFE. A CAPTAIN CRACKED IS GIVEN
AND- RECOGNITION AS BEING THE
ORIGINAL FOUNDER OF THE SPECIAL
BOARDING SCHOOL SYSTEM THE START
AT CARLISLE INDIAN SCHOOL. AND
HIS FAMOUS QUOTE IS THAT YOU
SAVE THE U. YOU SAVE THE MAN
KILLING THE INDIA AND SO HE'LL
MOVE AHEAD WITH THAT. CONFORMITY
IS ON REQUIRED IN THE BOARDING
SCHOOLS AND THAT THE HORRIBLE
THINGS THAT HAPPENED WERE WERE
VERY TRUE PUBLIC BEATINGS FOR
SPEAKING THE TRIBAL LANGUAGES-
MOCHRIE AND- OF THEIR WAYS OF
LIFE HOW THEY LIVE HOW THEY WORK
TO HELP THE HOUSES THEY LIVED
IN. AND OF COURSE YOU'VE GOT THE
HAIR CUT THEY HAD TO WEAR
UNIFORMS. DISLOCATION FROM THEIR
HOMES- OF FORCIBLE REMOVAL FROM
THEIR HOMES. SOMETIMES WHEN THEY
DISCOVER THAT THEY LIVE TOO
CLOSE TO THE TRADITIONAL
HOMELANDS THEY KNEW THEY HAD TO
THEN TAKE CHILDREN FAR AWAY AND
THEY DID SOMETIMES A THOUSAND
MILES AWAY THEORETICALLY
STUDENTS COULD GO HOME BUT THEY
HAD TO GET PERMISSION TO DO IT.
PARENTS CAN SHOW UP IN THE
COMPLIANCE THE KIDS WEREN'T
THERE. OF SOMERS THEY CAN GO
HOME OF THE ONE OF THE CULT
AUDIENCE IN THESE OUTINGS WOULD
LIVE WITH FAMILIES THAT WOULD
TEACH THEM YOU KNOW THE BENEFITS
OF RUNNING IT A PERFECT. WHITE
HOUSEHOLD. SO THAT THAT BUT.
INDIA'S RESISTED. OUR CHILDREN
RESISTANCE AND IF YOU THINK OF
YOUR OWN CHILDREN AT HOME HOW
OFTEN DO THEY FIND A WAY TO GET
AROUND YOUR RULES I REMEMBER MY
FATHER TELLING. YOU THAT- I
COULD NOT- WEAR MAKE UP EIGHTH
GRADE AND I WAS GOING TO THE
MISSION SCHOOL A DAY SCHOOL AND
NOW. SO I FIGURED OUT YOU KNOW
WELL ALL THE STATEMENTS OF
BERRIES AND I'LL GET THE
CHARCOAL MIX IT WITH A LITTLE
BIT OF WAX AND- YOU KNOW PUT
MASCARA ON MY EYEBROWS AND- EYES
AND A DAD I DID NOT USE ANY MAKE
UP I USE THE NATURAL PRODUCTS OF
LIFE. SO YOU KNOW HIS KIDS FIND
WAYS TO GET AROUND THE RULES IN
THE INDIAN KIDS DID IT- THEY
SLOW DOWN THEIR PROGRESS
DELIBERATELY. THE CLASS LATE
TURN IN ASSIGNMENTS LATE. ONE
AWAY WHICH OFTEN TIMES HAD
TRAGIC CONSEQUENCES. ON THE LINE
SINCE WITH EACH OTHER.
PROTECTIVE VALUE THE MOST WEEK-
TRIBES THAT WERE FORMER ENEMIES
THEY LEARN TO OVERCOME THEIR
DIFFERENCES TO A CERTAIN DEGREE
CREATE A PAN INDIAN ISM. I TELL
MY STUDENTS THAT THE IRONY OF
THE BOARDING SCHOOL WHICH WAS
INTENDED TO WIPE OUT TRIBAL
IDENTITY. AND TO DIMINISH THE
CONNECTION TO HOME AND HOMELANDS
. IT BACKFIRED BECAUSE THE
INDIAN BOARDING SCHOOL WASN'T
INTENDED BUT THE INDIAN BOARDING
SCHOOLS BECAME LIKE THE ELITE
BOARDING SCHOOLS OF EUROPE AND
AMERICA. IT'S ONLY THE BEST OF
THE BEST LOOK TO THOSE SCHOOLS
THEY CREATED THEIR ALLIANCES
THEIR MARRIAGES THEY SHARE THEIR
POWER AND THEIR RESOURCES THEY
CREATED COMMUNICATION NETWORK
AND PUT THE STRESS ON
COMMUNICATION AND NETWORK. THESE
INDIAN KIDS LEFT THE BOARDING
SCHOOLS AND THOSE WHO WENT HOME
AND WERE SIXTH IN ALL WERE ABLE
TO RE ESTABLISH THE
RELATIONSHIPS THEY CREATED A
NETWORK. EVENT NETWORK HULU
TOGETHER SO NO MATTER WHAT OUR
TRIBAL DIFFERENCES. WE CAN FORM
ALLIANCES AND RELATIONSHIPS THAT
WILL CARRY US THROUGH THE WORST
OF WHATEVER THE AMERICANS HAVE
TO GIVE TO US WASN'T EXPECTED TO
STRENGTHEN THE ROOTS OF THE
TRIBAL PEOPLES. CREATED TRIBAL
IDENTITIES WHERE YOU WERE NOT
JUST ONE TRIBE MAYBE SEVERAL OF
MY GRANDPARENTS MET SHERMAN
INDIAN HIGH SCHOOL DIFFERENT
TRIBES CAME TOGETHER. ON
EXPECTED THAT THERE'S SO MUCH
LITERATURE ON THE HORSE A
BOARDING SCHOOL THAT ARM. YEAH
YOU NEED TO READ IT YOU CAN. THE
DOWNSIDE SO BUT YOU KNOW BESIDES
WONDERFUL BEING ABANDONED USE
THE DOWNSIDE IS THAT THEY DIDN'T
HAVE GOOD ROLE MODELS AMONG
ADULTS. SO IT MADE IT DIFFICULT
WHEN THEY BECAME ADULTS HOW TO
BECOME A FAMILY IN THAT RESPECT
OTHER RAISE YOUR CHILDREN IN
THAT RESPECT. OF THOSE VERY
EARLY YEARS SOME OF THEM YOU
KNOW EXPERIENCED ACTUAL WARFARE
THEY SAW THE TRAUMA OF HAVING
PEOPLE. GUIDED BEFORE THEIR
EYEBALLS ON. SO THAT TAT DOES
DOES DOWNSIZE THAT ARE VERY VERY
REAL. IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
THE KENNEDY ADMINISTRATION DID A
STUDY. OF YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON IN OUR FEDERAL INDIAN
BOARDING SCHOOLS IN INDIAN
COUNTRY IN GENERAL AND THEY ALSO
HAD A STUDY OF EDUCATION. AND
THAT DOES THAT STUDY SAID WE
NEED TO CLOSE THESE BODIES
CLOSED OUT NOW. BECAUSE THE BOYS
BECAUSE IT HAPPENED ACTUALLY
MUCH EARLIER THE IDEA BUT THE
LIMITATION HAS NOT REALLY TAKEN
PLACE. AND THOSE FORTY SCHOOLS A
STATE EXISTENCE THE CURRICULUM
HAD TO GO THROUGH A RADICAL
REVISION. AND THAT'S HOW JUNIOR
SHERMAN STARTED ON THE
GENERATION AHEAD OF ME THEY
FOUGHT THE BATTLE THEY GOT THEY
GOT
WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO THIS TO
REPRESENT THE SOUTHERN TRIBES IN
CALIFORNIA AND I HAPPENED AND I
WAS SELECTED NICE I BECAME ONE
OF THE THREE CALIFORNIA INDIANS
WHO THEN REPRESENTED. THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE SHERMAN ARE
INDIAN SCHOOL BOARD. AND THEN
THE REMAINING CANDIDATES ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD FOR THE MOST
POPULAR OF ALL OF. THE LARGEST
TRIBES AT THE SCHOOL SO WE HAD
NOW TO HOLD APACHES. UP HE WAS-
TO NAME SOME OF THE TRIBES THAT
WERE THERE AND WE WORK TOGETHER
TO REVIEW THE CURRICULUM TO
INTRODUCE NEW CURRICULUM. AND TO
TRY TO IMPLEMENT THE RIGHTS OF
THE CHILDREN IN THE RIGHTS OF
THE TRIBES WITH THE SCHOOL
BOARD. AND IT WAS ROCKY BECAUSE
AT FIRST THE FORMER SCHOOL BOARD
WHERE THEY WERE. SOMEWHAT IN
EXISTENCE MORE LIKE RUBBER
STAMPS. ALL ALL PROBLEM. THIS IS
THE PERSONAL OPINION A PROBLEM
WITHIN THE FEDERAL SYSTEM IS
THAT OUT. OF WHAT CAN BE TEN YOU
KNOW SHORT OF LIKE DO SOME
EGREGIOUS OFFENSE OF HORRIBLE
CRYING YOU CONSPIRACY THERE
FOREVER AND DO YOUR JOB- SO THAT
GETTING PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS THE SCHOOLS WITH THE
HOMES OF THE KIDS. AT ALL WAS TO
MAKE THE MEN'S NOT JUST GOOD
CITIZENS GOOD TRAVEL SO SINCE
AND GOOD PEOPLE SKILLS AND
ABILITIES TO TRANSFER ON THE
CALL AGENTS TO DO WHATEVER IS
NEEDED FOR THEIR TRIBE. THAT IS
BASICALLY WE GOTTA GET UP TO
SCHOOL. AND WHATEVER WILL MAKE
IT WORK WILL WORK. WE HAD ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO. ALL WOULDN'T
TÍNH THE SUBSTITUTE. OF SPORTS
AND ON PHYSICAL EDUCATION OR
ENGLISH CREDITS. BECAUSE ALL
THEY HAD TO DO WAS SHOW THE
NUMBER OF CREDITS THAT THEY DID
YOU GRADUATE THAT KIND OF THING
SO THE FOCUS IS A GREEN CREDIT
OF ACCRUING CRESTING GRADUATE
BUT NOT NECESSARILY FEELS THAT
WOULD MAKE YOU- A WELL EDUCATED
PERSON. CRICKET THE CAMPUSES ARE
NOT WELL KEPT UP BUT THAT'S
IRONY OF IT. AND THIS IS THE- AS
IN PART IS THAT. THE KIDS OF THE
MID TO LATE TWENTIETH CENTURY
LIKE THE KIDS FROM A HUNDRED
YEARS EARLIER. THEY TOOK WHAT
THE SCHOOL HAD TO MAKE IT WORK
FOR THEM. AND I GUESS MY STORY
HERE FOR YOU IS NOT TO DWELL ON
THE HOLDERS OF THE BOARDING
SCHOOLS NOT TO DWELL ON WHAT IT
TOOK AWAY SO MUCH AS TO SHOW HOW
OBEY ME THE CHILDREN THEMSELVES
GAINED IT BACK IT'S NOT IT
WASN'T A PERFECT SYSTEM THERE'S
STILL WERE PROBLEMS THERE- BUT-
IT'S CHAU THE INADEQUACIES ALSO.
AND THAT AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU SO TO
SUM IT UP BECAUSE I THINK MY
FIFTEEN MINUTES OF. HAVE
EXCEEDED. YOU NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
THE DOCTOR DISCOVERY WITH THIS
FUNDAMENTAL BELIEF IT HAD A
RIGHT TO THE LAND. THE ONLY WAY
TO JUSTIFY FOR THE EYES OF
BEFORE THE EYES OF A BOD ARE THE
STATE ITSELF WE'RE TWO DIFFERENT
. THE INDIANS. THEN THAT
EUROPEAN NATIONS FOUGHT AMONGST
THEMSELVES OVER WHOSE CONVERSION
TO WHOSE GOD WHO CIVILIZATION.
AND THEN THAT WOULD JUSTIFY THE
TAKING OF THE LAND AND THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE PEOPLE IN
THIS VALUES. BECAUSE THEY WOULD
BECOME LIKE THEM BUT THE RD IS
THAT EVEN WHEN THEY ATTEMPT TO
DO THAT THE INDIANS SAM'S IN
OAKLAND BEING ONE PERSON AS AN
EXAMPLE. THEY ARE NOT SUFFICIENT
IN THE EYES OF THOSE WHO TOOK
THE LAND. IN MY EXPERIENCE IT'S
GERMAN WAS THAT. THE KIDS WERE
GOING TO MAKE IT WORK DESPITE
THE SYSTEM ITSELF. BUT EVEN WITH
THEIR- EFFORTS IN WITH AN INDIAN
SCHOOL BOARD. IT WAS DIFFICULT
TO FIGHT THAT INGRAINED BELIEVE
THAT YOU ARE INFERIOR PEOPLE
WILL HELP YOU WITH WHAT YOU NEED
TO MAKE IN THE WORLD BUT NOT TO
BE AN EQUAL AT OUR TABLE. THANK
YU. THANK YOU I'M A PROFESSOR
DIXON- FOR THOSE SOME
EDUCATIONAL AND INSIGHTFUL WORDS
ARE COMING FROM- CALIFORNIANS
PERSON A STEAM DOES YOURSELF
FROM PALMA INDIAN RESERVATION- I
WANNA WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBERS-
WENDY CARILLO AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE LOOKING ARAMBULA FOR
JOINING US AS WE- CONTINUE WITH
OUR FIRST PANEL. THE EVOLUTION
OF NATIVE AMERICANS AND
EDUCATION THE ROLE OF BOARDING
SCHOOLS AND THE EFFORT TO STRIP
NATIVE AMERICANS OF THEIR
LANGUAGE AND CULTURE. OUR NEXT-
SPEAKER- IS AMANDA WIXEN- MISS
WIXEN IS SHERMAN INDIAN MUSEUM
HISTORIAN AND UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE DOCTORAL
CANDIDATE SHEESH SERVES AS
ASSISTANT CURATOR AT SHERMAN
INDIAN MUSEUM AND RIVERSIDE. AND
AS AN ASSOCIATE CURATOR AT THE
AUTRY MUSEUM OF THE AMERICAN
WEST IN LOS ANGELES. SHE IS A CO
EDITOR OF TWO RECENT BOOKS ABOUT
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN ACTIVISTS
WOULD DOCTOR CLEAR RICH CLIFFORD
TRAVIS- AND DR DONNA AKERS
WIXOM'S RESEARCH FOCUSES ON
SHERMAN INSTITUTE NOW CALLED
SHERMAN INDIAN HIGH SCHOOL AND
MATH. POLLUTION USED TO
SYMBOLIZE NATIVE YOUTH IN THE
EARLY TWENTIETH CENTURY SHE IS
AN ENROLLED TRIBAL CITIZEN OF
THE CHICKASAW. NATION IN
OKLAHOMA. M. MY NOSE SAY THAT
SHE WAS TO BE HERE IN PERSON SO
YOU COULD COME UP TO THE TO THE
DIETS HERE. THANK YOU. SMALL
INCREMENTAL EXTENSION HE GUESSED
HIGH UP. OR THEY HAVE TO BE HERE
I'M ACTUALLY WANTED JUST A
PURPOSE THIS I'M AT THE REQUEST
OF LAWRENCE'S WALK. WAS THE
CULTURAL TRADITIONS LITERATURE
INDIAN HIGH SCHOOL AND ALSO I
MEAN MY MUSEUM DIRECTOR. CAN IS
IT WORKING YES GOOD OKAY- I'M
HERE FOR LEARNING CISCO THE CALL
FOR LEADER AND ME DIRECTOR
SHERMAN INDIAN HIGH SCHOOL AND I
KNOW SHE VERY MUCH WANTED TO BE
HERE TODAY BUT COULDN'T SO I
JUST WANTED TO MENTION FOR- SO.
WE CAN BEGIN- THE FOR THREE
YEARS THE DOMINANT EUROPEAN
AMERICAN SOCIETY AND STRUGGLE TO
FIND A SOLUTION TO THEIR INDIAN
PROBLEM. DESPITE DEVASTATING
POPULATION DECLINES DUE TO
DISEASE WAR REMOVAL NATIVE
PEOPLES PERSISTENT. DURING THE
PROGRESSIVE ERA EUROPEAN
AMERICANS OF THE DOMINANT
SOCIETY DECIDED THE INDIANS MUST
ASSIMILATE ENJOINED QUOTE
CIVILIZED SOCIETY. BY TARGETING
NATIVE YOUTH AND REMOVING THEM
FROM THEIR COMMUNITIES TO OFFERS
OF RUSSIAN INSTITUTIONS THE NON
NATIVE PUBLIC HOPE TO A RACE
NATIVE IDENTITY AND REPLACE IT
WITH THE CONCEPT OF THE IDEAL
INDIAN. EXIDE PLEASE- ALL READ
THAT OUT I GUESS OF THE HISTORY
OF INDIAN BOARDING SCHOOLS AS
DOCTOR DIXON MENTIONED- SORT
BEGAN IN THE SEVENTEENTH CENTURY
WITH THE JESUIT MISSIONARIES
WE'RE KIND OF THE PRECURSORS TO
THE BOARDING SCHOOLS UNTIL
NINETEEN SEVENTY MANY MISSIONS
WILL DIRECTLY SUBSIDIZED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. ROSE WILL
SYSTEM WAS ESTABLISHED IN THE
EIGHTEEN SIXTIES AND WE'VE HEARD
THE HEARD OF ARMY OFFICER
RICHARD HENRY PRATT WHO WAS
INSPIRED BY HIS EXPERIENCE WITH
INDIAN PRISONERS IN FORT MARION
FLORIDA- HE BELIEVE THE TRUE
ASSIMILATION FOR INDIANS WOULD
ONLY COME BY KILLING WHAT WAS
INDIAN. WITHIN A MAN TO SAVE
HIM. HE SUCCESSFULLY ADVOCATED
FOR FEDERAL POSITION BOARDING
SCHOOL FACILITY TO BE THROUGH
ISOLATION EDUCATION AND LABOR.
THE FIRST FRONT OFFERED UP
RESERVATION FOR JUST ONE
CARLISLE WAS ESTABLISHED IN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE. AND THEIR
PRATT AIM TO PHYSICALLY
IDEOLOGICALLY AND EMOTIONALLY
REMOVE INDIAN CHILDREN FROM
THEIR FAMILIES HOMES AND TRIBAL
AFFILIATIONS. AT SCHOOL THEY
COULD NOT BE INDIAN IN ANYWAY
CULTURALLY ARTISTICALLY
SPIRITUALLY OR LINGUISTICALLY.
AND THIS WAY CARLISLE AND OTHER
INDIAN BOARDING SCHOOLS WERE KEY
COMPONENTS IN THE PROCESS OF
CULTURAL GENOCIDE AGAINST NATIVE
CULTURES. IN THE FOLLOWING TWO
DECADES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ESTABLISHED AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
FOUR INDIAN OFFERS A VISION
BOARDING SCHOOLS. AND I PUT THE
SLIDE UP HERE THIS COMES FROM
OUR OWN STATUTES OF CALIFORNIA
BELIEVE IN NINETEEN OH NINE.
THERE IS IN THIS CONTEXT THAT
SHERMAN WAS ESTABLISHED THIS
IDEA OF EXCLUSION. THAT CHILDREN
COULD BE SEPARATED FOR VICIOUS
VICIOUS AND FILTHY BEHAVIORS.
BECAUSE THEY WERE DIRTY. AND
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN. AND I
THINK THAT'S THE SIMPLE THING TO
SEE IN WRITING YOU KNOW THAT THE
STATUS OF CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY
HAVE THIS KIND OF GARBAGE AT THE
TIME. SO NINETEEN OH ONE. CAN
YOU PUT THE NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
IN NINETEEN OH ONE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ESTABLISHED THE LAST
OF THE BOARDING SCHOOLS IN
RIVERSIDE I NINETEEN OH TWO
EIGHTEEN PM A STUDENTS WERE
ENROLLED WITH A HANDFUL OF
MISSION INDIANS ROOM INCREASED
YEAR BY YEAR AND BY NINETEEN A
WEEK SHERMAN HOUSE FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY STUDENTS. EVOKING THE
MISSIONARY OF THE ARCHITECTURE
OF THE SCHOOL SITE ENCOURAGED A
ROMANTICIZED VERSION OF
CALIFORNIA HISTORY ONE THAT DID
NOT REFERENCE THE LOSSES OF
NATIVE PEOPLE UNDER THE SPANISH
FATHERS IN HERE PUT A QUOTE
FROM. CHARLES LEWIS. ACTUALLY
FOUNDER OF THE SOUTHWEST MUSEUM
WHOSE EARLY CALIFORNIA PROMOTER
AND FRIEND OF FRANK MILLER WHO
WAS ALSO A RIVERSIDE PROMOTER.
AND IT SAYS I CAN'T REALLY READ
IT FROM HER- BUT IT TALKS ABOUT
HOW KIND OF- IT FOR MOST SHERMAN
AS A TOURIST DESTINATION FOR
MILLER ALSO ON THE STREETCAR AND
STREAKER ENDED RIGHT IN FRONT OF
SHERMAN SO YOU COULD GO SPEND
THE DAY LOOKING AT INDIANS AND
HE ADVERTISES HERE. WHAT A
BETTER WAY THAT TO SEE INDIANS
IT'S SO CHEAP THERE SO CLOSE
HERE THEY ARE TEAMED AND
DOMICILE SO THIS IS AN OPEN
ADVERTISEMENT FOR PEOPLE FROM
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA TO GO LOOK
AT INDIA'S KIND ON THEIR MARCH
TO CIVILIZATION. A COULD YOU THE
DANCE IS LIKE. SIX SHERMAN
MINISTRATION FILL THE STUDENTS
DAILY LIVES WITH WORK AND
ACTIVITIES THE CURRICULUM
INCLUDED A BASIC LEVEL OF
ACADEMIC LEARNING ARITHMETIC
HISTORY GEOGRAPHY SPELLING AND
READING HOWEVER THE VOCATIONAL
TRAINING PROGRAMS CONSUME MOST
OF THE STUDENTS TIME FLOOR
HISTORIES WE KNOW NOW EVEN
THOUGH OSTENSIBLY THEY WERE
SPLIT HALF DAY HALF ACADEMIC
HALF OCCASIONAL REALLY WASN'T
THE CASE IT WAS MORE LIKE AN
HOUR TO TWO HOURS OF
RUDIMENTARY. RUDIMENTARY
ACADEMICS AND THE REST WAS WORK
FROM FIVE IN THE MORNING TO TEN
PM CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS FOUR
YEARS OLD WORKED. OF FEMALE
STUDENTS WERE LIMITED TO
DOMESTIC SCIENCES WHILE MALE
STUDENTS DID I EVER CULTURAL
WORK PRINTING BLACKSMITHING
PRINTING I'M SORRY. THE PAINTING
CARPENTRY AND SHOEMAKING.
STUDENTS ALSO WORK BAKER SAID TO
KEEP THE SCHOOL OPERATING
COOKING GARDENING TENDING TO ALL
THE ANIMALS ALL THE OTHER MANUAL
LABOR INCLUDING WATCHING. THE
CHILDREN THIS THIS TEACHERS.
CHILDREN AS WELL. AS AN
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES
STUDENTS WERE ENCOURAGED TO JOIN
SCHOOL APPROVED CLUBSAND
SOCIETIES LIKE THE MANDARIN CLUB
AND THE LITERARY SOCIETY. SPORTS
ALSO PLAYED A LARGE PART OF THE
SMOKE SCHOOL PROGRAM WITH SPORTS
TEAMS REGULARLY COMPETING
AGAINST AREA SCHOOLS. A SCHOOL
OFFICIALS AND REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE OFFICE OF INDIAN AFFAIRS
LAID THE CORNERSTONE OF SHERMAN
INSTITUTE IN NINETEEN OH ONE
LIKE I MENTIONED. AND THE EVENT
LIKE I SAID GROUP- DREW OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND SPECTATORS OF
THIS KIND OF SPECTACLE CARRIED
ON THROUGH THE EARLY HISTORY OF
SHERMAN. EVERY SUNDAY THEY WOULD
FIGHT THE COMMUNITY THE
RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY WOULD COME
TO WATCH THIS. REAL AND OFTEN
SEEN FROM NEWS ON NEWS COVERAGE
THAT THEY ACTUALLY. TOLD THE NON
NATIVE AUDIENCE THEY NEED TO NOT
BE SO ROWDY AND TO CALM DOWN
BECAUSE THEY WERE ACTUALLY THE
ONES THAT WERE KIND OF OUT OF
CONTROL IN THESE LITTLE PUBLIC
DISPLAYS. COULD YOU. FOR THE
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO SHERMAN.
ALSO LIEBHARD OUTSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL AS PART OF THE
CONTROVERSIAL OUTING PROGRAM
LOCAL LIKE CHRISTIAN FAMILIES
HIRED SHERMAN STUDENTS FOR
VARYING LENGTHS OF TIME
SOMETIMES YEAR ROUND TO PERFORM
VARIOUS TASKS. CHORES AND OTHER
KINDS OF MANUAL WORK. FOR
SHERMAN STUDENTS THE PRICE OF
CIVILIZATION. STEEP BOYS WORKING
IN THE GROWTH OF RIVERSIDE OFTEN
LIVED IN POOR HOUSES AND WORKED
IN DANGEROUS CONDITIONS. ALL
GIRLS UNDER TO FORM OF CULTURAL
ISOLATION IN THE HOMES OF LOCAL
WHITE FAMILIES. LIVING AND
WORKING WITHOUT THE COMPANY OF
OTHER STUDENTS. AND I THINK IT'S
A GOOD TIME TO MENTION THIS KIND
OF STATISTICS THAT IT'S PRETTY
WELL KNOWN STATISTIC BUT BY
NINETEEN HUNDRED. TWENTY
THOUSAND NATIVE CHILDREN WERE IN
BOARDING SCHOOLS. BY NINETY
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THOUSAND
NATIVE CHILDREN WERE BOARDING
SCHOOLS AND BY NINETEEN TWENTY
SIX NEARLY EIGHTY THREE PERCENT.
OF ALL INDIAN SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN WERE IN BOARDING
SCHOOLS. SO THAT'S A PRETTY
POWERFUL STATISTIC- YOU KNOW
THERE'S NARY A FAMILY IN INDIA A
COUNTRY THAT HASN'T BEEN
AFFECTED BY BOARDING SCHOOLS TO
SOME EXTENT. COULD YOU THAT'S
EXCITING. HERE'S A PICTURE TO OF
THE GROVES AND KIND OF THIS
SMUDGING THAT WAS TAKING PLACE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
KIDS YOU KNOW. A LOT OF TIMES
ONE OF THE REASONS CITED FOR
MOVING STUDENTS FROM REMOTING
MAYBE CHILDREN FROM THEIR
COMMUNITIES WAS HEALTH. ACCEPTED
SHERMAN A LOT OF THE BOYS IN IT
BEFORE WORKING IN THESE- YOU
KNOW POLLUTION LADEN. GROSS
HOWEVER AS MANY. NATIVE SCHOLARS
AND HAVE WRITTEN PASSED IN AND
SHARE THEIR STORIES THE GIRLS
ALSO PRIOR PROVIDED AN
OPPORTUNITYFOR THEM TO SPEAK
THEIR LANGUAGES. TO SING THEIR
SONGS AND- A PATH FOR STUDENTS
TO SORT OF GET A LITTLE BIT
RELIEF FROM THE CONSTANT
SURVEILLANCE THAT THEY WERE
UNDER ANDERSON AT SHERMAN. HE-
NEXT PLEASE. SO ANOTHER PART
ANOTHER KIND OF IMPORTANT PART
OF THE PROGRAM WAS THE ART
PROGRAM IN THE EARLY TWENTIETH
CENTURY THE U. S. FEDERAL
POLICIES REGARDING THE
PROTECTION OF NATIVE AMERICAN
ART IN OFF RESERVATION BOARDING
SCHOOLS SHIFTED FROM SUPPRESSION
TO ACTIVE ENGAGEMENT SEEN AS A
PATH TO ECONOMIC STABILITY IT
MEASURES MINISTRATIONS PUSHED
OUR STUDENTS TO CAPITALIZE ON
THE ARTISTIC TRADITIONS OF
NATIVE CULTURES. ALTHOUGH THIS
PUSH LED TO SOME RETENTION OF A
FEW CULTURAL PRACTICES TEACHERS
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY OFTEN EXPLOITED
STUDENT TOP TALENT FOR PROFIT.
SEEKING THIS PROFIT STUDENTS
MADE SO CALLED INDIAN ART OFTEN
NOT FROM THEIR COMMUNITY. AND
WITHOUT THE GUIDANCE IN THE
CULTURALLY COLLECT CARRILLO
CORRECT WAYS TO DO SO. WITHOUT
EXPERIENCED ELDERS STUDENTS DID
NOT LEARN TOGETHER AND PROCESS
MATERIALS FOR BASKETS AND
BLANKETS PROPERLY. AND THE
INTERGENERATIONAL TRANSFER OF
ENVIRONMENTAL KNOWLEDGE THAT HAS
EXISTED FOR CENTURIES WAS
INTERRUPTED. THE CULTURAL
KNOWLEDGE LOSS DURING THIS
PERIOD IS NEARLY INCALCULABLE.
PLEASE NEXT SIGN. A RELIGIOUS
PROGRAMMING WAS ALSO AN
IMPORTANT PART OF SHERMAN
ALTHOUGH THIS THERE THE BOARDING
SCHOOLS WERE INITIALLY STARTED
IN SORT OF AN ANTI CATHOLIC
FERVOR FROM THE EAST COAST- AND
TOGETHER FOR FROM THE EAST COAST
IT WAS SOON RECOGNIZED THAT
BECAUSE OF THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA THAT THEY NEEDED TO
COMPETE WITH SOMEWHERE SPECIALLY
WITH OTHER BOARDING SCHOOLS LIKE
ST BONIFACE WHICH ARE OPERATED
BY THE CATHOLIC SCHOOLS. SO UPON
ENTERING SHERMAN WAS STUDENTS
COULD CHOOSE TO BE PROTESTANT OR
CATHOLIC NO OTHER OPTIONS. AND
YOUR LOCAL CHURCHES INCLUDING
RIVERSIDE WHICH IS KNOWN AS KIND
OF A CITY OF CHURCHES COMPETED
FOR STUDENT INVOLVEMENT STUDENT
ATTENTION- THERE WAS A LOT OF
OUTING PROGRAMS INCLUDING YOU
KNOW SOME SOMEWHAT CONTROVERSIAL
PROGRAMS WITH LOCAL. RIVERSIDE
CITIZENS KIND OF CHECKING OUT
BOYS AND GIRLS TO TAKE THEM FOR
THE EVENING TO DIFFERENT CHURCH
ACTIVITIES. AND THERE'S A
THERE'S LIKE QUITE A BIT WERE
THAT STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE IN
THAT AREA BUT IT'S AN IMPORTANT
OTHER IMPORTANT PART OF KIND OF
THE SELECTION PROCESS. EXIDE THE
PERFORMANCES OF. BASICALLY YES.
THE SHERMAN PRO OF ASSIMILATION
EXTEND TO PERFORMANCES AS WELL.
WITH THE GOAL OF REPLACING
INDIGENOUS CULTURAL PRACTICES
WITH CIVILIZED EUROPEAN AMERICAN
PRACTICES THE ADMINISTRATION
STAGED ELABORATE DISPLAYS OF
INDIANS OBEDIENTLY PARTICIPATING
AND FORMS OF CULTURAL PARITY AND
DEVALUATION. THE PERFORMANCES OF
THIS KIND EMPHASIZE THE LOWER
SOCIAL POSITION OF NATIVE
AMERICANS WHOSE CHILDREN COULD
BE CALLED ON TO PERFORM AT WILL
BOTH INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF
SHERMAN INSTITUTE. SURE
RESIDENTS ALSO PUBLICLY PERFORM
PLAYS DESIGNED TO INTRODUCE NEW
CULTURAL TRADITIONS. THE SCHOOL
REPORTS MANY PROGRAMS DEDICATED
THE FOUNDING FATHERS SUCH AS
THIS ONE WASHINGTON'S HOME
COMING. AND TO ANY NATIVE SPECT
INCLUDING STUDENTS THEMSELVES
THE IMAGE PRESENTS THE ONLY
ACCEPTABLE VERSION OF INDIANS AT
THIS TIME ONE THAT UNDERSTOOD
EUROPEAN AMERICAN CULTURAL
DOMINANCE AND BEHAVED
ACCORDINGLY. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
ALMOST OF SERVICE STUDENTS DID
NOT GRADUATE IN THE EARLY YEARS
THE LENGTH OF TIME SPENT AT
SCHOOL LARGELY DEPENDED ON THE
STUDENTS WILLINGNESS TO CONFORM
AT TIMES STUDENTS LEFT AT THE
INSISTENCE OF THEIR PARENTS
OTHERS WERE SICK AND DIED.
HANDFUL STUDENTS RUN AWAY SUCH
AS FRANCIS MORONGO DELOS REYES
SERRANO- HATED THE CLOSET
TREATMENT AND ESCAPE WALKING
TWENTY MILES TO HER HOME AND
SEVEN WELL. FOR MANY WHO STAYED
IN DURING THE PROLONGED
SEPARATION FROM FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY ACCRUAL FORM OF
PUNISHMENT AWAITED. AFTER STUDY
INDOCTRINATION OF WHITE EUROPEAN
AMERICAN CULTURE. A FORMER
STUDENTS COULD NOT ADJUST TO
LIFE ON THE RESERVATION AND
PURSUE DIFFERENT LIFE WAYS IN
THE CITIES. THERE ARE MANY YOUNG
YOUNG PEOPLE EXPERIENCE EXTREME
FORMS OF RACIAL DISCRIMINATION
DESPITE THEIR TRAINING IN
CIVILIZATION I COULD NO LONGER
DEPEND ON THE SOLACE OF FAMILY
OR COMMUNITY. LIKE
INSTITUTIONALIZED EX PRISONERS
MANY FORMER STUDENTS STRUGGLED
OUTSIDE THE WALLS OF THE PRISON
. SOME STUDENTS PAID THE
ULTIMATE PRICE AND DIED ALONE AT
SHERMAN. AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND AS A PARENT MYSELF I CAN'T
IMAGINE THAT THAT KIND OF PAIN.
OF WE KEEP GOING. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. SO WHAT CHANGED
OBVIOUSLY SHERMAN TODAY IS MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN SHERMAN BEFORE
OTHERS A LOT OF FACTORS HERE SO
OF FEDERAL GOVERNMENT POLICY
CHANGES THERE'S SERIES OF POLICY
CHANGES THAT THAT EFFECTIVENESS
OF THOSE PROCEDURES NEED OF
ACTIVISM A TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY
TRIBAL SUPPORT INCLUDING- LOCAL
TRIBES AND- INSTITUTIONAL AND
COMMUNITY RECOGNITION SO THIS IS
SOMETHING OF COURSE THAT'S
ONGOING AND- I LIKE TO THINK OF.
YOU KNOW SHERMAN OF THEN AND NOW
AS A KIND OF THE PIVOT POINT I
THINK AFTER THE AFTER THE EVENTS
OF THE SIXTIES IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND THEN ALL
THESE EXPRESSIONS OF NATIVE
SOVEREIGNTY TRIBAL SUPPORT- A
LOT OF THESE FORMER STUDENTS
CAME BACK TO SHERMAN AND THAT'S
WHERE YOU SEE THE REAL CHANGE
THE SEACHANGE OF ALL THE NATIVE
STUDENTS CAME BACK TEACHING. AND
EVEN THOUGH SOME OF THE STUFF
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE TEACHERS
MIGHT HAVE BEEN STILL SOMEWHAT
PRO ASSIMILATION IT'S IMPORTANT
TO SEE YOUR OWN FACE AS AN
AUTHORITY FIGURE ESPECIALLY IF
YOU'RE AWAY FROM YOUR FAMILY AND
SO I THINK WE CAN LOOK AT ALL
THIS BUT YOU KNOW THERE'S A
HANDFUL OF EXCEPTIONAL TEACHERS
AND THEN JUST. YOU KNOW LOTS OF
HOUSE STAFF AND OTHER KINDS OF.
I THOUGHT SHERMAN. THAT HAVE
MADE ALL THE- IN CHANGE. THE
PROGRAMMING OF SHERMAN. THE
ATTITUDE OF THE STUDENTS. AND
ALSO AFFECTS WHO COMES TO
SHERMAN SO NOW COURSE. BACK IN
THE DAY IT WAS LIMITED TO TRAIN
TRAVEL HORSE TRAVELING FROM
WHOEVER CAN GET TO SHERMAN. BUT
NOW YOU KNOW WITH THE FLYING YOU
COULD WE HAVE STUDENTS FROM
ALASKA. STUDENTS FROM BACCHAE
STUDENTS THAT. FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS COME BECAUSE THEIR
GRANDPARENTS CAME THEIR FATHERS
CAME- THEY WANT TO SEE THE BEACH
THEY THINK WE'RE CLOSE TO
HOLLYWOOD. KIND OF. THEY WANT
COULD DISNEYLAND THERE'S LOTS OF
DIFFERENT REASONS. BUT OBVIOUSLY
SHERMAN TODAY LOOKS MUCH
DIFFERENT. ACCUSED IT DOESN'T
EXCITE PLEASE. I JUST WANTED TO
SHOW THIS ONE THIS IS THE
GRADUATE SERVE TO THE- SEVENTEEN
SO OBVIOUSLY AS YOU KNOW THAT
FIRST. IMAGE I SHOWED OF THE
NINETEEN OH NINE GRADUATION.
DRESSED IN VICTORIAN DRESS IS
SOMETHING A LOT DIFFERENT. SO WE
THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY TO
CEREMONIES AND THEY HAVE ONE
WHERE THEY WERE YOU KNOW THE
TRADITIONAL EUROPEAN ROPES
MEDIEVAL ROBES BUT THEN THEY
HAVE ANOTHER ONE WHERE THEY WERE
TRAVEL. KALYA AND THEY HAVE ALL
THE FLAGS OF THE NATIONS
REPRESENTATIVE. AND I THINK
THAT. THIS PICTURE REALLY
ENCAPSULATES WHAT SHERMAN HAS
BECOME AND WHAT IT CAN BE IN THE
FUTURE. WITH OUR CONTINUED
ATTENTION AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU- SO MUCH FOR THE AND
INSIGHTFUL- DISCUSSION AND
HISTORY AND AWAKENING RIGHT THE
DIFFERENT- ADVOCACY THAT
CONTINUES TO BE NEED TO BE DONE
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING- A TRIBAL ELDER WHO
IS STILL ON- FRANCIS. MORONGO
WHO HE MADE THE STATEMENT THAT
THE BOARDING SCHOOLS THAT
THERE'S NOT THOSE IN IN
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE THAT
HAVEN'T HAD SOME TYPE OF IMPACT
AND- IT CERTAINLY- OUR ELDER
FRANCIS MORONGO- LEAVING THERE
TO WALK BACK. TO THE RESERVATION
TWENTY MILES- AS WELL AS MY
GRANDMOTHER MARTHA- MANIU-
CICCONE WHO THAT WAS AT ST
BONIFACE AND- WAS- DISCIPLINED
THERE FOR HER UNWILLINGNESS TO.
COMPLY AND THAT'S BEEN
DOCUMENTED- AS FAR AS BEING-
WHIPPED IN SO THAT THESE ARE
TRUE- AREAS THAT HAVE AFFECTED
OUR PEOPLE. BUT ALSO GOING TO
THE LAST LINE OF WHERE WHERE
WHERE YOU FALL INTO BUT WE CAN'T
EVOLVE SO QUICK. WITHOUT
ATTESTING TO THE TRUTH ACTUAL
HISTORY OF WHAT HAS BEEN
INFLICTED UPON OUR PEOPLE. SORT
OF THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
. OUR NEXT- PRESENTER. IS- WAR
SOLDIER SHE IS AN ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR AT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY AND IS AN ENROLLED
MEMBER OF THE CIVIL OF A BAND OF
THE SEGNO INDIANS SHE HAS TAUGHT
ETHNIC STUDIES AT NORTHERN
ARIZONA UNIVERSITY AND HER
RESEARCH AND TEACHING HAS
FOCUSED ON TWENTIETH CENTURY
AMERICAN INDIAN ACTIVISM SOCIAL
AND CULTURAL HISTORY POLITICS
EDUCATION AND SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
SHE'LL BE JOINING US VIRTUALLY
THE SEE IF- IF SHE'S. ABLE TO GO
NOW. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I AM
TRYING TO SHARE MY SCREEN BUT I
DON'T SEEM TO HAVE THAT OPTION.
RIGHT NOW. LET'S SEE IF
PERMITTED. THERE YOU WE SEE YOU
. RIGHT I HAVE A PRESENTATION AS
WELL I THINK NOW IT'S SHOWING UP
OKAY. SO LET ME GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED- SO TO FORTY AGAIN I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JAMES TROUBLES OUT FOR
THE INVITATION AND ALSO
RECOGNIZE ALL THE- GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS WHO ARE PRESENT I
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT THIS
ISSUE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT- IS
DEEPLY PERSONAL AS A PRODUCT OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS- BUT
IN ADDITION THIS IS WHAT I'VE
SPENT YEARS RESEARCHING- AND- I
REALLY. APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT-
CALIFORNIA INDIANS IN THE PUBLIC
EDUCATIONAL SCHOOL SYSTEM IN
ADDITION I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE- THE
ME WALK THE NISSAN- AND MIGHT
YOU. WHICH IS THE TRADITIONAL
HOMELANDS- WHERE SACRAMENTO IS
LOCATED AT. SO I'VE BEEN TASKED
TO SPEAK ABOUT CALIFORNIA
INDIANS IN PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
SO WE SAW A FROM THE PREVIOUS
PRESENTATION A BIT ABOUT
BOARDING SCHOOLS. REALLY TO
THINK ABOUT- PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND SO I WANT TO BEGIN BY
HIGHLIGHTING- THIS IS A BOOK
THAT I RECOMMEND FOR EVERYONE TO
READ IF YOU HAVE NOT READ THIS
IS BAD INDIANS IT IS WRITTEN BY.
DEBORAH MARANDA SO THIS IS A
QUOTE OF FOURTH GRADERS THEIR
PARENTS THEIR TEACHERS TOURISTS
TO THE MISSIONS EVEN HISTORIANS
OFTEN LEARN AND PERPETUATE ONLY
ONE STORY ABOUT CALIFORNIANS.
CONQUEST SUBJUGATION DEFEAT.
DISAPPEARANCE WHEN STILL REALLY
THINK ABOUT- THE WAYS IN WHICH A
PARTICULAR- PEDAGOGICAL
STANDARDS THAT SOMETIMES ARE
ACTUALLY EVEN STANDARDS HOW
ABOUT THE LASTING LEGACY NOT
JUST ON CALIFORNIA INDIAN
CHILDREN IN THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE SYSTEM. BUT ALSO GO
DIFFERENTLY- NON INDIANS WHO ARE
IN THE EXACT SAME EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM- AND SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE FOURTH GRADE- MOST OF
YOU WHO ARE BORN OR WHO WERE
RAISED IN CALIFORNIA MIGHT
RECALL THE FOURTH GRADE MISSION
UNIT AND THAT'S WHAT SHE SAID
SPECIFICALLY REFERENCING AND
THIS QUOTE. AND SO TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT THE WAYS IN WHICH
NATIVE PEOPLE NATIVE CULTURES
EXPERIENCES ARE EITHER
COMPLETELY ABSENT OR WHEN THEY
ARE TAUGHT REALLY LACK THE
NUANCE THE SPECIFIC- ITS TIES. I
MIGHT BE SPECIFICALLY BROAD AND
HOW WE CAN PERHAPS MOVE TO
IMPROVE- THE K. TO TWELVE AND
EVEN INTO COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. THE WAY IS THAT A
NATIVE HISTORIES ARE TAUGHT. I
ALSO WANT TO SHARE OF THIS IS A
QUOTE FROM LEANNE SIMPSON SO
SHE'S MISSION KNOBS- FROM CANADA
SHE'S A POET AND SO AN ACADEMIC
AND SO SHE- AND THIS QUOTE WHERE
SHE'S DISCUSSING LAND AS
PEDAGOGY I THINK IT'S VERY
REPRESENTATIVE- TO DESCRIBE HOW
MANY NATIVE PEOPLE FEEL ABOUT
SORT OF GOING THROUGH THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM- SO I'M
NOT GOING TO READ IT IN ITS
ENTIRETY. BUT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS IN
THIS RATE- SHE DISCUSSES AND
ASSERTS NO ONE EVER ASKED ME
WHAT I WAS INTERESTED IN NOR DID
THEY ASK FOR MY CONSENT TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THEIR SYSTEM
EXPERIENCE OF EDUCATION WAS ONE
OF CONTINUALLY BEING MEASURED
AGAINST A SET OF PRINCIPLES THAT
REQUIRES SURRENDER TO AN
ASSIMILATIVE COLONIAL AGENDA IN
ORDER TO FULFILL THOSE
PRINCIPLES. COMING INTO WISDOM
IT TAKES IN THE CONTEXT OF
FAMILY COMMUNITY AND RELATIONS.
THE LAND IS BOTH CONTEXT AND
PROCESS. AND SO SHE'S OUTLINED
IN DESCRIBING UPON HOUSE HER
REFLECTIONS OF NOT ONLY K.
THROUGH TWELVE BUT ALSO HER
EXPERIENCES GOING INTO A
COLLEGE. NOW I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AN INDIVIDUAL IN THIS
IS WHO I- AND HIS ORGANIZATION
THAT I WROTE MY DISSERTATION ON
IT SO THIS IS REPORT COSTA AND
SO HE- WAS KOREA I HE WAS- FROM
THE CLEAR RESERVATION AND HE-
WAS A CO FOUNDER OF AN
ORGANIZATION AND CALLED THE
AMERICAN INDIAN HISTORICAL
SOCIETY- AND SO HIS ORGANIZATION
WAS. FORMALLY FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR ONE OF THE
FIRST SORT OF KEY THINGS THAT
THE SOCIETY EXAMINED AND LOOKED
AT WAS LOOKING AT THE TEXT BOOKS
THAT WERE BEING USED IN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEMS
AND WHILE RUPERT HIMSELF WAS NOT
A TRAINED HISTORIAN HE
RECOGNIZED ALONG WITH- THE
ORGANIZATION THE IMPORT OF
HISTORY. THE IMPORT OF WHAT IS
BEING TAUGHT THE IMPORT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT- THAT NEEDED
CHILDREN WERE BEING EXPOSED TO.
SPECIFICALLY IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS
BUT HE ALSO EXPRESSED CONCERN
ABOUT THE IMPACT THATTHIS WAS
HAVING ON NON NATIVE CHILDREN
RIGHT SO- THE IDEA OF TEXTBOOKS
AND LESSON PLANS THAT THEY ARE
SOCIALIZING. BOTH NATIVE AND NON
NATIVE CHILDREN ABOUT HOW TO
PERCEIVE AND THINK ABOUT- NATIVE
CULTURES BROADLY NATIVE PEOPLE
BROADLY. AND HE HE WOULD- VERY
MUCH REGULARLY ARTICULATE THAT
YOU CANNOT EXPECT GREATER SORT
OF SOCIETAL PERHAPS- SHIFTS OR
CHANGES. IF FOLKS SIMPLY DO NOT
HAVE ANY CONCEPT ABOUT NATIVE
PEOPLE NEEDED HIS TREES NATIVE
EXPERIENCES OR NATIVE VOICES AND
SO- THIS PARTICULAR QUOTE COMES
FROM A BOOK THAT HE CO WROTE
WITH HIS WIFE JANET HENRY
ACOSTA. SO HE'S DISCUSSING- HOW
IN HIS OPINION EVERY SOCIETY
QUOTE HAS EDUCATED ITS YOUNG
ACCORDING TO THE BEST INTERESTS
OF ITS DOMINANT CLASS PERHAPS
THIS CAN CHANGE AND HUMANITY
BEING MADE TO SEE ITSELF FACE TO
FACE WITHOUT FEAR AND IN SPITE
OF THE PANGS OF CONSCIENCE. AND
SO AGAIN WHAT THE SOCIETY VERY
MUCH SPOKE TO. IS THE IDEA OF
THE IMPACT OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS NOW
REPORT HIMSELF WAS A PRODUCT OF
PUBLIC SCHOOLS- HIS SIBLINGS
WERE THE PRODUCTS OF PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND SPECIFICALLY-
CERTAINLY THERE IS A LASTING
LEGACY OF BOARDING SCHOOLS AGAIN
MOST NATIVE PEOPLE DEPENDING ON
ONE'S AGE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THEIR GRANDPARENTS THEIR GREAT
GRANDPARENTS- PERHAPS THEIR
PARENTS- WERE FORCED TO ATTEND
BOARDING SCHOOLS HOWEVER
SPECIFICALLY IN CALIFORNIA-
THERE WAS A SHIFT WHERE THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA INDIAN
CHILDREN WERE ATTENDING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS- BUT I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR THAT SIMPLY BECAUSE ONE
HAD ACCESS TO ATTEND PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. DID NOT NECESSARILY
TRANSLATE INTO EQUITY- WHEN IT
CAME TO WHAT WAS POSSIBLE AT
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND SO THE NEXT
FEW SLIDES I'M GOING TO DISCUSS
SOME OF THE FRAMING- OF
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED IN
SCHOOLING FOR NATIVE CHILDREN.
SO THIS IS A QUOTE- BY THE
INDIAN AGENT FROM ROUND VALLEY-
THIS IS A HE WROTE- IN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR SO THIS IS PRIOR TO-
SORT OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS BUT IT TO
THE REALLY PAY ATTENTION TO THE
SCHOOL THIS REPORT- AND SO HE
NOTED IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOUR AT
THAT QUOTE LITTLE PROGRESS CAN
BE MADE. IN THEIR EDUCATION
WHILE THEY'RE ALLOWED TO RUN IN
THE CAMP SUBJECT TO THE TAUNTS
AND JEERS OF THE OLD AND THE
CONTAMINATIONS OF THE YOUNGER
AND MIDDLE AGED NOW WHAT AGENT
SHELDON WAS REFERENCING IS THAT
HE WAS A FIRM BELIEVER. IN
BOARDING SCHOOLS HE FIRMLY
BELIEVES THAT THE ROOF PHYSICAL
REMOVAL OF CHILDREN WAS
NECESSARY- IN ORDER TO- REALLY
SORT OF MEET THAT GOAL OF
ASSIMILATION SO WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT BOARDING SCHOOLS
PRIMARILY- THEY SERVED AS- A
COLONIAL ASSIMILATIONIST TACTIC
GREAT. HOW CAN YOU REMOVE
CULTURE HOW CAN YOU REMOVE
CONNECTION CAN YOU REMOVE
KINSHIP- AND HE GREAT SO HE HE
HE'S SPEAKING AND REFERENCING IN
THIS GOVERNMENT REPORT ALSO IN A
VERY PATERNALISTIC MANNER HE'S
TALKING ABOUT THE IDEA OF
CONTAMINATIONS. THIS IS THE
REASON THAT WE HAVE TO REMOVE
THE CHILDREN FROM I'M
RESERVATIONS BECAUSE THEY COULD
BE CONTAMINATED- YOU KNOW LITTLE
PROGRESS CAN BE MADE AND I'VE
BEEN SHARING THIS QUOTE TO HAVE
TO PRESENT- YOU KNOW THE SORT OF
THE MINDSET- WHEN IT CAME TO
SORT OF FORMAL EDUCATION OF
CALIFORNIA INDIAN CHILDREN. SO
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EDUCATION FOR CALIFORNIA AND ITS
CHILDREN THERE REALLY CAN BE
DIVIDED INTO ROUGHLY THREE
DIFFERENT TIME PERIODS- SO YOU
KNOW BETWEEN THIS THE BEGINNING
OF STATEHOOD- TO ROUGHLY
NINETEEN SIXTY. AT NINETEEN
SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA INDIAN CATION
EXISTED PRIMARILY THROUGH
FEDERAL BOARDING SCHOOLS- BASED
SCHOOLS AND SOME CONTRACTS- WITH
LARGELY RELIGIOUS- PRIMARILY
CATHOLIC SCHOOLS- REALLY WHEN
YOU'RE THEN I'M SPEAKING TO-
WHAT THE PREVIOUS PRESENTATION
MENTIONED I WHICH WAS THE-
SECTION SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS WHAT WAS
UTILIZED TO EXCLUDE NATIVE
CHILDREN FROM ATTENDING REGULAR
SCHOOLS- AND SO YOU THEN HAVE.
TO ASK YOU THINK- THE THIRD
PERIOD WHICH IS- I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT IT IN A COUPLE OF SLIDES-
WHICH IS AFTER THE PAPER
DECISION- BUT THIS IS AN ADDRESS
THAT WAS WRITTEN BY- THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC EDUCATION EDWARD HYATT
AT THE TIME- THIS WAS A SPEECH
THAT HE GAVE- AND- HE- IS
ASSERTED IN HIS SPEECH QUOTE THE
BEST SOLUTION OF THE PROBLEM. IS
FOR THE INDIAN CHILDREN TO BE
SQUARELY TAKEN INTO OUR ORDINARY
STATES TRICKS SCHOOLS AND TAUGHT
BY THE SAME TEACHERS IN TE SAME
WAY AS OTHER CHILDREN. SO IN
NINETEEN FOURTEEN THAT
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IS REALLY PUSHING
FOR THIS IDEA OF TO A DEGREE
INTEGRATION. HOWEVER HE TEMPERS
HIS COMMENT- BY NOTING THAT ONLY
POSITIVE RESULTS COULD BE
POSSIBLE. AKIF QUOTE WHEN EVER
INDIAN CHILDREN ARE FEW AS
COMPARED WITH THE WHITES AND SO
WHAT HE'S ARGUING IN THE SPEECH
IS THAT WHILE INTEGRATION COULD
PERHAPS BE POSSIBLE THAT AGAIN
IT IS ONLY- PERHAPS- YOU KNOW
ASSIMILATIONIST. IF NEEDED
CHILDREN ARE IN THE MINORITY
POPULATION- YOU ALSO HAVE LATER
ON GOVERNMENT REPORTS THAT ARE
DOCUMENTING ONE OF THE CAUSES
THAT A LOT OF- WHITE PARENTS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT INTEGRATION IS
THAT THEY'RE WORRIED THAT THEIR
CHILDREN ARE PERHAPS GOING TO
BEGIN. I'M DATING OR HAVING
ROMANTIC RELATIONSHIPS WITH-
INDIAN TEENAGERS- AND SO HIS IS
SORT OF WHAT IS MOTIVATING SOME
OF THESE- IDEOLOGIES THAT ARE
BEING HELD- SO IT'S VERY ANTI
INDIAN AT SOME. SO AGAIN TO
HIGHLIGHT THE SHIFT BEGINS TO
OCCUR SPECIFICALLY IN
CALIFORNIA- THIS DATA COMES FROM
THE ANNUAL REPORT OF THE
COMMISSIONER OF INDIAN AFFAIRS
TO THE SECRETARY OF THE
INTERIOR. SO YOU CAN SEE
OUTLINED RATE IN NINETEEN
FIFTEEN- THAT THERE ARE ONLY
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA INDIAN STUDENTS-
BASED ON THE DATA THAT'S
AVAILABLE BECAUSE THAT COULD BE-
GREAT- DOCUMENTS CAN SOMETIMES
BE WRONG- BUT THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN BY NINETEEN SIXTEEN IT'S
ONE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTEEN IT'S ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE AND BY
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN AND
SUBSEQUENTLY THROUGHOUT THE
REMAINDER OF THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY- THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA INDIAN STUDENTS ARE
ATTENDING PUBLIC SCHOOLS. AND SO
IT WAS ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND TWENTY IN COMPARISON
TO ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE AND SO NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN IS THAT THAT YEAR THAT
THAT OCCURS. SO THE PAPER
DECISION IS LARGELY- CELEBRATED
THOUGH ODDLY NOT KNOWN BUT A LOT
OF FOLKS- THE PAPER DECISION
INVOLVED THE TEENAGER FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD BY THE NAME OF ALICE
PAPER SHE WAS BY YOU- SHE WAS A
RESIDENT OF BIG PINE. AND THE
MAP YEAR SIR LIKE WHERE IS BIG
TIME- SO HER PARENTS FILED A
LAWSUIT. AND ULTIMATELY THERE
WAS THE UNANIMOUS CALIFORNIA
STATE SUPREME COURT DECISION
THAT ARGUED THAT THERE WAS NO
CAUSE FOR HER IN ELIGIBILITY FOR
ATTENDING A LOCAL PUBLIC SCHOOL.
EVEN IF THERE WAS A DAY SCHOOL
AND AN INDIAN DAY SCHOOL- NEARBY
TOO- AND SO THIS WAS THIS
DECISION- WAS ANNOUNCED THE VERY
SAME DAY THAT YOU HAVE THE
NINETEEN. TWENTY FOUR INDIAN
CITIZENSHIP ACT- AND SO- THIS.
COURT DECISION ALONG WITH THE
MENDEZ DECISION WE'RE ACTUALLY
CITED AND USED- IN ULTIMATELY
THE NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR BROWN
VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION TO
PEEK A KANSAS- WHICH WE ALL
KNOW- ENDED. I'M SCHOOL
SEGREGATION HOWEVER EVEN THAT
DECISION- IT UTILIZED THE PHRASE
WITH ALL DELIBERATE SPEED AND SO
THIS MEANT THAT FOR ACTUALLY
SEVERAL YEARS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AROUND THE COUNTRY- DID NOT
INTEGRATE PURPOSELY- AND SO YOU
CAN SEE. A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT- THE PAPER DECISION RIGHT
THAT SHE COULD NOT BE PREVENTED
FROM ATTENDING A PUBLIC SCHOOL-
BECAUSE SHE WAS OF INDIAN BLOOD-
TO THEN JUMP IN TIME IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES THERE ARE-
LIKE- PROFESSOR DIXON MENTIONED-
A SERIES OF GOVERNMENT REPORTS
THERE'S ALSO A SERIES OF
HEARINGS AND SO. THIS IS JUST AN
EXAMPLE OF- THAT WAS DESCRIBED
BY DENISON NIGHTS HE WAS
PUMMELED YOU KYRA- AND SO HE
SHARED THE STORY OF THE TEACHER
ACTING AS A HALL MONITOR WHO
GRABBED FOR YOUNG INDIAN WOMEN-
MARCH THEM TO THE PRINCIPAL'S
OFFICE WITH THE LOUD
PRONUNCIATION. I'M HERE ARE YOUR
FOR BLACK RATS- HE COMMENTED IN
DESCRIBING THIS THE CAUSES OF
DISCRIMINATION APPEAR TO STAY.
LONG TIME DEEP ROOTED PREJUDICES
OF THIS AREA. AND SO THIS
OCCURRED WITHIN A PUBLIC SCHOOL-
YOU ALSO HAVE IN NINETEEN TWENTY
SIX THE COMMONWEALTH CLUB OF
CALIFORNIA ISSUED A REPORT. AND
THE DETAILS RIGHT SO THIS IS
AFTER NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR WHEN
INDIAN CHILDREN CALVIN INDIAN
CHILDREN ARE- LEGALLY SUPPOSED
TO BE ABLE TO ATTEND PUBLIC
SCHOOLS- BUT WHAT THE DETAIL IS
THAT- THIS OCCURS AND IT RANGES.
WHAT THEY TERM CRUEL FLIRTATION
TO QUOTE FRIENDLINESS AND
HONESTY- THE REPORT SHARED THE
STORY OF MIDDLE CREEK DISTRICT
IN LEE COUNTY CALIFORNIA- DUE TO
A CLOSURE OF. AN INDIAN TO YOU
SCHOOL THE PUBLIC SCHOOL THEIR
ACCEPTED FOURTEEN INDIAN
CHILDREN. HOWEVER IT PARTITIONED
OFF A SPECIAL ROOM FOR THESE
STUDENTS IT FENCED IN A SECTION
OF THE PLAYGROUND AND IT HIRED A%
SEPARATE TEACHER FOR THEM SO
DESPITE THE NINETEEN TWENTY
FOUR- PAPER DECISION DESPITE THE
IDEA BREAK THAT. KHALFAN
INDENTURE SHOULD BE ABLE AND
BEING A LEGALLY PROTECTED TO
ATTEND PUBLIC SCHOOLS AGAIN THIS
DOES NOT NECESSARILY TRANSLATE
TO EQUITY THIS DOES NOT
NECESSARILY TRANSLATE TO
ACTUALLY. RECEIVING YOU KNOW
EQUAL EDUCATION IF YOU'RE
FANCYING OFF A PLAYGROUND
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT THE
INDIAN CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO
YOU KNOW US SOCIALIZE WITH THE
NON INDIAN CHILDREN. THERE IS
SOMETHING GOING ON WITH THAT
DECISION THAT IS BEING MADE. I
ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT-
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION THIS WAS DR MAX
RAFFERTY SO HE WAS THE
SUPERINTENDENT FROM SIXTY THREE
TO SEVENTY- HIS ELECTION WAS THE
VERY FIRST TIME THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT POSITION APPEARED
ON THE CALIFORNIA BALLOT- SO
THAT PEOPLE ACTUALLY VOTED HE
WON BY FIFTY TWO PERCENT- WAS.
CLOSE AND SO HE ACTUALLY WAS AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT WORKED WITH THE
ORGANIZATION THAT I MENTION
COSTA FOUNDED- AND THE SOCIETY
FORMED WHAT WAS KNOWN AS THE
INDIAN HISTORY STUDY COMMITTEE-
AND SO I TO NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
STATE CURRICULA COMMISSION MIDI
CHAIRED BY RAFFERTY- WHERE THE
SOCIETY PRISON. WART RAP
REMARKED PUB FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME ABOUT THE- MANNER IN WHICH-
NATIVE CULTURES WERE- PRESENTED
IN TEXTBOOKS AND SO HE REMARKED
THAT INDIAN HISTORY WAS ONE OF
THE QUOTE. MOST NEGLECTED AREAS
IN CALIFORNIA TEXTBOOKS. I'M AND
SO THIS IS A LIST OF THE- INDIAN
HISTORY STUDY COMMITTEE AGAIN
MOST OF THEM. ARE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN- THERE'S A LINK THAT I
CAN SHARE WITH FOLKS YOU CAN
WATCH IT A LITTLE LATER ON- BUT
I'M GOING TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
OF BOOKS THAT SOCIETY TARGETED
AND SO ONE AT THE TIME PERIOD. A
CALIFORNIA HAD THE STATE
PRINTING PRESS AND SO ALL THE
BOOKS ARE THE SAME THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE STATE- AND SO THEY
LOOK AT HELEN BOWERS CALIFORNIA
GOLD DAYS THIS WAS UTILIZED IN
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES AND THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES- AND SO YOU CAN
SEE HOW SHE'S TALKING ABOUT THE
GOLD RUSH- SHE ALSO INCLUDES
THIS QUOTE WERE THOSE INDIANS
HIDING BEHIND THOSE THICK
BUSHES- AND SO THE CHALLENGE
THIS BOOK. HOWEVER THE STATE
DETERMINED THAT THIS BOOK WAS
FINE FOR A CONTINUED USE. THE
SOCIETY ALSO WORKED ON- A BOOK
CALLED THE LAND OF FOLKS THIS
WAS WRITTEN BY JAMES HARLOW THIS
WAS USED IN THE OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHAT WHICH WAS-
RELOCATED- IT SELECTED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR OUT OF
STATE INDIANS TO MOVE TO
CALIFORNIA. THIS WAS ORIGINALLY
PUBLISHED IN FIFTY THREE IT WAS
ALSO REPRINTED IN FIFTY FIVE AND
FIFTY NINE SO IF YOU ATTENDED
SCHOOLS IN OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE FIFTIES
OR THE SIXTIES THERE'S A REALLY
GOOD CHANCE THAT YOU USE THIS
BOOK- SO HARLOW USED PHRASES IN
TERMS OF HIS BOOK LIKE A BIGGER
INDIAN. WHICH IS A SLUR SPOOKY
SONGS STRANGE LOOKING HOUSES HE
ALSO COMMENTED IT QUOTE EVERY
TIME YOU DIG INTO THE GROUND YOU
ARE LIKELY TO BUMP INTO
SOMETHING YOU COULD USE TO
DECORATE YOUR HOME AT HOLLY.
WHAT HE IS REFERENCING IN THAT-
ARE HUMAN REMAINS SKELETONS. I'M
SO THE SOCIETY ALONG WITH THE-
OAKLAND AMERICAN INDIAN
ASSOCIATION AS ALONG WITH THE
OAKLAND INTERTRIBAL FRIENDSHIP
HOUSE- REALLY WENT AFTER THIS
BOOK NOW THE DISTRICT DECIDED
THAT THEY DID REMOVE THIS BOOK.
HOWEVER PERHAPS AND A PUBLIC WAY
TO MINIMIZE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
NOT ONLY THE SOCIETY BUT ALSO
NEEDED PARENTS. YOU HAVE THE
DIRECTOR OF A STRUCTURAL MEDIA I
TELL THE OAKLAND TRIBUNE THAT
THE BOOK WAS OBSOLETE I HAD
ALREADY BEEN SCHEDULED TO BE
REMOVED BUT THIS IS AN EXAMPLE
OF- SORT OF- CREATING ALLIANCES
TO HAVE BOOKS REMOVED AND TO
THINK ABOUT AGAIN. THE IMPACT
THAT THIS BOOK WOULD HAVE NOT
ONLY ON NATIVE CHILDREN IN THE
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
BUT ALSO HOW THIS IS TEACHING
NON NATIVE CHILDREN TO THINK
ABOUT NATIVE PEOPLE- OF COURSE
AGAIN MANY OF YOU ARE FAMILIAR
WITH- WHAT WAS KNOWN AS A SORT
OF THE SUGAR CUBE MISSION
SOMETIMES POPSICLE STICKS. I
WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT IN
pTHE FALL OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ANNOUNCED ITS NEW EDUCATIONAL
HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE
FRAMEWORK- BECAUSE IT DETERMINED
THAT THE MISSION UNIT WAS
OFFENSIVE AND ACTUALLY TAUGHT
LITTLE HISTORICAL OF INFORMATION
ACCURATE INFORMATION AND ALSO
CAN BE VERY CLEAR THAT THE IDEA
OF THE DIORAMA. WAS ACTUALLY
NEVER PART OF A FORMAL- STATE
WIDE CURRICULUM THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT- TEACHERS DID ON
THEIR OWN AND IT BEGAN TO REPEAT
AND THIS IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
HOW WHAT YOU ARE EXPOSED TO
YOURSELF PERHAPS LEAD YOU TO AS
YOU GROW UP. AND INTO YOUR
CHOSEN REFLECTION YOU BEGIN TO
CONTINUE TO MIMIC THAT FOR
DECADES THIS WAS A MAINSTAY IN-
CALIFORNIA FOURTH GRADE- THE
MISSION UNIT AND WHAT THE STATE
IS NOW DOING IS REALLY EXAMINING
HOW TO REVISE- AND CORRECT- WHAT
SORT OF. IS TAUGHT IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS I ALSO REALLY WANT TO
QUICKLY MENTION A COUPLE OF
INSTANCES SO IN FEBRUARY OF
TWENTY. DON'T GET ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL A- THAT WAS SORT OF
CIRCULATOR AS HOMEWORK AND SO
INCLUDED THINGS LIKE QUOTE THE
WOMEN WERE CALLED SCHOOL LAWS AN
INDIAN WORD FOR WOMEN. OF COURSE
WE KNOW THAT GIVEN THE TERM
SQUAD THE WEIGHT IT PLACES ARE
BEING RENAMED THIS IS ACTUALLY
AN APPROPRIATE- BUT THIS IS WHAT
WAS BEING UTILIZED IN THEM AND
THEY ELEMENT ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
CLASS. LASTLY TO BRING ATTENTION
TO A HANDFUL OF REPORTS ABOUT
SORT OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
IMAGERY SO THE AMERICAN INDIAN
COLLEGE FUND REPORT CREATING
VISIBILITY NOTES THE
INVISIBILITY IS IN ESSENCE HE
MODERN FORM OF RACISM. USED TO
GET STATE OF AMERICANS IT IS
THIS INVISIBILITY THAT LEADS TO
COLLEGE ACCESS AND COMPLETION
CRISIS AMONG NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS YOU ALSO HAVE THE
TRIBAL COLLEGE JOURNAL OF
AMERICAN INDIANS- ENTITLED
CREATING COMMUNITY. IT ARGUES
THAT THERE'S IMPORTANT FACTORS
FOR- NOT ONLY- COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE BUT ALSO SUCCESSFUL
GRADUATION SURROUNDING YOURSELF
WITH COMMUNITY AND ALSO HAVING
AT LEAST ONE SUPPORTIVE MENTOR
OR ADVISER. LASTLY I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT BE ELIMINATED
RECLAIMING NATIVE TRUTH REPORT
WHICH REALLY ARTICULATES THE
IDEA OF NOT ONLY EDUCATION BEING
A KEY LEVER FOR CHANGE ACROSS.
ALL OF THIS RESEARCH IN THIS
REPORT BUT ALSO A RECOGNITION
THAT PEOPLE BOTH NATIVE AND
NONNATIVE RECOGNIZED THAT WHAT
THEY'RE BEING TAUGHT IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IS AN ACCURATE. AND IS
INDEED- A DEFICIT AND SO THIS IS
A PLACE A SITE WHERE PERHAPS
THERE CAN BE A CHANGE- SO. THIS
IS A WRAP UP OF MY PRESENTATION
SO I WOULD LIKE TO END AGAIN
WITH MY APPRECIATION AND
GRATITUDE I REMIND EVERYONE TO
RESIST. FOR A FIVE AN INDIGENOUS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- SO MUCH
FOR THAT- TESTIMONY. AND BRING
IT TO LIFE THE VERY HISTORY OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ITS
TREATMENT TOWARDS- CALIFORNIA
INDIAN PEOPLE AND NOT JUST IN
AND HISTORY BUT IT'S STILL
HAPPENING NOW AS YOU YOU
REFERENCE TO A BOOK THAT WAS
BEING USED IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO WE'RE
STILL- IDENTIFYING AND WORKING
TO ELIMINATE ALL THOSE THINGS I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THAT. THAT FORWARD- A SPIN IT
AND BRINGING TO LIGHT THE PIPER
DECISION THAT- MANY- WROTE DOWN.
AND SO THEY'RE GONNA GO ON
RESEARCH THAT BUT THE PIPER
DECISION WAS ALSO- DURING THE
SAME TIME THAT THE INDIAN
CITIZEN SHIP FACT MOVE FORWARD
SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HIGHLIGHT THE PIPER DECISION.
AND HOW THAT ACTUALLY- IMPACTED-
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SONA
THANK EACH ONE OF THE
PRESENTERS- FOR OUR PANEL ONE
DISCUSSION. IN AGAIN- ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU'VE BEEN
ABLE TO- BRING TO OUR ATTENTION
EACH ONE OF THE SPEAKERS HAS
RESOURCES THAT ARE OUTTHERE
AVAILABLE FOR- LEGISLATORS AND
THOSE THAT ARE WATCHING. THROUGH
THE ASSEMBLY AND THOSE IN THE-
IN THE CHAMBERS HERE TODAY- IF
YOU WANT TO FOLLOW UP AND LOOK
UP MORE INFORMATION THAT'S
THERE- EACH ONE OF THE
PRESENTERS IS OPEN TO- HAVE THAT
MOVE FORWARD. SO I THINK YOU-
PANEL ONE FOR YOUR DISCUSSIONS.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON A
PANEL TO AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON- WHO'S JOINING US ALSO
HERE TODAY. WE JUST FINISHED
POWER ONE ON THE EVOLUTION OF
NATIVE AMERICANS IN EDUCATION-
THE ROLE OF BOARDING SCHOOLS IN
THE EFFORT TO STRIP NATIVE
AMERICANS OF THEIR LANGUAGE AND
CULTURE. WE'RE MOVING ON THE
PANEL TO WHICH WOULD BE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HASTINGS COLLEGE. DISCUSS AND
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT TOPIC
WE'VE SEEN- THE HISTORY AND THE
TRAUMA THAT HAS BEEN- PRESENTED
BY THE PREVIOUS- PRESENTERS- AND
THIS PANEL WILL DISCUSS EFFORTS
BY THE U. K. INDIAN PEOPLE AND
THE ROUND VALLEY INDIAN TRIBES
TRIBAL COUNCIL AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAW IN
ONGOING EFFORTS- TO FORGE A PATH
THAT RECOGNIZES- THE TRI CITIES
IN GENOCIDE INFLICTED UPON THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE BUT TRYING TO
FORGE A PATH THAT MOVES FORWARD
WITH RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING AS WE-
MOVE FORWARD ON PANEL TWO
DISCUSSIONS WELL OUR PRESENTERS
WILL BE- MONA- DOTSON- UKEE
TRAVEL REPRESENTATIVE. OUR OUR
SECOND- PANEL WILL BE- OUR PANEL
OF PRESENTERS WILL BE- PRESIDENT
JAMES RUSS OF THE ROUND VALLEY
INDIAN TRIBES- AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AROUND VALLEY INDIAN
HEALTH CENTER AND WILL HAVE-
DEAN DAVID EGGMAN- UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
LAW THAT WOULD BE THE ORDER-
THAT WE WILL TAKE THE TEST. I'M
OUR FIRST- TESTIMONY WE DONE BY
MONA ON ADULTS IN A YANKEE
TRAVEL REPRESENTATIVE MONA IS A
YOU CAN JUST SEND AN ENROLLED
MEMBER OF THE ROUND VALLEY
INDIAN TRIBES SHE HAS WORKED
FORTY THREE YEARS FOR HER TRIBE
SERVING IN MANY CAPACITIES
INCLUDING- THE TRIBAL COUNCIL
I'D LIKE. TO WELCOME OWN UP TO
THE DICE.
AND ASSEMBLYMAN RAMOS I MONITOR
TO TALK TO YOU TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE YOU KEEP PEOPLE OF ROUND
VALLEY IN VALLEY AND SURROUNDING
MOUNTAINS. WE HAVE BEEN ON OUR
HOMELANDS FOR OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND YEARS. WE UNDERSTAND
THAT WE ARE HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF STRIKING
HASTINGS NAME FROM THE UC
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW. A FEW
YEARS AGO THE U. K. AND THE
TRIBAL COUNCIL WERE APPROACHED
BY REPRESENTATIVES FROM HASTINGS
COLLEGE THEY STATED THAT THEIR
THROUGH THEIR OWN RESEARCH THEY
BECAME AWARE OF THE ATROCITIES
THAT. THE SCHOOLS. FOUNDER HAD
COMMITTED UPON THE UKEE AND THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO ATONE FOR
THESE WRONGDOINGS. I WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE AN EXAMPLE OF A
PARTICULAR STORY OF THESE
ATROCITIES. I WAS GOING TO TELL
YOU THE STORY OF A TEN YEAR OLD
GIRL WHO WAS KILLED. JUST
BECAUSE SHE WAS BEEN STUBBORN
INSTEAD. I'D LIKE TO SHARE THE
STORY OF BLOODY WRONG. THIS IS
AN ACCOUNTING FROM ONE OF THE
SETTLERS. AS THE STORY GOES.
THERE WAS A BAND OF THE SIXTY
FIVE UN ARMED YUKI. THEY WERE
HANDED DOWN OVER HILLS AND
THROUGH THE CANYONS OF THE EEL
RIVER. IT WAS AT THIS PLACE
WHERE THERE WAS A ROCK FORMATION
THAT WAS. OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
FEET OF SHEER DROP. ON THREE
SIDES AND AT ITS BASE IT WAS
GUARDED BY SMALL BOULDERS AND
ROCKS. THE IRAQIS WERE HANDED IN
ON ONE SIDE HEADED OFF ON
ANOTHER. THE YANKEES WERE HALF
CRAZED BY SLEEPLESS NIGHTS AND
DAYS OF TERROR. FLEEING FROM
THOSE WHO HUNTED THEM. THEY WERE
OFFERED THREE ALTERNATIVES
EITHER CONTINUE AND FIGHT AND BE
PICKED OFF ONE BY ONE. CONCEDE
TO A TRUCE AND THEN RETURNED TO
ROUND VALLEY. WHERE THEY WOULD
BE. EVENTUALLY PERISHED FROM
HUNGER. OR LARGE HANDS AND LEAVE
OFF THE BOULDER. SO THE UK'S
ADVANCED TO THE EDGE OF THIS
MIGHTY BOULDER. JOIN HANDS
TOGETHER AND COMMENCED TO SING
THEIR DESK PHONE. WITH THEIR
CRIES THEY LIVE DOWN. DOWN TO
THEIR DEATHS. NO YOU GET A SKATE
OR WAS CAPTURED. AND MANY YEARS
LATER THE BURNS OF THE UK WERE
STILL IN EVIDENCE AT THE BOTTOM
OF BLOODY WROTE. ADDITIONAL
DETAILS IN THAT TIME JANUARY
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE THE
SACRAMENTO DAILY UNION PUBLISHED
REPORTS. IN MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY YUKI INDIANS. HAVE
BEEN KILLED BY WHITE WITHIN FOUR
MONTHS THREE TO FOUR MONTHS IN
THE U. K. I'M- IN THE EDEN
VALLEY REGIONS. J. ROSS BROWN
LATER WROTE. AT ROUND VALLEY
DURING THE WINTER OF EIGHTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. TO EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
PEACEABLE INDIANS INCLUDING
WOMEN AND CHILDREN WERE CRUELLY
SLAUGHTERED BY THE WHITES. IT'S
SETTLED PAYER UNDER OFFICIAL
AUTHORITY. ARM PARTIES WENT INTO
THE RANCHERIAS ONE DAY WHEN NO
ILLICIT APPREHENDED AND SHUT THE
INDIANS DOWN WE HARMLESS AND
DEFENCELESS AS THEY WERE WITHOUT
DISTINCTION OF H. SIX SHOT DOWN
WOMEN RECYCLING BABES IN THEIR
OMNIVOROUS. KILLED OR CRIPPLED
THE NAKED CHILDREN THAT WERE
RUNNING ABOUT. ON JANUARY
TWENTIETH THE DAILY ALTA
CALIFORNIA REPORTED THE
SLAUGHTER OF ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
INDIANS IN THE LOCALITY OF ROUND
VALLEY. THE SOLDIERS TRIED TO BE
PEACEKEEPERS BUT WHEN THERE WAS
A COMPLAINT TO WASHINGTON THE US
ARMY COMMANDER ORDERED THEM TO
QUIT PROTECTING THE ROUND VALLEY
INDIANS FROM WHAT WAS IN L. A.
PROFOUND LETHAL KILLING MACHINE
AND THUS. UNDERSCORING FEDERAL
CULPABILITY IN THE REGION'S
GENOCIDE. DILLON REPORTED FROM
ROUND VALLEY. THE PARTY THAT
WENT TO EDEN VALLEY TO HUNT THE
INDIANS. HAVE BEEN THERE NEARLY
TWO WEEKS HUNTING INDIANS. AND
THAT TWO HUNDRED FORTY INDIANS
WERE KILLED. AN INFORMANT WHO
HAD JUST ARRIVED AT REPORTED
THAT IN THE VICINITY OF T. OF
ROUND VALLEY WITHIN THE PAST
THREE WEEKS THERE WERE FROM
THREE HUNDRED TO FOUR HUNDRED
BUCKS SCORES IN CHILDREN THAT
WERE KILLED BY THE WHITE. IN A
TOTAL THESE REPORTS SUGGEST THE
KILLING PRIMARILY BY VIGILANTES
OF AT LEAST FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
AND PERHAPS AS MANY AS NINE
HUNDRED TEN INDIAN PEOPLE. IN
THE ROUND VALLEY REGION. WITHIN
FIVE MONTHS. THERE ARE NOT ONLY
A FEW HUNDRED FOR THE THOUSANDS
OF STORIES. OF HOW MY ANCESTORS
POPULATION WAS DISSEMINATED. THE
YOU CAN POPULATION WENT FROM
AROUND TWENTY THOUSAND. DOWN TO
THREE HUNDRED IN LITTLE UNDER
THREE YEARS. THIS IS TRULY NOT
JUST ABOUT A NAME CHANGE. IN
EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX SERENA FACING
FROM THOMAS FAMILY MET AS YOUNG
MEN. DURING THE WESTWARD
MOVEMENT YOUNG MAN WITH PLANS TO
HEAD WEST IN GAME THEIR
POSITIONS OF WEALTH AND POWER.
WELL THEY WERE DREAMING AND LINK
THEIR PLANS. THEY LIVE IN THEIR
STRONGHOLD THAT PROTECTED THEM
ALLOW THEM TO CARRY ON WITH
THEIR CULTURAL WAY OF LIFE. THE
WHAT VALLEY WAS SO ABUNDANT.
THAT EVERY THAT IT EASILY
SUPPORTED THE TWENTY THOUSAND OR
MORE YOU CAN. THAT WAS UNTIL
AROUND EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR.
SERENA TASTINGS AND THOMAS
HANDLING. MAY THEIR PLANS THEY
BOTH SERVED TIME ON AS A US
REPRESENTATIVES. SO THEY KNEW
WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH THE
GOVERNMENT AND AN INDIAN COUNTRY
. HEADLEY WAS APPOINTED
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE ROUND
VALLEY RESERVATION. WHERE HE
AIDED AND ABETTED HIS FRIEND.
SERENUS WAS NOT JUST ANOTHER
ACTOR WHAT HE DID. STARTED A
SNOWBALL EFFECT. IT PUT SYSTEMS
IN PLACE FUNDED SYSTEMS. HE
ORGANIZED AN EFFORT TO CLEAR THE
LANDS OF THE UK AND THE MILITIA
OF PAID BY THE STATE. HE USED TO
MARK PROCEED TO KILL PEOPLE.
THERE ARE RECORDS OF ORDINARY
CITIZENS THAT WROTE LETTERS TO
THE GOVERNOR. ORDINARY PEOPLE
FROM MENDOCINO COUNTY. BUT TOLD
OF THE ATROCITIES BY THE
HORRIBLE SLAUGHTERING OF YOU
KEEP PEOPLE. THIS IS A QUOTE
FROM CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IN
EIGHTEEN SIXTY. ACCOUNTS ARE
COMING IN FROM THE COUNTIES ON
THE COAST RANGE. OF SICKENING
ATROCITIES AND WHOLESALE
SLAUGHTER SAID A GREAT NUMBERS
OF DEFENSELESS INDIANS. FOR THIS
FOR AN EVIL THIS OF THIS
MAGNITUDE. SOMEONE IS
RESPONSIBLE THERE ARE GOVERNMENT
OR CITIZENS OR BOTH OF TO BLAME
. WHEN HASTINGS WAS ALREADY A
PROMINENT STATESMEN. HE WROTE
GOVERNOR WILDER AND GOVERNOR
RULER WAS AT HIS PERSONAL FRIEND
OF HIS. PERSONAL LETTERS TO THE
GOVERNOR AND MILITARY COMMANDERS
PRESSURING THEM TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THE INDIANS SO THE LAND
WOULD BE CLEAR OF THEM WHILE.
WHAT AND WHEN THE WHITE SETTLERS
ARRIVED. HASTINGS KEPT
PRESSURING AND PRESSURING AND
OFFERING THEM MONEY FOR SALARY
AND SUPPLIES FOR THE MILITIA.
AND WHEN THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FINALLY AGREED
HASTINGS'S READY. THE MILITIA
WAS CALLED THE L. A. RIVER
RANGERS. IT WAS LED BY WALTER
DARBO. A WELL KNOWN VIOLENT
PSYCHOTIC KILLER. THIS CONFLICT
WAS COLD THE MENDOCINO WARS IT
WAS BETWEEN THE YANKEES AND THE
WHITE SETTLERS IN MENDOCINO
CALAMY LASTING FROM JULY
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE THREE
JANUARY EIGHTEEN SIXTY. IT WAS
BECAUSE BY SETTLER INTRUSION AND
SLAVE RAIDS ON NATIVE LAND
SUBSEQUENT MADE. A NATIVE
RETALIATION RESULTING IN THE
DEATHS OF HUNDREDS OF YUKI'S. IT
TOOK THE POPULATION OF MY PEOPLE
FROM TWENTY THOUSAND DOWNTO
THREE HUNDRED. AND ONLY IN SIX
MONTHS. HASTINGS WAS SURELY NO
ORDINARY GUY. THIS IS A VERY
TRAUMATIZING TO ME. DRAMATIZING
TO READ PRIVATE TRAUMATIZING TO
FILL THE HEARD OF MY ANCESTORS.
AND IS NOT. TO BE SEEN. NOT TO
BE. SEEING THE INVISIBLE. DO YOU
HAVE TO FIGHT TO BE SEEN DO YOU
COULD DO NOT WANT TO BE
INVISIBLE. WE WANT A TRANSPARENT
PROCESS WE DESERVE IT AND THE
PUBLIC DESERVES IT- ASKING TO
CHANGE THE NAME OF THE COLLEGE
INTO A YOU CAN NAME. IT'S VERY
MINIMAL THAT THE STATE CAN DO
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THIS
HISTORY. BECAUSE NOTHING WILL
CHANGE HISTORY. WE ARE ASKING
FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE ANY NAME FROM
OUR LANGUAGE SALUTE THE LAW
SCHOOL. AND THOSE WHO RETURN THE
INSTITUTION WILL BE PARTICIPANTS
IN RESTORATIVE JUSTICE EFFORTS
DALY. BY SPEAKING AND HELPING TO
REVITALIZE THE U. K. LANGUAGE.
THE NEW NAME SHOULD BE ONE THAT
WILL NEVER ALLOW US TO FORGET.
ALL THE UNTHINKABLE HORRORS AND
I MENTION WILL. ATROCITIES
SPONSORED AND DIRECTED BY
CERAMIST HASTINGS AND STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE PROPOSAL
DEFLATION IS AN ESSENTIAL FIRST
STEP IN THE TRAUMA HEALING
DELIVERY OF JUSTICE FOR THE
DESCENDANTS OF THE STATE
SPONSORED GENOCIDE THAT OCCURRED
SPECIFICALLY AT THE URGING AND
ACTIVITIES. SUPPORT ACTIVE
SUPPORT THE SERRATED MISS
HASTINGS THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
MEASURES INCLUDING THE NAME
CHANGE WILL AID IN SOME OF THE
SUFFERING OF THE ATROCITIES
ASSOCIATED WITH UC HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW'S NAMESAKE.
THE PICK UP PEOPLE HAVE SUFFERED
EFFECTS OF LOS AND HOMELAND.
GENOCIDAL MURDER OF HIS
ANCESTORS. GENOCIDAL PAIN.
GENERATIONAL PAIN AND TRAUMA.
FOR THE HEINOUS ACTS OF MISTER
HASTINGS FOR NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY YEARS. HE HAD A STUDIO.
LET JUSTICE BE DONE. SURE OF THE
- THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND FOR
REPRESENTING THE IRAQI PEOPLE
AND- THE ANCESTORS BEING ABLE TO
SPEAK HERE AND THE CHAMBERS-
HERE THE STATE LEGISLATURE
BRINGING TESTIMONY FORWARD. WHEN
I THANK YOU FOR THAT AND FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY IN BRINGING TO
LIGHT- TRULY FROM THE YUKI-
PEOPLE'S OWN WORDS INVOICES- THE
TRAUMA THAT'S BEEN INFLICTED
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON I WAS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY APPRECIATE YOU
SHARING. YOUR PAIN WITH ALL OF
US AND GIVING US OPPORTUNITY TO
RE WRITE THE WRONGS THAT HAVE
TAKEN PLACE IN IN THIS COUNTRY-
AND I WANT TO SAY YOUR RAVERY
HERE TODAY- IN THE WORDS HE SAID
SURE- ABOUT PEOPLE NEVER
FORGETTING WILL NEVER FORGET AND
THAT'S WORRY HERE TO RE WRITE
THE WRONG THAT HAS BEEN DONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ASSUME REGULATION I ALSO WANNA-
ACKNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
TEEN- PARTICIPATING HERE AND IN
THE SOME HEARING. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIANG. OUR
NEXT- PRESENTER IS A PRESIDENT
JIM RUSSELL THE RUN VALLEY
INDIAN TRIBES AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ROUND VALLEY INDIAN
HEALTH CENTER. HERE'S WHAT WHILE
LACKEY DESCENDED IN AN ENROLLED
MEMBER OF THE RUN VALLEY INDIAN
TRIBES. PRESIDENT RUSS HAS
WORKED AT THE HEALTH CENTER FOR
MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS PRIOR TO
THAT HE WORKED FOR THE TRIBE. AS
EDUCATION DIRECTOR FOR TEN
YEARS- MISTER PRESIDENT-RUSH
CAN YOU PLEASE COME FORWARD
OFFER YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
. FIRST OF LIKE TECHNOLOGY ARE
TROUBLED OVER. THANK YOU FOR
BEING MAIENSCHEIN VERY VERY
POWER. SECONDLY I'LL START TO
ADD LIKE TO START WITH GIVING
THANKS TO OUR CREATOR. THE GREAT
SPIRIT OUR LORD IN HEAVEN. THANK
YOU FOR HIM FOR THIS BEAUTIFUL
BEAUTIFUL DAY BRING US TOGETHER
TO DISCUSS THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES I WILL AFFECT ALL INDIAN
TRIBES. JUST A QUICK NOTE TODAY
WE FIND OURSELVES IN A WORLD
NEARLY AT WAR. THAT COULD ASKING
ESCALATE VERY QUICKLY AND
EFFECTIVE TIRE WORLD WE ALSO
FIND OURSELVES IN THE SECOND
YEAR OF A WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC.
THAT HAS AFFECTED. EVERY NATION
AND OUR COUNTRY AND EVERY
COMMUNITY- CERTAINLY OUR
COMMUNITY AROUND VALLEY. SO I
GUESS THE QUESTION BECOMES HOW
DO WE CARRY ON NORMAL BUSINESS
WHEN WE HAVE ALL OF THIS STUFF
GOING ON THAT'S WE SEE AROUND US
EVERY DAY. AND AND HOW DO WE
JUST CARRY ON OUR DAY TO DAY AND
LOOK AT RESOLVING ISSUES SUCH AS
THIS- WITH ALL THIS GOING ON.
HOWEVER WE'RE NOT HERE TODAY TO
SOLVE ALL THE WORLD'S PROBLEMS.
WE'RE HERE TODAYTO TALK ABOUT
AND FOCUS ON SOME OF THE INDIAN
ISSUES THAT WE DEAL WITH AND
MORE SPECIFICALLY THE ROUND ALI. I'D LIKE TO THANK A GERMAN
RAMOS AND ALSO ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE
ON NATIVE AMERICAN AFAIRS. FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THE RIVAL INDIAN
TRIBES. AND TO LET THE PROCESS
BEGIN OF TELLING OUR STORY. AS
MONA HAS REALLY SET THE TABLE ON
ON WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
TODAY. AND BUT ANYWAY IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO- THAT OUR
STORY BE TOLD. AND TO START THE
PROCESS. WHATEVER YOU KEY ELDERS
CAME INTO OUR- ONE OF OUR
MEETINGS IN ROUND VALLEY. AND
SHOES VERY FORTHRIGHT
FORTHCOMING AND FORTHRIGHT BY
STAYING THAT. ALL OF OUR TRIBES
AROUND ALI HAVE A STORY TO TELL.
AND IS MOST MOST SPECIFICALLY
THE UK'S WHO ARE INVOLVED IN A
LOT OF THIS TRAGIC. STUFF THAT
IS GONNA. ANSWER BUT- BUT WE
THANKED HER FOR COMING IN THAT
DAY TO BRING IT UP AND- THAT SHE
HAD SOME STORIES TO BE TOLD THAT
SHE TOLD US THAT DAY TOO. WHICH
BRINGS IT TO A PERSPECTIVE. THAT
THAT WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD AND
TRY TO WRITE SOME OF THESE WRONG
SEN. AND PORTRAY OUR HISTORY
ACCURATELY AND NOT AS IT IS AND
A LOT OF THE TEXTBOOKS. THAT WE
SAW THIS MORNING ON SOME OF THE-
PRESENTATIONS THAT CAME THIS
MORNING. AND WE ARE ESPECIALLY
GRATEFUL TO CHAIRPERSON ROSS.
FOR INTERVENING IN THIS PROCESS.
AND BRING THE FULL IMPACT OF
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. STARTING
WITH EDUCATION AND MOVING INTO
OTHER OTHER AREAS AND THEN BRING
IT TO THE FULL ATTENTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY SO
WE'D LIKE TO THANK YOU I'D LIKE
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR DOING
THAT. LIKE LIKE THE CHAIRMAN
SAID MY NAME IS JAMES ARE
ASSIGNED TO DO ELECTED PRESIDENT
ARAMBULA INDIAN TRIBES- I AM
ENROLLED MEMBER OF THE RIVAL
INDIAN TRIBES. AND I HAVE A- OF
WELKE AND I'M LUCKY TO SENT. I
WORK FOR A TRIBE IN EDUCATION
AND HEALTH CARE FOR NEARLY
THIRTY YEARS AND- IT'S BEEN A
REWARDING AND CHALLENGING BOTH.
I'D LIKE TO START BY TALKING A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE HISTORY
BECAUSE I KNOW A LOT OF OUR- OUR
LEGISLATIVE FOLKS- DON'T REALLY
KNOW ABOUT WITH OF OUR HISTORY
CAME ABOUT. SO THE HISTORY OF
OUR VALLEY. AND WHAT HAD
<c.red>APPENED IN OUR AREA. SO</c>
RANDOMLY HAS BEEN THE HEART OF
THE U. K. TERRY TERRITORY QUOTE
UNQUOTE SINCE TIME BEGAN. THE
ACCUSED OF THE YOU COULD PEOPLE
HAVE LIVED IN THEIR ANCESTRAL
HOMELAND STRETCHING FROM HOMA
BAY TO THE UPPER RIVER RUSSIAN
RIVER AREA. FOR OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND YEARS. PRIOR TO OTHER
TRIBES. COMING INTO THE AREA AND
THEN OF COURSE- WESTWARD
MOVEMENT AND- CONTACT WITH THE
OTHER- THE DOMINANT SOCIETY. SO
THE HISTORY OF THE ROUND
BUILDING AND TRIBES ARAMBULA
INDIAN TRIBES IS THE FEATHER
RECOGNIZED TRIBE. BEGINNING AS
THE COUPLE INDIAN COMMUNITY.
ARAMBULA EIGHT TRIBES IS A
CONFEDERATION OF TRIBES THE YUKI
WELL AKKI CONCO LITTLE IT POMA.
NORMAL OKAY AND PITT RIVER. THE
TRIBES WERE FORCED AND RELOCATED
ON TO THE LAND FORMERLY
INHABITED BY THE YOU COULD TRY.
THE WE ARE LOW IF YOU DON'T KNOW
WE ARE LOCATED IN NORTHEASTERN
MINNESOTA COUNTY OVER TOWARD THE
COAST- ARE LAND BASED IS THAT
NEARLY ARE APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
TWO THOUSAND ACRES. AND WE'RE
ONE OF THE OLDEST AND LARGEST
TRIBES IN. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT OUR MEMBERSHIP IS
GETTING CLOSE TO SIX THOUSAND-
AN OLD NUMBERS. ARAMBULA INDIAN
RESERVATION BEGAN IN EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SIX AS THE NON CALL FARM
AND ADMINISTRATOR EXTENSION OF
THE NON LUCKY RESERVATION
LOCATED ON THE NORTHEASTERN EDGE
OF THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY. THERE
PASSED CANADA ONE OF THE FIVE-
RESERVATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BY THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY
TWO. THE SYSTEM OF INDIAN
RESERVATIONS HAD A DUAL PURPOSE
TO PROTECT INDIANS BY
SEGREGATING THE HELP FROM THE
SELLERS CONVERGING ON CALIFORNIA
AND GREATER AND GREATER NUMBERS.
AND A FREE INDIAN LAND FOR THE
SELLER SAYS THEY CAME IN. AND AS
THEIR- POPULATION GROWTH. WHEN
THE RESERVATION WAS ESTABLISHED
THE U. K. PEOPLE AS THEY CAME TO
BE CALLED ARAMBULA WERE FORCED
INTO A DIFFICULT AN UNUSUAL
SITUATION THEIR TRADITIONAL
HOMEOWNERS NOT COMPLETELY TAKEN
OVER BY SELLERS AS IN OTHER
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA INSTEAD A
SMALL PART OF IT WAS RESERVED.
CALL THE RESERVATION. ESPECIALLY
FOR THE USE AS WELL AS USE OF
OTHER INDIANS WHO WERE-
FORCEFULLY IF LOCATED IN THAT
AREA AS WELL- MANY WHO MAY NOT.
I HAD WRITTEN DOWN ENEMIES BUT I
HESITATE TO USE THAT WORD
BECAUSE IT DOES- KIND OF A
REACTION HOW TRIBES GOT ALONG
AND I HAVE A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT SOME IMAGES
SAID THAT MANY OF WITH THE OTHER
TRIBES WHO BABY THEY DIDN'T SEE
EYE TO EYE ON A DAILY. BASIS HI
HUH. SO ANYWAY AND THAT'S JUST-
IT GOES THAT ARE AREAS. THE IF
YOU HAD TO SHARE THEIR HOME WITH
STRANGERS WHO SPOKE OTHER
LANGUAGES LIVED OTHER. LIVES
WITH OTHER BELIEFS AND WHO USE
THE LAND. AND ITS PRODUCT
DIFFERENTLY. THE OTHER TRIBES
THAT CAME AROUND EARLY AS THEY
DID. TWO OTHER RESERVATIONS BY
FORCE THE WORD DR WIDELY USED AT
THE TIME. IS A DESCRIPTIVE OF
THE PRACTICE OF ROUNDING UP
INDIANS AND DRIVING THEM LIKE
CATTLE. TO THE RESERVATIONS
WHERE THEY WERE CORRALLED BY
HIGH PICKET FENCES AND
SURROUNDED BY THE- THE CALVARY
TOWERS STATIONED THERE. SAID
STRIDES TOOK PLACE IN ALL
WEATHER AND SEASONS AND THE
ELDERLY ELDERLY AND SICK OFTEN
DID NOT SURVIVE. THE NON CALL
LOCK IS AN ANNUAL RE ENACTMENT
OF ONE OF THESE DRIVES AS- WE
KNOW ONE OF THE MOST FAMOUS ONE
IS THE- TRAIL OF TEARS WITH THE
CHEROKEES. ONE ARE RIGHT WHEN WE
STARTED THIS YEARS AGO MY
GRANDMOTHER WAS STILL ALIVE. AND
I TOOK HERS HI HOUSE OVERHEARD
HER SPEAKING WITH ANOTHER TRIBAL
ELDER. AND WHAT THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT WAS THEY SAID THIS
IS ONE FORCED RELOCATION. AND
THERE'S MANY MORE THAT THAT HAS
OCCURRED. BUT WE DO THIS TO
HONOR OUR PEOPLE THAT CAME
BEFORE US AND TO- TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THEIR SACRIFICE THAT THAT THEY-
FOR TRADE. IN AND BEING DRIVEN
IN BUT BEING BUT BEING SURVIVORS
TO SURVIVE SURVIVING THROUGH
THESE HARDSHIPS. IN PARTICULAR
THE LOCAL LAW- MANY MANY INDIANS
DIED THE WEATHER BEING DRIVEN
OVER THE MOUNTAIN OF THE
MINNESOTA NATIONAL FOREST. SIR
FROM YEARS OF INTERMARRIAGES
COMMON LIFESTYLE AND I SHARED
LAND BASED A UNIFIED COMMUNITY
HAS EMERGED. IN NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX UNDER THE INDIAN
REORGANIZATION ACT THIS
DESCENDANTS OF THE U. K. E. Y.
LUCKY CON KALIKA MALL. I'M A
LUCKY AND PITT RIVER FORMED A
NEW TRIBE ON THE RESERVATION
THROUGH THE ADOPTION OF A
CONSTITUTION AND CREATED THE
COLVILLE INDIAN COMMUNITY. LATER
TO BE CALLED ARAMBULA INDIAN
TRIBES. OUR HERITAGE IS A RICH
COMBINATION OF DIFFERENT
CULTURES WITH A COMMON
RESERVATION EXPERIENCE AND
HISTORY. RODELINDA TRIBE IS
FAIRLY NEW CAN OR TRAVEL
DYNAMICS. AS I JUST MENTIONED
THE MANY TRIBES THAT ARE THERE
HUNDRED FEDERAL RECOGNITION. SO
IT'S TAKEN YEARS AND YEARS OF
TRYING TO WORK TOGETHER TO
CREATE A STABLE- TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT. AND ESTABLISHOUR
TRAVEL PROGRAMS TO DELIVER
SERVICES TO OUR PEOPLE INCLUDING
OUR OUR- RUNDELL INDIAN HEALTH
CENTER LOCATED ON A RESERVATION. SO I JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND ON-
WHERE- WE ARE AND WHERE WE ARE.
AND THEN I'D LIKE TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS NOW ON THE HASTINGS LAW
INITIATIVE.
THE HASTINGS LINE INSTEAD OF.
WELL THE INTENT OF THE HASTINGS
LINUS SHOULD HAVE HAS BEEN TO
BRING AWARENESS MAY COMMENCE AND
DECIDE HOW TO MAKE UP FOR
HISTORICAL WRONGS COMMITTED BY
THE FOUNDER OF HASTINGS LAW
SCHOOL. SARAN ESSAY STINGS. THE
HASTINGS LINE INSTEAD OF HAS
BROUGHT MANY ISSUES TO THE
SURFACE IN OUR TRAVEL COMMUNITY.
THE ROUND VALLEY INDIAN TRIBES
WORK DILIGENTLY TO ADDRESS THE
ONGOING EFFECTS. OF HISTORICAL
TRAUMA. AND NATURALLY WE WANT TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN A MANNER
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO PROMOTE
WELL BEING. AND HEALING FOR
COMMUNITY OR COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
ARAMBULA INDIAN TRIBES HAS BEEN
ADVISED AND GUIDED BY THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE SOME OF OUR
ALMOST. TOO NOT JUST PARTICIPATE
IN THE NAME CHANGE. OF A LAW
SCHOOL BUT TO TAKE THE TIME TO
TELL THE STORY OF OUR NATIVE
PEOPLE. IN ROUND VALLEY AREA AND
IN ALL CALIFORNIA. OUR STORY
INCLUDES THE TO OUR STORY
INCLUDES THE GENOCIDE AND
ANNIHILATION OF OUR WAY OF LIFE.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE STORY OF THE
NATIVE PEOPLE. AND CALIFORNIA
TRIBES. ARE STORIES BEGIN WITH
OUR CREATION. SKEWS ME OUR
STORIES ARE LANGUAGES CUSTOMS
AND CULTURES ARE WHAT DEFINE US
AS A DISTINCT ETHNIC GROUPS. OUR
LEGAL RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
UNITED STATES IS WHAT DEFINES
STRIDES A SOVEREIGN NATIONS.
QUITE OBVIOUSLY EACH IS AN
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION BUT OUR
ETHNIC IDENTITY WAS DEFINED
HUNDREDS OF YEARS BEFORE CONTACT
WITH EUROPEANS AND WESTWARD
EXPANSION OF THE UNITED STATES.
ANOTHER KIND OF SUB ISSUE IS IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE A
GROUP OF SENATORS AND
REPRESENTATIVES. REEMERGES THE
TRUTH AND HEALING COMMISSION OF
INDIAN BOARDING SCHOOL POLICIES
THE UNITED STATES WHICH WE'VE
HEARD MORE DETAILS THIS MORNING
ON THE AND THE- PRESENTATIONS.
BUT THIS WOULD ESTABLISH A
COMMISSION TO INVESTIGATE
DOCUMENT AND THE KNOWLEDGE
PASSENGERS THIS IS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S INDIAN BOARDING
SCHOOL POLICIES. WE EXPERIENCED
IN ROUND VALLEY THE SAME TYPES
OF ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN TALKED
ABOUT THIS MORNING OF CHILDREN
BEING FORCIBLY REMOVED- AS WE
SAW WITH SOME OF THE QUOTES.
THIS MORNING ON THE
PRESENTATIONS THEY'RE PEOPLE
THAT WERE INVOLVED WITH THAT
FELT THAT THAT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. AND THAT THAT WAS
TRYING TO CIVILIZE THESE
BARBARIC PEOPLE THOUGHT THEY
LOOK AT US AS INDIAN PEOPLE. SO
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
JUST WHEN WE THINK ABOUT IT IS
NOT JUST FIVE HUNDRED YEARS AGO
THAT'S THAT'S IN THE LAST
HUNDRED YEARS THAT'S OUR OUR
GRANDPARENTS. MAYBE PERHAPS
GREAT GRANDPARENTS IN SOME CASES
ARE PARENTS. SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT REALLY- HITS HOME WITH US.
IT IS THE HOPE OF AROUND BILLION
IN SIZE OF THE HASTINGS LANA
SHIVERS WILL INSPIRE AND EQUALLY
IMPORTANT CAMPAIGN. TO TELL THE
TRUTH ABOUT ALL ASPECTS OF WHAT
THE NATIVE. PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
DURING THE CONTACT PERIOD. AND
POSTCOLONIALISM. ISN'T THIS
INITIATIVE HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
RE WRITE HISTORY BOOKS AND BRING
ABOUT A TRUTH THAT MAY BRING
IMPORTANT MEANINGFUL CHANGES. TO
WHAT IS KNOWN ABOUT THE SETTLERS
THAT CAME TO CALIFORNIA IN
SEARCH OF GOLD. AND WE HURT WITH
THE ENCOURAGEMENT OF MANIFEST
DESTINY. THE FUNDAMENTAL GOAL ON
BEHALF OF THE RUN BUILDING
ENTRANCES TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
INITIATIVE PROCESS WHICH
TRANSPARENCY TRANSPARENCY. AND
INTEGRITY. AND THE PRIMARY FOCUS
ON HEALING AND THE TRUTH TELLING
ACCURATE TRUTH TELLING. OF WHAT
HAPPENED TO OUR PEOPLE. IN ORDER
FOR US TO CONTINUE ALONG THE
HEALING PROCESS THIS HAS TO
HAPPEN IN THAT MANNER. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HAPPENED AT THE
COUNCIL LEVEL AT THE REVEL INTO
TO OUR ATTENTION WE STARTED
HAVING DISCUSSIONS ABOUT MEETING
WITH THE HASTINGS- FOLKS. AND
COLLEGE BOOKS AND STUFF BOARD
MEMBERS WAS THAT- I FELT VERY
STRONGLY PERSONALLY THAT WE DO
HAVE YOU FEW FOLKS THAT. CAN
SPEAK ON THEIR BEHALF AND CAN
PORTRAY THE ACTOR HISTORY ON
THEIR OWN BEHALF. SO THE
COUNCIL- SANCTIONED UP COMMITTEE
TO MEET WITH THE HOSTING PEOPLE
THE LEGACY- OR START OF JUSTICE.
AND SO THAT WAS DONE BY- A
COUNCIL RESOLUTION AND THE
REASON I FELT VERY STRONGLY THAT
IS ABOUT THAT FACT IS WE HAVE TO
LADIES HERE TODAY. THAT ARE VERY
CAPABLE OF TALKING ABOUT THEIR
TRIBES AND THEIR HISTORIES I
WILL HAPPEN TO THEM. ANNA AND
THEIR STORIES SO- SO THE COUNCIL
DID APPROVE THAT AND WE ARE
MOVING AHEAD WITH THAT SO WE
WENT THROUGH I JUST WANNA MAKE
ONE QUICK QUICK COMMENT ABOUT
THAT. SO WE'VE GONE THROUGH ALL
OF THE- STORMING INFORMING AND
NORMING. MOST COMMITTEES GO
THROUGH. AND SO- BUT THAT'S YOU
KNOW THE WAY IT GOES AND IT
TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO
PULL THINGS TOGETHER. AND TO-
DEFINE YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
REALLY WORKING TOWARDS AND
DEFINE OUR COMMON GOALS
TOGETHER. AND SO IT'S BEEN A
PROCESS AND WE'RE STILL GOING
THROUGH THAT PROCESS- LET ME SEE. THE FUNDAMENTALS SO THE
FUNDAMENTAL ON BEHALF OF THE
REVELERS TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
INITIATIVE PROCESS WHAT'S
TRANSPIRED IN INTEGRITY AND THE
PRIMARY FOCUS ON HEALING AND
TRUTH TELLING HOW THIS OCCURS
THE PENCIL ALL OF US THAT ARE
INVOLVED. THE RAVALLI- DO YOU
COULD TRAVEL MEMBERS THE RAVALLI
COUNCIL- HASTINGS LAW GROUP YOU
KNOW WE'RE STILL COMING TOGETHER
ON THESE ISSUES- WHICH WE'VE-
WORKED INTO- THE PROCESS THAT
WE'RE CALLING INITIATIVES. AND
IS IT JUST TAKES TIME IT TAKES
TIME TO IDENTIFY THIS-
ATTENTIONAL WAYS THAT WE COULD
PARTNER AND HOW WE WORK- WITH
EACH OTHER ADD TO FOR COMMON
GOALS AND TO CREATE SOME TYPE
OF- RESOLUTION AND SOLUTIONS TO
THESE ISSUES THAT ARE COMING UP. BUT DURING THIS TIME WHEN I'M
TALKING ABOUT- COMING TOGETHER
AND STORMING AND NORMING AND
PERFORMING- AND WORKING
TOGETHER- IT HAS CREATED-
KIDDING. ALL THESE THINGS POINT
TO A MUCH DEEPER. DEEPER ISSUES
OF UNRESOLVED GRIEF THE PAIN OF
MULTI GENERATIONAL TRAUMA. AND A
TRIBAL TRIBAL COMMUNITY FIND BY
ITS HISTORY OF COLONIZATION. NOW
THAT THESE WOUNDS HAVE BEEN
RESURRECTED. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN JUST BELOW THE
SURFACE FOR A VERY VERY LONG
TIME. WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
RAVALLI TRIBES CALLS FOR
ASSISTANCE IN ADDRESSING THE
HARM THAT HAS THAT THIS EFFORT
HAS COST. CURRENTLY ALL PARTIES
OF THE NEW SHOULD HAVE
IDENTIFIED THE FOLLOWING WAYS OF
MAKING AMENDS FOR THE PAST
ATROCITIES WHICH I JUST REFERRED
TO AS THE INITIATIVE- OF MISTER
HASTINGS. WELL THIS LIST WAS
CREATED WITH INPUT FROM ALL
PARTIES THE TRIBE HEREBY
RECOMMENDS ADDITIONAL EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE STRUGGLE TRAUMA. OF
NOT JUST THE PEOPLE BUT ALL
NATIVE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
BEGIN WITH THIS MAY LOOK LIKE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
YET TO BE DEFINED. I'D LIKE TO
TAKE JUST A MOMENT TO. IT'S TO
STRESS OF JUST A FEW- OF SOME OF
THE BROADER ISSUES THAT WE DEAL
WITH AS A TRIBE JUST TO BRING IT
TO THE ATTENTION OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE AND TO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY IN GENERAL.
SO SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
DEAL WITH ON A DAILY BASIS AND-
AND HAVE DEALT WITH FOR YEARS AS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND- ALSO IN TERMS OF
JUST COMMUNICATION- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT CAME TO OF I HAD
THAT WAS VERY RELEVANT. IN THE
DURING THIS PANDEMIC WAS OUR
CHILDREN WERE NO LONGER ALLOWED
TO GO TO SCHOOL THEY WERE TOLD
TO STAY HOME AND- WERE ALLOWED
TO GO INTO THE CLASSROOMS. AND
SO THEN THEY WERE TOLD THAT WELL
YOU CAN ZOOM IN. OUR TO VARIOUS
THINGS. THE PROBLEM WE HAD WITH
THAT WAS WE HAD NO ACCESS. ON A
RESERVATION TO- HIGH SPEED
LINES- WE HAVE ONE OUTSIDE
COMPANY THAT. WAS HAD- FEW COULD
OR GET HIGH SPEED INTERNET BUT
IT WAS A VERY HIGH SPEED. AND SO
WAS AND IT CERTAINLY WASN'T- BUT
NOW IF IT WASN'T SUFFICIENT FOR
OUR KIDS TO LEARN. SO WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON OUR OWN ISSUES WITHIN
THE VALLEY OF TRYING TO START
OUR OWN. CELL TOWER SYSTEM TO
GET THOSE- UP AND RUNNING AND
GET OUR KIDS TO HAVE ACCESS AND
OUR FOLKS TO IN THE VALLEY TO
HAVE ACCESS TO. HIGH SPEED LINE
HIGH SPEED LINES ANOTHER VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE FORCES
EDUCATION. AND I KNOW WE'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT IT IN
EDUCATION THERE'S A LOTOF WORK
TO BE DONE. THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US. AS A TRIBE.
AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD. WE HAVE
ONE- LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
ROUND VALLEY. AND WITHIN ABOUT
THE LAST FIVE YEARS- WE HAD
ABOUT 80% OF OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT WAS INDIAN KIDS. AND
SO- BUT WE STILL DEAL WITH THE
SAME ISSUES EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
THE LARGEST POPULATION. WE STILL
DEAL WITH THE SAME ISSUES THAT
YOU HEAR FROM OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AS WELL. AND BASICALLY
JUST TO SUM IT UP IN ONE WORD.
IT'S JUST REYES RACIST IT'S
BLATANT RACISM. THAT WE DEAL
WITH ALMOST ON A DAILY BASIS. SO
WE HAVE SOME HUGE CHALLENGES IN
EDUCATION AND WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
TO WORK THROUGH THEM- ANOTHER
ISSUE THAT I'D LIKE TO BRING TO
THE ATTENTION IS- WE DO HAVE A-
RIVAL INDIAN HEALTH CENTER IF
THIS LOCATED ON A RESERVATION.
AND IT'S ONE OF THE OLDEST
HEALTH CENTERS THAT WAS AROUND
TOO STARTED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. BUT ANYWAY- IN NIGHT IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE THE INDIAN HEALTH STATE
IN HEALTH PROGRAM WAS CUT. FROM
THE BUDGET ENTIRELY. AND SINCE
THEN AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE HITS- DEFICIT BUDGET
DEFICIT IN THE STATE NEEDED TO
DO SOMETHING TO BALANCE THE
BUDGET. BUT ALL OF THE PROGRAMS
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WERE CUT
DURING THAT TIME WE'RE ALL HAVE
ALL BEEN REINSTATED. EXCEPT FOR
OUR PROGRAM. SO I KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN A BILL AND THERE'S
BEEN SOME- ADVOCACY ON THE PART
OF GERMAN AROUND WE'RE ALMOST
ANOTHER LEGISLATORS. TO TRY TO
REINSTALL THAT PROGRAM ON IT ON
AN ONGOING BASIS. SO IT'S VERY
IT'S CRUCIAL TO- TO OUR ENDED
HEALTH. AND TO OUR COMMUNITY SO
I'D REALLY LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
THAT. THE OTHER ISSUE THAT I'D
LIKE TO BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION
AS THE- MMI W. MURDERED. MISSING
INDIGENOUS WOMEN. SO WE HAD SET
A VERY HIGH PROFILE. CASE THAT
WAS BROUGHT TO THE ATTENTION OF
NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA BUT PROBABLY
THE COUNTRY. BUT IT HAD SOME
WITH THE FOR US VERY- RIGHT TO
THE CORE OF OUR HEART. AS WE
HAD- ONE YOUNG LADY IN OUR
COMMUNITY WAS BRUTALLY
ASSAULTED. SHE'S RIGHT NOW IN UC
DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER AND SO SHE
IS JUST CLINGING TO LIFE SHE'S
STILL ALIVE SELUK FORTUNATELY
SHE WAS FOUND. BUT THIS IS
ANOTHER THING THAT WE NEED TO
BRING TO THE FOREFRONT ON BEHALF
FOR INDIAN INDIGENOUS WOMEN.
DOES THAT THIS HAPPENS FAR TOO
OFTEN AND WE NEED TO COME TO
SOME TYPE OF SOLUTIONS- WORKING
COLLECTIVELY TOGETHER. WITH
STATE GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OF COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS. TO TRY TO DO
SOMETHING AND I'LL COME TO SOME
RESOLUTIONS ON THIS PROBLEM TO
WHICH IS AFFECTING- ALL OVER
RESERVATIONS. SO I'D LIKE TO IN
BY. I JUST KIND OF SUMMING UP ON. THIS WORDS THAT I'M GONNA BE
TALKING ABOUT- FROM ONE OF OUR
GREAT LOOK COULD OF LEADERS. I
CAN FIND THEM. I THINK THIS IS
KIND OF FITTING TEN WITH- THIS
IS BY ONE OF OUR LOCAL LEADER
SITTING BULL. LAWYERS ARE NOT
WHAT YOU THINK OF AS LAWYERS THE
LAWYERS NOT SOMEONE WHO FIGHTS
FOR NO ONE HAS THE RIGHT TO TAKE
ANOTHER LIFE. THE WARRIOR FOR US
IS THE ONE WHO SACRIFICES
HIMSELF FOR GOOD FOR THE GOOD OF
OTHERS. HIS TASK IS TO TAKE CARE
OF THE ELDERLY THE DEFENSELESS
THOSE WHO CANNOT PROVIDE FOR
THEMSELVES AND ABOVE ALL THE
CHILDREN. THE FUTURE OF HUMANITY
. AND- AND WITH THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU-
RESEARCHERS- RUSS FOR YOUR- WERE
TESTIMONY AND BRING IT TO LIFE-
THE ISSUES THAT STILL PLAGUE-
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICANS AND
PARTICULARLY- THE TRIBES HERE AS
FAR AS THE- WHAT STILL IS GOING
ON TODAY RIGHT MISS EMERGING AS
SOME. WOMEN PERSONS ON FEDERAL
RESERVATIONS AND OUR OUR HEART
NO REFERRALS OUT TO YOUR MEMBER
WHO IS IN UC DAVIS AND IN THE
HOSPITAL RECOVERING FROM THOSE
AREAS BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE
HAPPENING STILL IN THE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO BRING THAT ATTENTION.
WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE ARE MOVING FORWARD
ON TACKLING THOSE ISSUES-
BROADBAND ANOTHER ISSUE OF OUR
AND OUR COLLEAGUES HERE WE
WORKED ON BROADBAND LAST SESSION
WHERE WE INCLUDED- TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES IN THAT LANGUAGE.
WILL BE FORWARD BUT THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THAT AND THANK YOU
TO THE TESTIMONY- MONA- FOR
BRINGING FULL CIRCLE FROM YOUR
OWN VOICES RIGHT THE TRUSTEES
THAT HAPPENED I THINK THAT'S
VERY. VERY IMPORTANT AS THIS
PROCESS CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD AND NOW I'D LIKE TO
BRING UP- DEAN- DAVID HAGEMAN
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
THE LAW. CHANCELLOR AND DEAN HE
IS- THE JOHN DAVID A
DISTINGUISHED PROFESSOR. AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF. HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF. AS PROFESSOR IN THE SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE DEPARTMENT OF
PSYCHIATRY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IN SAN FRANCISCO. I
COULD HAVE THE D. AND MOVE
FORWARD. BUT AROUND MOST- FAMILY
MEMBERS MATHIS AND TANG- MISTER
TENDER TO SEE YOU AGAIN- I HAVE
A PREPARED STATEMENT- THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE. OUR
SUBJECT TODAY IS VERY IMPORTANT
HOW THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAW
SHOULD RESPOND TO THE EVILS
COMMITTED BY CIVIC AND
GOVERNMENT LEADERS AGAINST THE
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES OF
CALIFORNIA. IN THE MID NINETEEN
TH CENTURY INCLUDING THE FOUNDER
OF OUR LAW SCHOOLS AROUND THE
SAFE THINGS. THE OF WHITE
SETTLERS TREAT OF INDIGENOUS
TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA. IS ONE OF
BLOOD TEARS. HEARTACHE AND-MISERY. IS A HISTORY THAT I WAS
LARGELY UNFAMILIAR WITH UNTIL
THE FIRST YEAR OF MY REGULAR
DEANSHIP. THOUGH OF COURSE SO
GENERALLY FAMILIAR WITH THE
ATROCITIES CARRIED OUT BY
SETTLERS ACROSS NORTH AMERICA.
HOWEVER SHORTLY AFTER MY
DEANSHIP BEGAN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND OP ED APPEARED IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE
DETAILING THE PARTICIPATION OF
TWO INDIVIDUALS IN PARTICULAR
WHO HAD PRESTIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS
NAMED IN THEIR HONOR. ONE WAS WE
WENT STANFORD AND THE OTHER WAS
OUR SCHOOLS FOUNDER SERINUS
LISTINGS. THE FIRST CHIEF
JUSTICE AND THE FIRST ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF CALIFORNIA. AFTER
SEEING THIS OP ED I READ TWO
BOOKS ON THE SUBJECT THAT HAD
RECENTLY BEEN PUBLISHED ONE BY
BENJAMIN MADLEY AND AMERICAN
GENOCIDE AND THE OTHER BY
BRANDON WINS THE MURDER STATE.
BOTH OF THESE BOOKS TOLD THE
GRUESOME STORY OF CALIFORNIA'S
PRACTICE UNDER COLOR OF LAW. OF
REMOVING NATIVE AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA FROM THEIR LAND BY
WHATEVER MEANS NECESSARY
INCLUDING BY KILLING AND
ENSLAVING NATIVE PEOPLES. IN
EACH OF THOSE BOOKS WRITERS WHO
THINGS OCCUPIED TO DISCUSSION OF
PARAGRAPHS. STILL HIS SUPPORT
AND PROMOTION OF KILLINGS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA MADE HIM AN
ACCOMPLICE TO THE GREATER CRIMES
AGAINST HUMANITY THAT OCCURRED
IN THE EIGHTEEN FIFTIES AND
BEYOND. SHORTLY AFTER READING
THESE BOOKS I CONSTITUTED A
COMMITTEE IN THE SPRING OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHAT CAME TO BE
KNOWN AS THE HASTINGS LEGACY
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR LEGACY
COMMITTEE. TO THEM IN OUR
FOUNDERS ACTIONS AND THEN AND TO
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO ME ABOUT
THE BEST PATH FORWARD.
ADDITIONALLY I F. PROFESSOR
BRENDAN LINDSAY AUTHOR OF MURDER
STATE. TO PREPARE A WHITE PAPER
TO FURTHER RESEARCH THE SPECIFIC
ACTIONS OF SERINUS HASTINGS. IN
THE FOLLOWING THREE YEARS THE
LEGACY COMMITTEE COMPLETED
SUBSTANTIAL WORK IN PARTICULAR
THE COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY THE
THEN. THE HUSING BOARD OF
DIRECTORS TOM GETTING HIMSELF IN
INDIAN LAW EXPERTS. REACHED OUT
TO SEVERAL TRIBAL GROUPS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
THE ROUND VALLEY INDIAN TRIBES
AND THE CEO. AN INTER TRIBAL
WILDERNESS COUNCIL. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEVERAL TRIPS TO YOU
KYRA AND COBLE- THE LATTER BEING
THE CEO OF THE ROUND VALLEY
TRIBAL COUNCIL. I HAD THE HONOR
OF JOINING SEVERAL OF THESE
MEETINGS IN BOTH U. KADA AND
KOBYLA. OTHER THE CHARGE OF THE
LEGACY COMMITTEE WAS TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE TEAM
REGARDING WHAT RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE EFFORT SHOULD BE
CONTEMPLATED. IT SOON BECAME
CLEAR THAT THE ANSWER TO THIS
QUESTION DEPENDED ON DEVELOPING
A RELATIONSHIP WITH THE AFFECTED
TRIBES OF ROUND VALLEY. IN
PARTICULAR THE TRIBE GENERALLY
KNOWN AS THE U. P. MANY TRIBAL
MEMBERS HOWEVER ASKED US TO USE
ALTERNATIVE NAMES FOR THEM SINCE
YOU KEEP ORIGINALLY MEANT AN
ENEMY ANOTHER TRIBE'S LANGUAGE
NAME SUGGESTED TO A SEVERITY BUT
INCLUDING NAM HOANG- WOULD TO
COME WITH TOOK NAM AND PEOPLE
EVEN AROUND. ADAM FOR THEIR WE
AS WELL AS THE FUNDAMENTAL THAT
EACH OF US AS SOVEREIGNS OVER
OUR OWN AND OUR COLLECTIVE
DESTINY YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DECIDE FOR OURSELVES WHAT OUR
NAME SHOULD BE. I SHALL REFER TO
THE MOST DEEPLY AFFECTED FIVE
WITH RUNNERS HE THINGS ACTIONS
AS THE PEOPLE OF EDEN AND ROUND
HOURS. FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THROUGH THE PRESIDENT THE
COLLEGE HAS SOUGHT TO DEVELOP A
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR V. I. T.
AS THE SOVEREIGN REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE CONFEDERATION OF TRIBES
OF BROWN'S OUT. AS WELL AS THE
PEOPLE OF EVEN IN ROUND VALLEY.
BASED ON OUR SEVERAL MEETINGS
WITH TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVES AS
WELL AS THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE LEGACY COMMITTEE. I NEED TO
REPORT TO THE HASTINGS BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY. IN THAT REPORT I
RECOMMENDED THAT THE COLLEGE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH R. B. I.
T. AND THE PEOPLE OF THE EVENING
AROUND OUR USE AND FOCUS ON
DEVELOPING TRUST AND FRIENDSHIP.
WHICH WOULD BE THE FOUNDATION
FOR RESTORATIVE OPPORTUNITIES
GOING FORWARD. MY REPORT
RECOMMENDED CONCENTRATING ON
CONCRETE WAYS TO BUILD A
PARTNERSHIP. A COLLABORATION.
INDEED A FRIENDSHIP BETWEEN OUR
TWO COMMUNITIES ON OUR CAMPUS I
CREATED THE SUCCESSOR TO THE
LEGACY COMMITTEE. BY DESIGNATING
A GROUP OF STUDENTS STAFF
FACULTY AND ALUMNI TO SERVE ON A
DEEP CLEAN- RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
ADVISORY BOARD BUT YOU COME
KNOWN AS OUR JOB. HOW
DIFFERENTIALS CONTINUED TO MEET
DURING THIS TIME WITH TRIBAL
MEMBERS BUT IN PERSON MEETING
FOR LIMITED BY BOTH THE GLOBAL
COVERT PANDEMIC AND WILDFIRES
THAT RAGED ACROSS ROUND VALLEY.
NONE THE LESS THE COUCHES MOVE
FORWARD ON A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES INCLUDING
DESIGNATING A SPACE IN THE LOBBY
OF OUR MAIN ADMINISTRATION
BUILDING MARY KAY CAN HALL TO
COMMEMORATE THE HISTORY AND
EXPERIENCES OF THE PEOPLE OF
EATING AROUND VALERIE'S. WE WERE
GIVEN A GIFT OF TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM AN ALARM
TO SUPPORT THE GATHERING OF
NARRATIVE. FROM TRIBAL ELDERS
WHICH COULD BE WHICH COULD BE
ARCHIVED IN OUR LIBRARY AND
SHARED WITH OUR STUDENTS IN THE
COMMEMORATIVE SPACE. IN TWENTY
TWENTY RECREATED THE INDIGENOUS
LAWCENTER LED BY PROFESSOR JOE
CARILLO. THE INDIGENOUS
LAWCENTER HAS BEEN VERY ACTIVE.
IN INVITING DISTINGUISHED
VISITING SCHOLARS IN INDIAN LAW
AND WORKING WITH THE RAHMATULLAH
SALONI ON WHOSE ANCESTRAL LANDS
THE COLLEGES SITUATED TO DRAFT A
LANDED KNOWLEDGE MINT. THIS YEAR
THE COUCHES FUNDED FOR SUMMER
GRANTS FOR STUDENTS TO WORK WITH
LEGAL AID AND TRIBAL COURTS
SERVING THE INDIGENOUS PEOPLES
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING THE TRIBES AROUND OUR
- IT IS THUS IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE COUCH HAS
BEEN INVOLVED IN DEFINING AND
CARRYING OUT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
EFFORTS WITH OUR V. I. T. AND
THE PEOPLE HERE IN ROUND VALLEY
FOR OVER FOUR YEARS FOR THE
SCHOOL THIS IS A MATTER OF
UTMOST IMPORTANCE. BOTH IN TERMS
OF WHAT A LAW SCHOOL MIGHT DO IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE TRIBES
AROUND VALLEY AS WELL AS HOW OUR
STUDENTS CAN BENEFIT BY LEARNING
THE HISTORY OF NINETEENTH
CENTURY CALIFORNIA. AND THE
START OF OUR EFFORTS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND INDEED IN THE
TITLE TO THE OP ED MENTIONED
ABOVE. THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
HE SINGS HIS NAME SHOULD BE
CONTINUED TO BE A FIX TO OUR
GREAT LAW SCHOOL. HAS BEEN PART
OF THE CONVERSATION. THE LEGACY
COMMITTEE CONSIDERED IT AND
RECOMMENDED THAT FOR THE TIME
BEING RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
EFFORTS TO BE THE FOCUS OF OUR
WORK. IN MY REPORT TO THE BOARD.
I TO RECOMMENDED KEEPING THE
FOCUS ON RESTORATIVE JUSTICE-
REDWOOD RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
EFFORTS AND NOT SEEKING YOUR
NAME FAN. HEY SAFE WATER
DIRECTORS ACCEPTED THAT INITIAL
RECOMMENDATION UNANIMOUSLY. OVER
THESE FOUR PLUS YEARS THE ISSUE
OF CHANGING THE NAME OF THE
SCHOOL HAS BEEN COMPLICATED THE
NUMBER OF WAYS. THE COLLEGES
COMMUNITY WAS DEEPLY DIVIDED ON
THE MATTER IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
TRIBAL LEADERS THEY TO INDICATED
THE DESIRE TO EMPHASIZE
RESTORATIVE EFFORTS AND WAY FOR
US TO BUILD TRUST AND A
CONTINUING GROUP CONTINUING
FRIENDSHIP. IN OUR IN PERSON
MEETING WITH THE PEOPLE OF YOU
AROUND THE HOUSE IN AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN SAN
FRANCISCO THE ISSUE THE NAME WAS
DISCUSSED AT SOME LENGTH BUT
AGAIN IT WAS A FAIR DEGREE OF
DIVISION AMONG THE ASSEMBLED. OF
COURSE THE ISSUE THE SCHOOL'S
NAME IS DEEPLY COMPLICATED BY
THE FACT THAT HOW DOES A
STATUTORY. AND CONSTITUTIONAL
ENTITY AND DOES NOT HAVE
UNILATERAL POWER TO CHANGE ITS
NAME. CHANGING THE NAME IS NOT
THAT STRAIGHTFORWARD OR SIMPLE
MATTER. IN ANY CASE FOLLOWING
THE NEW YORK TIMES STORE
LEFTOVER TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ENTITLED SCHOOL
FACES FOUNDERS ROLE IN NATIVE
KILLINGS. THE ISSUE THE
COLLEGE'S NAME BECAME A NATIONAL
ISSUE. AS WE HAVE FOUND
THROUGHOUT THESE PAST FOUR YEARS
THE DEBATE ABOUT THAT NAME
SHOULD SOON ALL OTHER
CONVERSATIONS INTENSE UNDERMINE
SUFFER THAT FOR TO BUILD LASTING
RELATIONSHIPS IN FURTHERANCE OF
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. ANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH SENIOR
LEADERS AT THE COLLEGE AS WELL
AS MEMBERS OF THE HOUSTON FORTY
DIRECTORS I BROUGHT TO THE BOARD
THE QUESTION OF WHETHER THE
COLLEGE SHOULD SEEK LEGISLATION
TO CHANGE THE NAME OF THE
SCHOOL. IN DECEMBER THIS PAST
DECEMBER THE HAITIAN BORDER
DIRECTORS VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO
DIRECT ME TO WORK WITH
LEGISLATORS AND THE GOVERNOR TO
CHANGE THE NAME. SINCE THAT TIME
WE HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
MEETING WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
RAMOS AND TANG. SENATOR WIENER
OTHER LEGISLATORS ELECTED
LEADERSHIP OF OUR V. I. T. AND
MEMBERS OF THE PEOPLE EVEN
AROUND VALUES DISCUSS HOW BEST
TO MOVE FORWARD. THERE TWO
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES THAT NOW FACE
CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS. THE FIRST
IS WHETHER THE NAME HASTINGS
SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM THE
CALLING. THE CROWDED BOARD OF
DIRECTORS IS NOTED VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO DO SO AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS NOW THE
RIGHT COURSE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE TO. THIS APPEARS TO
BE A VIEW SHARED BY OUR V. I. T.
pROUND OUT. THE QUESTION RESOLVED
DOWN TO WHETHER IN THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY A GREAT LAW SCHOOL
SHOULD CONTINUE TO HONOR TO
ANTICIPATE THINGS. AFTER
LEARNING OF HIS ACT PROMOTING
THE KILLING OF CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICANS IN THE LATE EIGHTEEN
FIFTIES WE BELIEVE THAT THE
ANSWER IS CLEAR. THAT IT SHOULD
NOT. THE SECOND ISSUE IS WHAT
SHOULD BE THE NAME OF THE SCHOOL
GOING FORWARD. THE COLLEGES
BOARD OF DIRECTORS VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY IN A SECOND MEETING
IN DECEMBER TO RECOMMEND TO THE
LEGISLATURE IF YOU SAN FRANCISCO
TO DESIGNATE THE SCHOOL. THIS IS
THE SCHOOL'S REQUEST WHICH IS
BASED ON NUMEROUS CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING. FIRST THE COLLEGE HAS
BEEN IN SAN FRANCISCO FROM ITS
FOUNDING FOR NOW OVER ONE
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR YEARS IS
LOCATED IN THE HEART OF THE
CITY. WITHIN URBAN CAMPS- CAMPUS
IT OVERLOOKS CITY HALL IT IS
WITHIN BLOCKS OF VIRTUALLY EVERY
CITY STATE AND NATIONAL AGENCIES
IN COURT. THE SCHOOL IS THEN IS
VAST UNIQUELY ASSOCIATED. WITH
THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
SECONDLY UNIFORM AND DEFAULT
DESIGNATION FOR ALL UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES IS
THERE GEOGRAPHIC HOME. THIRD
THESE TO SAN FRANCISCO ON THE
COLLEGE'S NAME IS SUPPORTED BY
PRESIDENT MICHAEL DRAKE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND SEN
AND CHANCELLOR SAM HOLD THE OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO. IF WE RETURN THIRD
FOURTH IF WE RETURN TO EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT AND SURRENDERS
HASTINGS WITH HAD NOT BESTOWED
HIS NAME ON THE SCHOOL THE
COLLEGE AS THE FIRST LAW
DEPARTMENT OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD MOST LIKELY
HAVE BEEN NAMED. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF THE LAW
SAN FRANCISCO. AND FIFTH AND
FINAL THIS HAS BEEN DEMONSTRATED
REPEATEDLY IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
PEOPLE EDEN AND RANTAU IS A
FIRST PRINCIPLE OF SOVEREIGNTY
WHETHER IT'S A PERSON OR AS A
COMMUNITY IS TO CHOOSE BY WHAT
NAME YOU WISH TO THE CALL. WE
WISH THE DIFFERENCE WILL BE
HONORED IN THE CASE OF OUR GREAT
LAW SCHOOL. HE THINKS HOW TO THE
LAW HAS A RICH AN HONOR HISTORY.
ITS GRADUATES INCLUDE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES FEDERAL
AND STATE LEGISLATORS. US
ATTORNEYS AND DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND DEFENSE
COUNSEL. OTHER DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THE LEGAL PROFESSION
AND THE CURRENT THREAT THE
CURRENT VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES. AS A SCHOOL WE
ARE DEDICATED TO CONTINUING
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE EFFORTS.
THAT BENEFIT BOTH OUR COMMUNITY
AND THE INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES
AROUND VALLEY AND IDEAL WAY
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. THESE EFFORTS WERE
FREELY EMBRACE MORE THAN FOUR
YEARS AGOAND WILL CONTINUE INTO
THE FUTURE WE WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE TRIBES
AND PEOPLES AROUND AROUND VOWED
TO REMOVE THE NAME HASTINGS.
FROM THE COLLEGE AND BEGIN A NEW
CHAPTER IN THE DISTINGUISHED
HISTORY OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF THE LAW
SAN FRANCISCO. THIS IS BEEN A
JOURNEY OF GROWTH AND LEARNING.
I UNDERSTAND THE NEW WAVE THE
IMPASSABLE AT THIS STORE COULD
TRAUMA AND OF HEALING. I AM
GRATEFUL TO PRESIDENT RUSS FOR
HIS FRIENDSHIP AND HIS
PARTNERSHIP. I'M ALSO HUMBLED
AND THANKFUL FOR THE FRIENDSHIP
AND TRUST TO THE PEOPLE. OF EVEN
VALLEY WHO HAVE COME TO KNOW.
AMONG THEM ARE THE MCDOWELL A.
P. DOING FAMILY FARM ON THE TO
READ A STATEMENT FROM THEM NOW.
FROM THE DALLES AND PETE AND
FAMILY WHO ARE- DESCENDANTS OF
EVEN VALLEY. HERE ON A BOAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES RAMOS AS
WE ADDRESS THE MATTER THE NAME
CHANGE OF HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
LAW LET US FIRST ADDRESS OUR OWN
NAME. AS DIRECT DESCENDANTS OF
THE WOOD WITH THE TOP TOOK NON
PEOPLE OF UC'S THE MAHANE KNOWN
TODAY AS YOU'D BE THE WORD YUKI
MEANS ENEMY AND WE ARE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO ACQUIRE THIS NOW IN
THE FUTURE THAT WE ARE NOT YOUR
ENEMY. OUR PEOPLE WERE HERE
BEFORE THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT. WE WERE HERE BEFORE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE WERE
HERE BEFORE SERINUS HASTINGS WE
WERE HERE BEFORE THE ROUND
VALLEY INDIAN TRIBES AND WE ARE
STILL HERE WE ARE THE
AUTOCHTHONOUS OF THE LAND. WE
ARE THOUGH IT TOOK NON PEOPLE OF
UC'S FILLED. KNOWN TODAY AS EVEN
VALLEY. WE RECOGNIZE OUR
INHERENT SOVEREIGN RIGHT FROM
OUR CREATOR TO THIS PLAN AND
HELP BRING FORGIVENESS OR
REDEMPTION TO THE VICTIMS AND
THE PERPETRATORS. WITH THIS
FORGIVENESS WE WALKING THE
FREEDOM AND BLESSING GIVEN BY
OUR CREATOR TO ASK THAT THE NAME
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW AND THE
BOARD FEET OF THE AIR OF
SERENITY HASTINGS. REMAIN IN
PLACE. IT IS THIS FORGET THAT WE
CAN BRING REAL TRUTH AND HEALING
TO OUR PEOPLE AND TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THIS ACTOR
FORGIVENESS HOPE THIS MOVE
TOWARDS RECONCILIATION
RESTORATION ENSURING THAT THERE
IS JUSTICE AND LIBERATION OF OUR
PEOPLE. WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
JUST THE BEGINNING OF THE
PROCESS BUT WE MUST FIRST AND
FOREMOST START WITH THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR EXISTENCE. AT
THE END THERE WRITER I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY IN
YOUR ATTENTION. THANK YOU- SO
MUCH- FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- DEAN
FAGAN AND I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR- TO THE COMMITTEE AND TO
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IN THOSE-
WATCHING ON TELEVISION WE DO
HAVE THE REPRESENTATION OF THE
PRESIDENT ARAMBULA TRIBES AND-
MONA REPRESENT YOU KEEP PEOPLE
THROUGH THE RESOLUTION FROM THE-
THE TRIBAL. GOVERNMENT FROM
AROUND VALLEY INDIAN TRIBES- AND
THEY SPOKE SO ELOQUENTLY ABOUT
THE HISTORY AND THEIR-
INVOLVEMENT IN THIS ONGOING
PROCESS- WITH THE NAME CHANGE
AND RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR THAT WE
ARE HEARING FROM THE SOVEREIGN
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND THE
RESOLUTION AND THE U. KEY PEOPLE
OF THE COMMITTEE THAT'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED SO THAT VOICE IS
LOUD AND CLEAR. IN THIS HEARING.
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE THAT CLEAR
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
DEAN FAGAN AND YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT.
RESTORING OF JUSTICE AND THE
PROCESS OF- THE RENAMING. OF THE
LAW SCHOOL ITSELF I THINK WHAT
WE'VE HEARD WAS THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE INCLUSION OF VOICES ALSO
IN THAT PROCESS. AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NOW THAT
HAS COME TO THE ATTENTION OF THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. THAT WERE
VERY MUCH ENGAGED AND ALLOWING.
THAT PROCESS TO MOVE FORWARD.
ONE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR- GIVE
ME QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS. SOME
OF WITH TAKE ME TO CHURCH LET ME
THINK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THE SELECT
COMMITTEE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
ALSO WANT TO THANK PRESIDENT
ROSS AND- ORLANDO THE ORLANDO
SUN AND PAULA DIES IF I MISSED
THAT PENALTY ENABLE. OUR AND OF
COURSE D. DEAN FIGMENT- MY
DISTRICT OFFICE IS ONLY A BLOCK
AWAY FROM THE HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF LAW- IT HAS- BEEN THERE AND I
THINK WHEN THIS ISSUE HAS
REALLY- ROSE AS AN ISSUE OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS I REALLY
WANT TO THANK. DEAN FIGMENT IN
THE IN THE HASTINGS LEADERSHIP
BOTH THE ALUMNI THE FACULTY FOR
REALLY TAKING A HARD LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE AND REALLY GOING
THROUGH A VERY THOUGHTFUL
PROCESS AS TO WHAT SHOULD BE
DONE. GOT TO OFTEN WE HAVE
INSTITUTIONS WITH THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS OR
GOVERNMENT INSTITUTIONS OR
COMPANIES REALLY LOOK THE OTHER
WAY TRYING TO BRUSH HISTORY
UNDER THE RUG AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOUR KNOWLEDGE MENT
OF WHAT HAPPENED- AND REALLY
YOUR- BEING VERY OPEN ABOUT
DISCUSSING THE HISTORY IT'S YOU
KNOW HAVING EVERYBODY SPEAK
TODAY- THE FIRST. THE FIRST
THING I THINK OF IS ALL THE PAIN
THAT HAS BEEN CAUSING ALL THE
PAIN THAT PEOPLE FEEL IT'S EVEN
DUE TO IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
EVEN TALK ABOUT IT WHETHER IT'S
WHETHER YOU'RE THE LAW SCHOOL OR
THE- THE TRIBAL LEADERS- AND TO
TALK ABOUT THE GENOCIDE BUT-
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS IF WE
DON'T. TALK ABOUT HISTORY. WE
DON'T ACKNOWLEDGE IT WE DON'T.
OWN IT- THE WE REFER. AND SO I.
HAVING SITTING HERE TODAY AND
HE- FROM THE VARIOUS PARTIES
INVOLVED THE FACT THAT. THERE IS
NO DISAGREEMENT ABOUT WHETHER WE
SHOULD CHANGE THE NAME OF THE OF
THE SCHOOL OF LAW. REALLY THE
ONLY QUESTION IS WHAT WE CHANGE
IT TO AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THE- ALL THE DISCUSSION AND
ALL THE OUR PROCESS I THINK
WE'RE WE ARE STILL TAKING TIME-
OUR CHAIRMAN HERE IS REALLY
BRINGING ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER AND I HOPE. THAT AS WE
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS THROUGH
THIS YEAR THAT WE CAN COME TO
SOME RESOLUTION THAT WE COULD
ALL. BE VERY VERY PROUD OF I
THINK- I FIND AT THE RESPECT THE
WISHES OF THE BOARD BUT I ALSO
DO RESPECT THE WISHES OF THE
TRIBAL LEADERS WHO I WANT TO SEE
SOME ACKNOWLEDGEMENT- WITHIN THE
NAME. OF WHAT HAS HAPPENED AND I
HOPE AND I'M VERY CONFIDENT THAT
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS SO WE
CAN. COME TO AGREEMENT TO BE MY
- DIRECT GOAL THAT WE COME TO AN
AGREEMENT I REALLY FEEL THAT I
CAN THIS ROOM TODAY THERE'S OF
KNOWLEDGE MINT OF WHAT HAPPENED
THERE'S AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
HAPPENED. AND THERE'S KNOWLEDGE
AND THAT HE WAS WRONG- THE AND
THERE'S NO ONE JUST. THE OR-
TRYING TO- A- A WHITEWASH
HISTORY AS AS TOO OFTEN HAPPENS.
IS THOSE A TODAY- THIS
REPRESENTING- MY CITY AND COMING
AND ALSO HAVING A VERY CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR OUR DEAN
AND ALSO THE SCHOOL OF LAW SINCE
SINCE WE ARE NEIGHBORS- I THINK
IT'S JUST IMPORTANT TO JUST TO
GET APPRECIATE EVERYONE FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO BE HERE. I
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY FOR A
KNOWLEDGE WHAT HAPPENED BUT ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THIS IS- THIS
IS A PROCESS THIS IS A STRUGGLE-
WHAT HAPPENED WAS HORRIBLE BUT
UNDERSTANDING HOW WE PROCESS IT
AND HOW WE COME OUT OF IT. IS
ALSO- THEY ALSO A STRUGGLE AS
WELL SO AGAIN APPROPRIATE ALL
THE LEADERS I'M IN TODAY I
REALLY AREN'T WHICH ALL OF US TO
KEEP HAVING DISCUSSIONS WERE IN
GOOD HANDS WITH OUR CHAIRMAN
HERE. AND I'M VERY VERY
CONFIDENT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
COME TO SOME RESOLUTION SO WE
CAN AGAIN ENACT THE BOARD'S
WISHES AND I THINK FRANKLY THE
WISHES OF THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
TO RENAME A VERY VERY GOOD
INSTITUTION. AND TO REALLY MOVE
FORWARD AND ACKNOWLEDGE ALSO-
THE ATROCITIES THAT HAPPENED TO-
THE TRIBES AND THEIR ANCESTORS
AND ENSURE THAT WE NEVER FORGET. THAT AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ASSUME TEAMS NEVER GIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
CHAIRMAN ALSO- LINE MY COM WITH
- MISTER AND- DEAN'S. FIGMENT
FOR JOY US AND ARE READING THE
LETTERS- AND THE WISHES OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND- AGAIN I
THINK WE COME AT A TIME IN OUR
HISTORY- THAT WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT RESTORING RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE AND I THINK RESTORE
RESTORE ADDRESSES LOOKS LIKE-
THE NAME BEING CHANGED AND ALSO-
THE NATO THE FIRST PEOPLE BEING
PART OF THAT PROCESS AND THIS IS
THAT PROCESS RIGHT HERE. THAT WE
HAVE OPEN UP TESTIMONIES- I AM
APPALLED BYE BY WHAT I HEARD-
BECAUSE I'VE ALWAYS REFLECTED
BACK ON- YOU KNOW BLACK PEOPLE
AFRICAN AMERICANS PEOPLE- IN
SLAVERY AND CERTAINLY. IN THIS
COUNTRY HAS A VERY CHECKERED
PAST WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
PEOPLE OF COLOR BUT WE MUST BE.
AT LEAST IN THE THIS POSITION AS
POLICYMAKERS TRY TO RE WRITE THE
WRONGS OF WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
THE PAST- SO THAT WE CAN MOVE ON
AND I THINK THE WAY WE MOVE ON
IS TO. RENAME THIS INSTITUTION
AND I THINK THAT IT'S REFLECTIVE
OF A COLLABORATION. OF MANY
VOICES BUT MOST OF ALL OF THE
FOR THE FIRST AMERICANS OF
VOICES WHICH IS MOST IMPORTANT
IS A NATIVE AMERICAN VOICES. OUT
TO MAKING SURE THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT- THEY CAN BE PROUD OF- IT
CAN MAKE SURE THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
AND CALIFORNIA COULD BE PROUD
OF. BECAUSE I THINK WE STAND AT
A TIME. WHERE WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO I GREW UP WITH-
THAT THAT- WERE SINCE SLAVE MY
PEOPLE- THAT. THE SITES TO OTHER
PEOPLE OF COLOR- AND WE CANNOT
LOOK AT THOSE STATUES THOSE
MONUMENTS AND FEEL GOOD ABOUT
OURSELVES AND I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE. ARTICULATED HOW MANY WELL
KNOWN PEOPLE HAVE GRADUATED AND
WENT THROUGH HASTINGS LAW SCHOOL
AND THAT'S ALL AND WELL AND WE
APPRECIATE THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PROVIDE GREAT LEADERSHIP- BUT.
THIS INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
LEARNING IT SHOULD REFLECT- THAT
THE- A PROUD PEOPLE OF PEOPLE
WHO LOST A TREMENDOUS. AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE- IN THIS COUNTRY. DUE TO
RACISM AND DISCRIMINATION AND TO
HAVE SOMETHING THAT REFLECTS-
PEOPLE THAT CAN FEEL PROUD OF
GOING THERE- AND NOT HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE PAST I THINK IS
THE RIGHT STEP TO DISS TO TAKEN
SO AGAIN- MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR GREAT LEADERSHIP
BECAUSE HAD YOU NOT BEEN
ELECTED. I'M NOT SURE WE'LL BE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION TODAY.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
STANDING UP- AND SPEAKING TRUTH
TO POWER. BECAUSE IT WAS BECAUSE
OF YOU YOUR BIRTHDAY YOUR
COMMITMENT YOUR HERITAGE- THAT
LED YOU TO BE IN THIS PLACE IN
THIS DISPENSATION. TO WRITE
HISTORY A RIGHT. AND SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU BELIEVE THIS LEADER
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND BRINGING US
HERE TO RAISE THE CONSCIOUS
LEVEL OF THIS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SO A MEMBER-
GIPSON I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA- ALSO
PARTICIPATING IN THIS HEARING.
IS THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON
THIS TOPIC ON THIS PANEL. WE
MOVED TO THE NEXT. THANK YOU-
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU- TO ALL THE
TESTIMONY THAT WAS SPOKEN-
CERTAINLY- PRESIDENT RUSS- MONA
NO REPLIES YOU KEEP PEOPLE IN
THOSE IN ATTENDANCE HERE TODAY
AND- THE DEAN AND HASTINGS LAW
SCHOOL- FOR ACKNOWLEDGING-
ATROCITIES THAT WERE INFLICTED
BY THE FOUNDER'S NAME OF THAT.
THAT LAW SCHOOL BUT ALSO OPEN
TO- DISCUSS AND HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD I THINK IS WHERE WE'RE
HEADED I THINK THERE IS GENUINE
AGREEMENT- THAT THE NAME
HASTINGS- SHOULD BE STRICKEN
IT'S MORE OF THE DISCUSSION AND
THE PROCESS OF ONGOING
DISCUSSION OF WHAT THAT
REPLACEMENT NAME SHOULD BE. SO
WITH THAT- I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION HERE ON
PANEL TWO WE WILL MOVE ON TO
PANEL THREE PANELS THREE S.
CALIFORNIA INDIAN NATIONS
COLLEGE WHY WE NEED OUR OWN
COLLEGE TAKING BACK OUR POWER.
AND TO THOSE IN IN THE AUDIENCE
AND THOSE WATCHING- THROUGHOUT
THE TELEVISION ASSEMBLY
TELEVISION CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
THE ONLY STATE THAT HAS NO
FAMILY RECOGNIZE ARE FEDERALLY
ACCREDITED TRIBAL COLLEGE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA YET. WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST POPULATION OF NATIVE
AMERICANS LIVING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO IT'S MY PLEASURE
TO INTRODUCE PANEL THREE. PANEL
THREE WHO WILL DISCUSS THE NEED
AND ROLE OF TRIBAL COLLEGES AND
THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN NATIONS
COLLEGE EFFORTS TO GAIN FEDERAL
ACCREDITATION AND WHY THEY ARE
IMPORTANT WE HAVE- THERESA MIKE
HONORABLE THERESA MIKE WHO WAS
BORN AND RAISED AND ALLOW ME
NATION IN WASHINGTON STATE MISS
MIGHT WORK. THROUGH A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND LATER THE LEMME
INDIAN SCHOOL OF AQUACULTURE-
WHILE RAISING A FAMILY
MAINTAINING HER CULTURE AND
SERVING IN TRIBAL GOVERNMENT IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY SHE HELPED
LEAD THE TRANSITION OF THE LEASE
UP TO ALLOW ME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND HELP SEE IT THROUGH TO
ACCREDITATION. AND IN THIS
TRANSLATE TRANSITION TO THE
NORTHWEST INDIAN COLLEGE AS IT
EXPANDED SO MANY IN THE
NORTHWEST UP IN THE WASHINGTON
AREA. MISS MIKE LEAD TO FURTHER
EXPAND UPON HER PREVIOUS WORK-
WHICH LED TO FOUNDING THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN NATIONS
COLLEGE. WHICH THE TWENTY NINE
PALM BANDS OF BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS TRAVEL GOVERNMENT
CHARTED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. SHE
WILL BE JOINING US WITH
VIRTUALLY AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT SHE'S ABLE TO JOIN.
AS A AS SHE GETS READY TO GO ON
I WANTED TO JUST ADD. TO THAT-
BIOGRAPHY. SHE WAS THE TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WOMAN OF THE YEAR IN THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THAT I GET TO
REPRESENT THE COACHELLA VALLEY
SUGGEST ONE PUT A CHERRY ON TOP
OF THE- BIOGRAPHY INTRODUCTION
THAT'S- JUST THE CHERRY. AND I
WOULD ABLE TO BRING A RUBBER SHE
- OKAY. HELLO HI THERESA WE
COULD HEAR YOU. OKAY GOOD GOOD-
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY AND I'D
LIKE TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO WHAT
I HAVE TO SAY- AND I'VE BEEN IN
EDUCATION- FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS- R. AS- MISTER ROBERTS
STATED IT WAS WORKING AFTER MY
MEETING- AND HELPED ESTABLISH
NORTHWEST INDIAN COLLEGE FOR
ABOUT FOURTEEN YEARS. AND
CONTINUED THAT WHEN I MOVED HERE
AND- WAS CENTER INSTRUMENTAL
AND- HIRING AND HUMAN RESOURCE
DIRECTOR FOR SPOTLIGHT TWENTY
NINE CASINO AND THE TWENTY NINE
PALMS BAND OF MISSION INDIANS.
WE ALSO HAD A GED PROGRAM THAT
RAN FOR TWO YEARS AT SPOTLIGHT
AND WE GRADUATED OVER SEVENTY
FIVE OF OUR EMPLOYEES WITH THEIR
G. D. SO. I YEAR- I WOULD LIKE
TO- START BY SAYING THAT THROUGH
MY YEARS OF WORKING AS A HUMAN
RESOURCE DIRECTOR AND AS AN
EDUCATOR I'VE SEEN THE
TRANSFORMATION OF SEVERAL
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND- HOW ARE MANY
HAVE COME FROM ALCOHOLISM AND
DRUGS AND- A SENSE OF
HELPLESSNESS- TO- EMPLOYMENT.
AND VIRTUAL TURN AROUND THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES SO I HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN A TRUE BELIEVER IN
EDUCATION. AND- AND- THE HELP OF
NATIVE AMERICANS. BUT
TRANSFORMING THE LIVES OF NATIVE
AMERICANS AS- MOST OF THE TIME
NOT AN EASY TASK. IN ORDER TO
AFFECT CHANGE PEOPLE NEED VOICES
AND CHANCES SOMETIMES THEY GET
NEITHER. I REMEMBER WHENI WAS
IN HIGH SCHOOL- AND IN MY FINAL
YEAR TWELFTH GRADE. THE
COUNSELORS WOULD COME AND PICK
DIFFERENT CHILDREN FROM THE
CLASSROOM AND THEY WOULD BE GONE
FOR OUR SEEMINGLY. AND THEN WHEN
IT WAS MY TURN I WAS GONE FOR
FIVE MINUTES SO WHAT I WAS TOLD.
I WOULD PROBABLY NEVER ATTEND
COLLEGE SO AND I WAS SENT BACK
TO CLASS. SO I NEVER REALLY HAD
A CHOICE BACKGROUND AND NEVER
KNEW WHAT MY CHOICES WERE. BUT
AS WE STARTED WORKING ON THE
COLLEGE AT LEMME AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE TRIED TO GIVE
PEOPLE THOSE CHANCES AND THOSE
CHOICES. YOU'RE SORT OF
CHRISTIAN AND SUPPRESSION HAS
LEFT MANY. WITHOUT EITHER FOR
CENTURIES THEY HAVE TAKEN THE
LAND THEY HAVE SUPPRESSED THE
LANGUAGE AND THE RELOCATION AS
SIMULATION ACT OF NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE WHERE THEY CHECK NATIVE
AMERICANS FROM THE RESERVATIONS
AND PLACED THEM. IN TRAINING
SESSIONS OR ON THE JOB TRAINING
. IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY THEY ESPECIALLY AT
LAMBING A LOT OF LET ME SCAN
HERE TO CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE
GIVEN AND- MINIMAL JOBS- WERE
TAUGHT WELDING IN MOST CASES MY
MOTHER WAS A WELDER- BUT THOSE
JOBS DIDN'T LAST AND SO ASSEMBLY
SHOULDN'T DIDN'T WORK AND THE
RELOCATION PROGRAM. DIDN'T WORK
FOR A GREAT MAJORITY OF THE
PEOPLE- EVENTUALLY EVERYONE
MOVED BACK TO THE RESERVATIONS.
SO ALL OF THIS MAY HAVE LEARNED
A TRADE BUT COULDN'T USE THAT IF
THEY GOT A JOB THAT WAS AT
MINIMUM WAGE AND- WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO FULLY ASSIMILATE INTO
SOCIETY. AND PAY THE RENT AND
HAVE FOOD TO EAT AND HAVE NO
MEDICAL CARE. THESE ARE JUST A
FEW OF THE ACTIONS BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND STATES
ALSO GET INVOLVED THERE IS NO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ON
RESERVATIONS. UNTIL THE CABAZON
DECISION. THAT STARTED GAMING
EVEN IN GAMING AS I WAS THE
HUMAN RESOURCE DIRECTOR I SAW
THE- THE TURN AROUND THERE'S
SOME OF OUR- TRIBAL MEMBERS WHO
REALLY WANT TO WORK BUT- COULD
NEVER GET HIRED IN ANY TOWN OR
CITY. BECAUSE OF RACISM. SO. AND
THEN IN ORDER TO APPLY FOR STATE
ASSISTANCE. TRIBAL MEMBERS WERE
NOT ALLOWED TO OWN ANYTHING
WHICH IS AT LET ME HOW WE LOST A
LOT OF OUR TRIBAL LANDS IF YOU
WANTED- STATUS SYSTEM. OF FOOD
AND MEDICAL YOU HAVE TO SELL
EVERYTHING YOU HAVE A VALUE
INCLUDING CARS AND LANDS. IN
ORDER TO GET FOOD STAMPS BACK
DOWN OR COMMODITY FOODS THAT WAS
ISSUED BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IN OUR GRADES ARE K. THROUGH
TWELVE- EDUCATION WAS ONLY GOOD
FOR TRIBAL MEMBERS THROUGH WHAT
I CALL COUNT WEEK I DON'T KNOW
IF ANY OF YOU. REALIZE WHAT
COUNT WEEK AS- STILL DISTRICTS
WERE GIVEN FUNDING BY THE STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF AMERICANS
ATTENDING IN THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT. SO THEY GUARDIAN AS
MANY NATIVE AMERICANS AS A
CREDIT BEARING CAL POLY AND THEN
DIDN'T CARE A SHOW ABOUT FOR THE
REST OF THE YEAR. SO MANY NATIVE
AMERICANS- WHERE EITHER
DISMISSED- WE'RE- PICKED ON TO
THE POINT OF GETTING IN FIGHTS
AND THEN LATER DISMISSED FROM
SCHOOL SO THEY COULD NEVER
GRADUATE. SO THAT WAS CANNOT BE. IF YOU LOOK NOW AT THE THIRTY
EIGHT TRIBAL COLLEGES IN THE
UNITED STATES PARTICULARLY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA- EDUCATION IS
THRIVING FOR SOME OF THOSE. AND
SO. WE ARE ALSO- TRYING TO PICK
UP- AND HELP- PUT TOGETHER A
GOOD EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM FOR.
ARROGANCE BY STARTING CALIFORNIA
INDIAN NATIONS COLLEGE. AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE WE ARE AS
MENTIONED BY BRAHMOS WE STARTED
OUT AS LONG BEACH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND WE CAN GET ANY
TRIBES THAT JOINED US AT THAT
TIME. WHEN WE TRANSITIONED OUR
NAME TO NORTHWEST INDIAN COLLEGE
WE HAVE NOW SERVED OVER ONE
HUNDRED TRIBES NATIONWIDE WHO
COME TO LET ME. TO FINISH THEIR
EDUCATION- AND- WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED THE END OF TWO THOUSAND
AND- R. SEVENTEEN- WE TOOK TOOK
A LOOK AT THE STATISTICS. NOT
OUR STATISTICS BUT THE
STATISTICS ARE YOU SEE ARE AND
COLLEGE OF THE DESERT WHICH ARM
SHOWED THAT THERE WERE OVER.
EIGHT HUNDRED. ALMOST A NATIVE
AMERICANS LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
BUT LESS THAN 1% ATTENDED. BY-
THEIR OWN RECOGNITION OF BEING
NATIVE AMERICAN. ARE A COLLEGE
OR UNIVERSITY LESS THAN 1% SO
THAT PROVES THE NEED- AND THEN
WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT HOW. YOU
HAVE TO KIND OF SELF IDENTIFIED
WHEN YOU'RE ENROLLED FOR A
COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY BECAUSE
SOMETIMES NATIVE AMERICAN IS NOT
LET THAT. SO THERE IS REALLY NO
WAY TO KNOW IF THE STATISTICS
ARE CORRECT OR NOT. BECAUSE MOST
NATIVE AMERICANS DON'T CHOOSE
OTHER. THEY'D RATHER CHOOSE
NOTHING. SO- IF YOU TAKE A LOOK
AT THE DOOR TWENTY TWENTY
SENSES- IT STATES THAT THERE ARE
NOW MORE THAN ONE POINT TWO
MILLION. THEY GIVE AMERICANS
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA SO. IS A
TRIBAL COLLEGE NECESSARY I WOULD
SAY YES AND BY THE NUMBERS THAT
WE'RE SHOWING CALIFORNIA AND YOU
NATION'S COLLEGE. BILL WOULD SAY
YES WE ARE OUR NUMBERS ARE
GROWING- SEMESTER OVER SEMESTER
AND. I THINK WE HAVE A GOOD
RUNNING START. R. I WOULD LIKE
TO-STOP THERE YEAH- INJECTED
CELESTE COUNSEL ARE THE
PRESIDENT. YOU CAN C. E. O.
CALIFORNIA INDIAN NATIONS
COLLEGE AND THANK YOU FOR MY
TIME. THANK YOU THE HONORABLE-
MISS MIKE AND WOMEN OF
DISTINCTION- FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND WHY THOSE DISTRICT-
IN TWENTY. TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU- FOR THAT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
BRING IT TO LIGHT- THE
IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATION- FOR ALL
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE. WE LIKE
TO- BRING- THE CELESTE TOWNS AND
UP TO THE DYESS- TABLE TO SPEAK
MISTER TOWNSEND IS AN ROLE
MEMBER OF THE GATE TO CHECK CUT
BAND OF FORT BIDWELL PAIUTES
LOCATED IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IN A DESCENDANT OF THE DUCK
VALLEY INDIAN RESERVATION HOME
OF THE SHOSHONE PAIUTE TRIBE IN
NORTHERN NEVADA. SHE WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH BOTH PARENTS-
BEING FROM RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA
IN CALIFORNIA NATIVES. PRESIDENT
TOWNSEND COMES TO CALIFORNIA
INDIAN NATIONS COLLEGE WITH OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS EXPERIENCE IN
EDUCATION ADMINISTRATION FINANCE
AND BUDGET. AND OVER TWENTY TWO
OF THOSE YEARS HAVE BEEN IN
INDIAN EDUCATION. HER EXPERIENCE
BEGAN AT SHERMAN IT IN HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO
THEN IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT SHE
TRANSITION TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE IN SOON
WENT. TO SEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. DURING THIS TIME SHE
WAS NO STRANGER TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENTS RELATE TO WHEN
ENTERING POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY THE SINK BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OFFICIALLY HIRED HER AS
PRESIDENT AND C. E. O. OF THE
COLLEGE. THANK YOU FOR ATTENDING
THANK YOU FOR OFFERING-
TESTIMONY. FISH OUR MORE NOT
SELECT THEM AND ANANTH. NOT
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA. WHITER NO
BIG ARE YOU. NOT TIRED NEWMONT.
FORBID WILL ENDING COMMUNITY
LATER CANNOT DO NOT PASHA.
ASSEMBLY MINERALS NO PATIENT
NEWMONT YET TO WELL. PETER OC.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS CELESTE TOWNSON AS ROMA SAID
I AM FROM. RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA
I AM A MEMBER CITIZEN ENROLLED
MEMBER OF THE FORT IT WILL
INDIAN COMMUNITY. I WANT TO
THANK RAMOS AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL I PARTICULARLY WOULD
LOVE TO THANK THESE WONDERFUL
PEOPLE WHO HAVE GIVEN TESTIMONY.
AND THANK THOSE. WHOSE LAND WE
REMAIN ON AND I THINK OUR
CREATOR. SO AND THANK YOU TERESA
WHAT I REALLY WANT YOU TO DO IS
TAKE A LOOK AT OUR- SEAL. THIS
SEAL DEPICTS SO MUCH WORK IN
MEANING FOR THE COLLEGE IF YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT THE CRACKS ON THE
SIDE THOSE ARE FOR THE CONTINUED
BROKEN PROMISES THAT WE- AS
INDIAN PEOPLE EXPERIENCE. YOU
LOOK AT THE MANY STARS IN THE IN
THE BETTER. THAT REPRESENTS ALL
THE TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZED AND UNRECOGNIZED. YOU
LOOK AT THE SUN YOU CAN'T TELL
IF IT'S A SUNSET OR THIS OR THE
SUN GOING DOWN BECAUSE EACH DAY
BEGINS WITH THE SUN COMING UP IN
THE SUN GOING DOWN. YOU LOOK AT
THAT BEAR THAT'S THE BARE OF
CALIFORNIA EVEN THOUGH IT'S A
ZUNI BEAR IT'S STILL OF BEAR IN
A TRADITIONAL FORMAT. YOU LOOK
AT THE FIRE IN THE BELLY. AND
THAT'S TO REPLICATE WHAT
MAINSTREAM EDUCATION HAS IS THE
LAMP OF LEARNING. THIS IS OUR
WAY OF LEARNING AROUND THE FIRE
WITH OUR FAMILY WITH THEIR
ELDERS. SO GIVEN THE FOUNDATION
AND HISTORY OF INDIAN EDUCATION
IS PRESENTED EARLIER. THERE
REMAINS TO BE A DISTRESSED IN
MAINSTREAM EDUCATION WHERE INTER-WOVEN TRAUMA. IS INGRAINED IN
THE MINDS OF NATIVE AMERICAN
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES THERE'S
NO DOUBT THAT THE MIND SET OF
FREE EDUCATION. TO THE
GENERATIONS OF OUR PEOPLE WAS TO
REMOVE THEIR IDENTITY WAS TO
REMOVE AND ERASE THEIR LANGUAGE
TO REMOVE THEIR SUPPORT SYSTEM.
WITHIN THEIR CULTURE AND
FAMILIES WHICH IN ESSENCE MEANT
TO REMOVE THEIR WAY OF LIFE. AND
IN MANY CASES REMOVE THEIR LIVES
. SLIDE TO PLEASE. THIS IS
CLEARLY DEPICTED IN A PHOTO THAT
STATES HERE THAT BOARDING
SCHOOLS ARE THE ONLY SCHOOLS ON
THE PLANET OUR STUDENTS ARE
REMEMBERED AS SURVIVORS NOT
GRADUATES IT REALLY HITS HOME
WHEN YOU THINK OF THAT. THERE'S
SO MUCH HIDDEN ATROCITIES BUT W
CAN SEE HOW THOSE SURVIVORS OR
GRADUATES HAVE CHANGED TO TODAY
. YET TODAY WE STILL FIND MORE
MORE COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
WHO HAVE TAKEN A STEP TO
APOLOGIZE TO INDIAN COUNTRY
THROUGH DIVERSE CITY INITIATIVES
SOCIAL INJUSTICE PROGRAMS AND
LANDEC KNOWLEDGE MINTS OR
MAINSTREAM EDUCATION HAS GOOD
INTENTIONS BY INCORPORATING
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT CEREMONIES AND
PROGRAMS. THEIR INTENTIONS OFTEN
PROMOTE SYMBOLS OVER SUBSTANCE
WE NEED FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
. AS WE CONTINUE TO HEAR NATIVE
AMERICANS COMPRISE LESS THAN 1%
OF THE UNITED STATES POST
SECONDARY POPULATION AND EVEN
ACCORDING TO WORLD POPULATION
REVIEW NEXT SLIDE PLEASE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER NATIVE AMERICANS WITH THE
POPULATION OF OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SEVEN SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND. BETTER IT TO HAVE BEEN
TAKEN IN THE CENSUS AND WE KNOW
THAT SKEWED BECAUSE NOT MANY ARE
ABLE TO CLAIM IT BECAUSE OF
THEIR- OWN REGISTERED OR FOR A
LACK OF. CONFIDENCE OKAY
OKLAHOMA FOLLOWS CALIFORNIA WITH
A LITTLE OVER. FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED NATIVE AMERICANS YEAH
OKLAHOMA HAS THREE ACCREDITED
TRIBAL COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
AND CALIFORNIA HAS ZERO. SINK OR
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION'S
COLLEGE AS CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
FULLY ACCREDITED TRIBAL COLLEGE
WILL STRENGTHEN TH STATE'S
ABILITY TO IMPROVE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL ACCESS AND CLOSE
THAT GAP. SYNC WILL ALSO ALLOW
EACH STUDENT TO SECURE THEIR AND
TRUSTED ACADEMIC PATHWAY TO A
FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY OF THEIR
CHOICE. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. AND
YOU HEARD FROM MRS MIKE.
ASSEMBLY MEN GRABBED A GARCIA
YOU'LL NOTICE THIS PICTURE HAS
HER CAN YOU AWARDED HER THIS AND
THIS IS MIKE AS SHE AS SHE WAS
INTRODUCED IS THE FOUNDER OF
CALIFORNIA AND IN NATION'S
COLLEGE AND SHE'S ALL TOO
FAMILIAR WITH THE HISTORY IN THE
CONTINUE CHALLENGES OF LIMITED
OR SHOULD I SAY RESTRICTED
ACCESS TO QUALITY EDUCATION. IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN SHE
BEGAN A MEETING OF THE MINDS
THAT INCLUDED A COALITION OF
OVER THIRTY FIVE PROFESSIONALS
AND EDUCATORS IN INLAND EMPIRE.
EACH MEETING MRS MIKE PROVIDED
DINNER TO THIS GROUP TO DISCUSS
THE POSSIBILITY THE POSSIBILITY
OF CREATING A TRIBAL COLLEGE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SOON A
DECISION WAS MADE TO BEGIN THIS
MASSIVE PROJECT. AND A CHARTER
WAS DRAFTED AND PRESENTED TO THE
TWENTY NINE PALMS BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS WHO ON SEPTEMBER
NINETEENTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN SIGNED THE CHARTER.
THEN ON MARCH EIGHT TWENTY NINE
PALMS BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
PROVIDED GENEROUS COMMITMENT OF
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO FIND
THE FIRST TWO YEARS AT THE
COLLEGE AND WITH MANY MEMBERS OF
THIS GROUP STEMMING FROM UC
RIVERSIDE. UC ARE OFFERED TO
SPONSOR THE COLLEGE'S OFFICE
SPACE AT NO COST FOR THE FIRST
TWO YEARS. AND I WAS TIRED THAT
DAY AS IN TURN PRESIDENT. WE
TOOK OFFICE YOU SEE OUR PALM
DESERT IN JULY TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND MEET IMMEDIATELY
BEGAN STRUCTURING OUR COURSE
OFFERINGS. THROUGH UCR EXTENSION
CENTER. BY OFFERING THREE THREE
ACCREDITED COURSES AND IN LESS
THAN THREE WEEKS WE HAD
RECRUITED OVER FORTY STUDENTS.
TWENTY OF HIM WORKING CURRENTLY
ENROLLED THROUGH SHERMAN AND IN
HIGH SCHOOL YET OUR- COMMUNITY
OUR OUR OTHER PARTNERS THAT
OTHER. INSTITUTIONS QUESTIONED
WHERE YOU GONNA FIND INDIANS TO
ATTEND YOUR SCHOOL ARE JOSH HIT
THE TABLE. THROUGH ROMANCE AND
THE DEMANDS THE CONTINUED GROWTH
AND SUCCESS I WAS HIRED AS THE
BOARD BY THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
AS A PRESIDENT OF SINK IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND MRS MIKE
SERVES AS A LIFETIME BOARD OF
TRUSTEE AND NOW WE LOOK TOGETHER
WITH OUR TEAM TO SUBMIT FOR
CREDIT ASIAN THROUGH THE
ACCREDITING COMMISSION. FOR
COLLEGES AND JUNIOR COLLEGES BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. SO WHY SANK WELL YOU CAN
SEE OUR VALUES THERE AND OUR
MISSION AS AN ACCREDITED TRIBAL
COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA WE WILL
SERVE AS A STEPPING STONE TO
EDUCATE STRENGTHEN AND EMPOWER
PEOPLE TO BOOST TRIBAL ECONOMIC
PRODUCTIVITY AND GROWTH RATE
MORE HIGHLY SKILLED AND
COMPREHENSIVE COMPETITIVE WORK
FORCE AND ALSO TO PROMOTE A
GREATER ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT
AMONG OUR TRIBAL CITIZENS TO
BECOME MORE SELF SUFFICIENT.
ASSETS CALIFORNIA INTONATIONS
COLLEGE FULLY UNDERSTANDS THE
RELENTLESS CHALLENGES AND
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND OUR
STUDENTS GIVE TESTIMONY THAT OUR
COLLEGE PROVIDES A SAFE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT WHEN THEY WERE NOT
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY OR ACCESS
AS THEIR PEERS IN THE- FEEDER
SCHOOLS. OUR COLLEGE OPERATES
WITH THE NORMALCY OF
UNDERSTANDING THE LACK OF DISK
ACCESSIBILITY AND INCLUSION WE
UNDERSTAND THE HISTORICAL AND
MULTI GENERATIONAL TRAUMA AND
DISTRUST. IN EDUCATIONAL AND
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS WE
UNDERSTAND THE SOCIAL DYNAMICS
OF TWO WORLDS ESPECIALLY IN
CEREMONIAL SECRETION TRADITIONS
AND CELEBRATIONS AND WE
UNDERSTAND AND WORK TO AMEND THE
SYSTEMATIC STANDARDS THAT
OPERATE THROUGH SOCIAL
PERCEPTIONS AND BIASED
IDEOLOGIES. CALIFORNIA
INTONATIONS COLLEGE AIMS TO
REGAIN THE TRUST IN EDUCATION
FOR OUR NATIVE AMERICAN AND
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. BY ONE WE
IDENTIFY RESEARCH AND DEVELOP A
SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT CONFRONTS
THE CHALLENGES FOR OUR PEOPLE
AND OUR STUDENTS WHO DID NOT
THINK OF YVERDON. CONSIDER OR
EVEN CONSIDER GOING TO COLLEGE.
THERE MUST BE A FULL COMMITMENT
TO FULLY EXAMINE THE NEEDS OF
THE COMMUNITIES AND THE PAST
FAILURES TO WHERE PEOPLE. ARE
CALLING BEEN OPERATING ON AND
WILL CONTINUE TO OPERATE IN AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT IS COMMITTED TO
ONE. DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION TO
CULTURAL TRADITIONS IN HEALING.
THREE INTELLECTUAL ENGAGEMENT
AND GROWTH FOR COMMUNITY
RESPONSIBILITY AND RECIPROCITY.
FIVE HOLISTIC HEALTH AND
WELLBEING AND SIX ACADEMIC
FREEDOM AND INTEGRITY. OUR
COLLEGE PROVIDES ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATION IN A SAFE AND
AT TIMES A TRADITIONAL LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
TEN HONOR NATIVE IDENTITIES TO
HONOR TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY
TRADITIONS AND CULTURE AND TO
ALLOW THE TRUTH OF THE HEAD IN
HISTORICAL EXPERIENCE OF FOR OUR
PEOPLE TO SURFACE SO THAT WE-
CAN ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES FOR
PEOPLE AND FOR COMMUNITIES TO.
PROVIDING PERSONALIZED SERVICE
THAT FOSTER SOCIAL AND FAMILIAL
SUPPORT IN A SAFE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT IS KEY. WE TREAT
EVERY STUDENT AS A PERSON
THEY'RE NOT LOST IN MAINSTREAM
SYSTEMS THEY'RE NOT JUST A
STUDENT ID NUMBER WE PROVIDE
PERSONALIZED IN IN JULY
INDIVIDUALIZED SERVICE TO ALL.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE I WILL REPEAT
THE QUOTE THE DOCTOR WAR SOLDIER
PRESENTED EARLIER THE AMERICAN
INDIAN COLLEGE FUND REMINDS US
THAT IN VISIBILITY IN ESSENCE
THE MODERN FORM OF RACISM
AGAINST NATIVE AMERICANS. THIS
INDIVISIBLE INVISIBILITY LEADS A
COLLEGE TO COLLEGE ACCESS AND
COMPLETION CRISIS AMONG NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENTS. EVIDENCE
CONFIRMS THAT CULTURALLY BASED
RESOURCES AND OPPORTUNITIES IN
AND OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH THE
CRITICAL SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE
THEY NEED TO LEAD COMMUNITIES.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. WE PROVIDE
INDIVIDUALIZED AND PERSONALIZED
SERVICE TO OUR STUDENTS FACULTY
STAFF AND COMMUNITY WE HEAR THE
VOICES OF ALL AND WORK TO
INCORPORATE AND STRENGTHEN OUR
COURSE OFFERINGS ARE WORKSHOPS
ARE PROGRAMS AND ADVANCE WE
FOSTER INDIGENIZATION KNOWLEDGE
VALUES CULTURE TRADITIONS AND
PERSPECTIVES TO SHARE AND
DEVELOP A DEEPER UNDERSTANDING
AND RESPECT FOR PEOPLE AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. WE AIM TO INCREASE
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH
SCHOLARSHIPS AND LISTENING TO
THE VOICES OF OUR STUDENTS. WE
NOT ONLY AIM TO RECOGNIZE
ACHIEVEMENTS AND RESILIENCY BUT
WE ALSO PROVIDE THE SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES AND CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL WE HAVE
STUDENT TESTIMONIES THAT HAVE
SAID THEY- SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN
JAIL AND NOT PLANNING FOR
COLLEGE OR THAT THEY DIDN'T SEE
THEM EVEN ATTENDING COLLEGE WE
HAVE STUDENTS THAT WEREN'T
ACCEPTED IN ANY OF THE RACES
COMING FROM MULTI GENERATION
GENERAL. MULTI RACES OF HER
ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS. I ALWAYS
MENTION THAT IT TOOK ME MORE
THAN TWELVE YEARS TO ATTAIN MY
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE I ATTENDED A
GREAT HIGH SCHOOL IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE. I HAD FANTASTIC GREAT
GREAT ATTENDANCE BUT NEVER WAS I
CALLED IN BY THE COUNSELOR AND
ACKNOWLEDGED. OF OR EVEN
CONSIDERED OR TO TAKE THE SAT
USER SEAT'S I HEARD OF MY PEERS
GOING AND TAKING THESE EXAMS
THEM BEING CALLED IN. BUT I WAS
NEVER CALLED IN. SO I WASN'T
FAMILIAR WITH THE SYSTEMS AND
WHAT IT TOOK TO GO TO COLLEGE- I
ENDED UP WORKING IMMEDIATELY
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL AND DECIDED I
WANTED TO TAKE A CLASS AT A TIME
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL I STARTED
WORKING AT SHERMAN ENDED HIGH
SCHOOL. THAT ONE OF THE
COUNSELORS THERE HELPED ME AS A
CO WORKER AND ENCOURAGE ME TO GO
TO SCHOOL AND FROM THERE I WENT
AND GOT I FINISHED MY ASSOCIATES
DEGREE I GOT MY BACHELOR'S
DEGREE AND I GOT MY MASTER'S
DEGREE THAT WAS THE COUNSELOR
SHERMAN A CO WORKER. WHO HELPED
ME. THANK WILL NOT OPERATE IN A
STRUCTURE OF TOP HEAVY
HIERARCHIES WE AIM TO SECURE
STAFF TO STUDENT RATIOS THAT
WILL SUPPORT OUR MISSION. OF
PERCIVAL PERSONALIZING
INDIVIDUALIZED SERVICES. SAID
THAT THE NEEDS OF EVERY SINGLE
STUDENT IS HEARD. AND THAT A
PERSONALIZED PATHWAY IS PUT IN
PLACE. FOUR WE LOOK TO REDUCE
DROPOUT RATES AND INCREASE THE
LOW ENROLLMENT OF NATIVE PEOPLE
IN POST SECONDARY EDUCATION. THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR EDUCATION
STATISTICS RATE REPORT THAT
NATIVE STUDENTS MAKE UP POINT 8%
OF THE TOTAL COLLEGE POPULATION
. IT HAS BEEN REPORTED THAT
NATIVE AMERICAN CITIZENS WHO
ATTEND A TRIBAL COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY ARE FOUR TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO RECEIVE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE THAN THOSE WHO ENROLL IN
MAINSTREAM FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES. AND EVEN STILL ON
THIS SLIDE YOU'LL SEE THAT
ACCORDING TO POST SECONDARY
NATIONAL POLICY INSTITUTE A
REPORT THAT WAS GENERATED IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
24% OF EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOR
YOUR FOUR YEAR OLDS. OF NATIVE
AMERICANS ARE ENROLLED IN
COLLEGE COMPARED TO THE 41% OF
THE OVERALL UNITED STATES
POPULATION. 41% OF FIRST TIME
FULL TIME NATIVE STUDENTS
ATTENDING FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITIES
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN GRADUATED WITHIN SIX
YEARS COMPARED TO THE SIXTY
THREE PERCENT. FOR ALL STUDENTS
IN THE UNITED STATES. IN
20001979% OF OUR STUDENTS
ATTENDED PUBLIC TWO YEAR OR FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTIONS ALSO IN
20001925% OF NATIVE AMERICANS
OVER THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE HAD
AN ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE. COMPARED
2402% OF ALL THOSE OVER THE AGE
OF TWENTY FIVE IN THE UNITED
STATES BETWEEN THE YEARS TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN AND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE PERCENTAGE
OF NATIVE AMERICANS OVER THE AGE
OF TWENTY FIVE WHO HAD ATTAINED
AN ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE. INCREASE
FROM 21% 225% SEEING AIMS. TO
HELP THIS NUMBER GROW STILL LESS
THAN 16% OF OUR NATIVE AMERICANS
HOLD A BACHELOR'S DEGREE OR
HIGHER COMPARED TO THE NEARLY
33% OF THE TOTAL UNITED STATES
POPULATION. SO FIVE WE AIM TO
DECREASE IF NOT ELIMINATE
SYSTEMATIC BIASES AND BREAK DOWN
THOSE SOCIAL BARRIERS IN THE
CLASSROOM YOUR HIRING PRACTICES
. WE HAD RECENTLY LOST A
QUALIFIED ELDER TO THE
SYSTEMATIC BARRIERS AND
IDEOLOGUE ALL THE CHEESE HE
TAUGHT A CLASS WHERE I WITNESSED
. FULL ENGAGEMENT OF OUR
STUDENTS HAS PERSONABLE AND
TRADITIONAL TRAITS DID NOT MEET
THE EXPECTATIONS AND A
SYSTEMATIC JUDGMENT OF CHARACTER
. WELL MAINSTREAM INTERVIEW
PROCESS IS OF GOOD INTENTIONS
THE INEFFECTIVENESS TOWARDS OUR
CULTURE ALLOWS FOR THIS DISPLAY
OF SELF IMPORTANCE. TO
PERPETUATE MISUNDERSTANDINGS
THAT PROLIFERATE THE EXCLUSION
OF NATIVE AMERICAN VOICES AND
THE ELEGANCE OF THEIR
TRADITIONAL VOICE. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. SO WE CELEBRATE
DIVERSITY INCLUSION THEIR
NORMALCY FOUND IT CALIFORNIA IN
THE NATION'S COLLEGE IS ONE OF A
SAFE AND TRUSTED LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT WITHOUT OUR TRIBAL
COLLEGE AND THOSE LOOKING TO
EMERGE WEEK WOULD CONTINUE TO.
ALL SUBJECT TO THE PERPETUAL
MARGINALIZATION AS A PEOPLE IN A
SYSTEM THAT WAS ESTABLISHED AND
REMAINS UNDER SOCIETY'S
PRINCIPLES AND SOCIAL STANDARDS
. YET STILL. THERE'S A FEDERAL
MANDATE OF BLOOD QUANTUM WE AS
INDIVIDUALS MUST PROVIDE PROOF
THROUGH A CERTIFICATE OF INDIAN
BLOOD THAT WE ARE REGISTERED
WITH THE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES AND AT A MINIMUM OF ONE
QUARTER OR ONE FOURTH DEGREE AND
IN BLOOD TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE. AND YET THIS
SYSTEMIC CONTROL DRIBBLES DOWN
TO OUR TRIBAL COLLEGE WHERE WE
MUST PROVIDE PROOF THAT OUR
STUDENT POPULATION IS THAT OF
OVER FIFTY ONE PERCENT. NOT A
PROBLEM. BUT A SHAME THAT SOME
ARE IDENTIFIED AS NOT INDIAN
ENOUGH. AND THEN AS THERESA
MENTIONED WERE SUBJECT TO A FORM
OF ACCOUNT WEEK. HOW MANY
INDIANS DO HAVE. CALIFORNIA IN
THE NATION'S COLLEGE OFFERS HIGH
QUALITY FULLY ACCREDITED COURSES
THROUGH OUR PARTNER COLLEGE OF
THE DESERT TO ALL STUDENTS
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED STATE
RECOGNIZE SELF IDENTIFIED AND
THOSE THAT ARE NOT. WE DO NOT
FURTHER COLONIZE THE
QUALIFICATION OF RANKING OF OUR
DIVERSE NATIVE AND INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE. WE INCORPORATE AND
RESPECT THE NATIVE AMERICAN AND
INDIGENOUS WISDOM TRADITIONS
WELL BEING AND KNOWLEDGE IS
PASSED DOWN THROUGH ELDERS AND
LEADERS. SOME OF WHO HAVE THE
MOST VALUABLE AND EFFECTIVE
TRUTHS STORIES SONGS AND DANCE
THESE ARE TRAITS BLESSINGS AND
EXPERIENCE THAT ARE FAR RESERVED
AND PROTECTED FROM BEING SHARED
OR RECORDED IN A BOOK. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE SO WHERE ARE WE. WE
CURRENTLY OFFER ASSOCIATES
DEGREES LIBERAL EN EL LIBERAL
ARTS DIRECTORS PARDON ME IN
LIBERAL ARTS STUDIES TO PREPARE
STUDENTS TO TRANSFER TO A WIDE
RANGE OF BACCALAUREATE PROGRAMS
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF THEIR
CHOICE WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH A FEW LOCAL FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES TO LAUNCH GUIDED
PATHWAYS. AND YET TO DATE SANK
HAS GRADUATED TWELVE STUDENTS
AND HAVE SERVED OVER A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY STUDENTS WHO
REPRESENT OVER FIFTY FIVE TRIBAL
NATIONS. NEXT OH I'M SORRY WE
CONSIDER. OUR MEDIAN AGE IS
THIRTY TWO AND THIS PAST FALL
SEMESTER OUR STUDENT POPULATION
REMAINED UNCHANGED WHILE LOCAL
COLLEGES HAVE EXPERIENCED AT 31%
DECREASE THANK HELD STRONG WITH
THE 10% INCREASE. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO GREATER INCREASE THE
FALL TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A TRANSFER RATE
OF 67% WITH THE FEW REMAINING AT
OUR COLLEGE TO SECURE THE MOST
TRANSFERABLE CREDITS THAT THEY
CAN EARN BEFORE MAKING THAT
TRANSITION. THE DECISION HAS
ALSO BEEN BASED TO REMAIN IN A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT AND STAY WITH
THEIR FRIENDS AND TRANSFER
TOGETHER. AGAIN THE SOCIAL.
SUPPORT OF THEIR COMMUNITY. SO
WHERE ARE WE GOING NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. THIS TIME NEXT YEAR SAME
GAMES TO SUBMIT THE APPLICATION
FOR ACCREDITATION THROUGH THE
ACCREDITING COMMISSION FOR
COMMISSION FOR COMMUNITY AND
JUNIOR COLLEGES IS IT IT IS
BEING SHARED BY THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF A. CCJ SEE THAT
GOVERNANCE AND SUSTAINABILITY
ARE THE TWO AREAS WHERE MERGING
COLLEGES SEEM TO FALL SHORT.
SINGH HAS SYNC HAS A STRONG
BOARD OF TRUSTEES YOU CAN SEE
THEM PARTICIPATING IN OUR
GRADUATION CEREMONY AND THIS
BOARD INCLUDES LOCAL TRIBAL
CHAIRS TRIBAL COUNCIL MEMBERS
DIRECTORS OF NATIVE. AMERICAN
PROGRAMS AT UNIVERSITIES AND
PROFESSIONALS FROM LOCAL TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND MISS PATRICIA
DIXON WHO SPOKE EARLIER IS ONE
OF OUR BOARD OF TRUSTEES. OUR
SUSTAINABILITY. NEEDS THE
DEVELOPMENT AND INSISTENT
FINANCIAL SUPPORT THE LIMITED
AND RESTRICTED ACCESS TO FUNDS
FOR ANY EMERGING TRIBAL COLLEGES
PERILOUS. LACK OF SUPPORT FROM
THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS IS DAMAGING TO THE
ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND PERSONAL
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR NATIVE PEOPLE
. IN WHICH THEY DESERVE. OUR
PEOPLE NEED TO REGAIN A LEVEL OF
TRUST IN OUR STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT TRULY AIMS TO
SUPPORT INDIAN EDUCATION
CONSIDERING OUR GROWTH RATE AND
THE OUT REACH THAT OUR STAFF AND
BEEN ACTIVELY PUTTING FORTH
CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION'S
COLLEGE ANTICIPATES A GROWTH
RATE OF AT LEAST 50% FOR FALL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND WE ARE
DEDICATED TO ATTAIN A STUDENT
POPULATION OF TWO HUNDRED
STUDENTS BY FALL TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. BUT THIS CAN ONLY CONTINUE
WITH THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
THE HIGHER UPS TO ALLOW US TO
HIRE HIGHLY QUALIFIED FACULTY
AND STAFF. WE ARE SMALL BUT
MIGHTY TEAM OF SIX WE SEEK TO
EMPLOY THOSE WHO ARE SELF
MOTIVATED AMBITIOUS AND WHO ARE
INSPIRED BY OR LEAD WITH
INNOVATION FOR THE CONTINUED
DEVELOPMENT OF THE COLLEGE. WE
LAUNCH THE COLLEGE FROM GROUND
ZERO AND THERE IS SO MUCH MORE
TO DO IT TAKES A UNIQUE
INDIVIDUAL. WHO WILL NOT GIVE UP
WHEN THE GOING GETS TOUGH IT'S
NOT AN EASY ROAD TO CREATE A
COLLEGE WHEN THERE'S NO PATHWAY
. BUT IT IS A MUCH NEEDED AND
FOR FILLING DEVELOPMENT FOR
INDIAN EDUCATION ESPECIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WE CONTINUE AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DEVELOPMENT
RECRUITMENT PLANS CONDUCTS STAFF
AND FACULTY HIRES WORK WITHIN
REPORT TO OUR CHARTERING TRIED
AND PUT FORTH FUNDRAISING
EFFORTS WE HAVE INCORPORATED
INFORMATION SESSIONS TO LOCAL
TRIBES HIGH SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THIS YEAR WE ARE ABLE
TO PLAN TO CONNECT WITH THE
HUMAN RESOURCES AND EDUCATIONAL
ART EDUCATION DIRECTORS AT THE
TRIBAL CASINOS LOCAL TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS. WE HAVE RECENTLY
INCREASED OUR STAFF TO USE.
EIGHT FULL TIME AND ONE PART
TIME EMPLOYEE AND WE AIM TO HAVE
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE POSITIONS
FILLED AS WE LOOK TO FILE FOR
ACCREDITATION BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR. PLUS WE HAVE ANY WE HAVE A
CONSTANT NEED FOR ADJUNCT
FACULTY TO ADD TO OUR ACTION
POOL WE ARE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR
QUALIFIED INSTRUCTORS THOSE OF
THE NATIVE DESCENT OR THOSEWHO
ARE HIGHLY EXPERIENCED WITH OUR
PEOPLE. TWENTY NINE PALMS BAND
OF MISSION INDIANS HAS BEEN
GENEROUS AND COMMITTED TO SEEING
ACCREDITATION. AND WE THANK THEM
AND THE LOCAL TRIBES WHO HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR COLLEGE. WE
HAVE REACHED OUT TO YOU AND WILL
CONTINUE TO REACH OUT TO LOCAL
TRIBES INDIVIDUAL DONORS AND
ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN CONTRIBUTIONS
AND GENERAL SUPPORT.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE A 100%
EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS AND 73%
BOARD OF TRUSTEES CONTRIBUTING
TO THE COLLEGE. TO BECOME THE
FIRST FULLY ACCREDITED TRIBAL
JUNIOR COLLEGE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE NEED THE SUPPORT
OF OUR CALIFORNIA TRIBES OUR
STATE OUR LEGISLATORS. AND OUR
LOCAL AND TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. YET I STAND
HERE. I SIT HERE. TODAY'S TO
HAPPILY REPORT THAT THERE ARE
THREE TRIBAL COLLEGES EMERGING
IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT CURRENTLY
OPERATE IN AIMED TOWARDS GAINING
FULL ACCREDITATION WITHOUT
FEDERAL OR STATE ASSISTANCE
COMING I COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LOCATED IN RANCHO SAN DIEGO.
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL CALL COLLEGE
LOCATED HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
CALIFORNIA INDONESIANS COLLEGE
LOCATED IN PALM DESERT I BEGAN
THE TRIBAL COLLEGE COALITION IN
CALIFORNIA KNOWN AS T. TRIPLE C.
TO BRING TOGETHER OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS TO DISCUSS THE
CHALLENGES AND STATUS OF EACH
INSTITUTION WASSINK IS THE
NEWEST SINK IS THE CLOSEST
TOWARDS ADMITTING FOR
ACCREDITATION ELIGIBILITY.
NEVERTHELESS CALIFORNIA HAS A
POPULATION THAT NEEDS THESE
TRIBAL COLLEGES SO I'M HERE. DID
YOU TELL YOU WHY WE NEED AND TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO DEVELOP
THE FIRST FULLY ACCREDITED
TRIBAL JUNIOR COLLEGE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CAN STRENGTHEN
OUR CAPACITY TO CONTINUE TO
EDUCATE STRENGTHEN AND EMPOWER
OUR NATIVE AMERICAN AND
INDIGENOUS INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES. NEXT SLIDE. CAN
FINAL SLIDE. PAGE EMMA THANK YOU. THANK YOU- THE LUXURY THAT
INSIGHTFUL EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENTS- TO THE- STATISTICS
AND DATA- FOR OUR NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENTS THE IMPORTANCE
OF MOVING FORWARD- TO CREATE THE
FIRST FAILURE CREDIT- TO YOUR
COLLEGE HERE IN THE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU
IDENTIFIED IN OKLAHOMA THEY HAVE
THREE A CREDIT BUT YET HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE NONE SO I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT TESTIMONY
TO THAT THAT WE HAVE A QUESTION
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
MISTER COMMENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TESTIMONY TODAY AND FOR
PROVIDING THIS MUCH NEEDED
INFORMATION AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AS WE SHOULD. BECAUSE LOOK AT
OUR POPULATION AND LOOK AT WHAT
OTHER STATES ARE DOING- THAT'S
WE SHOULD BE LEADING IF ANYTHING
AND SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR PROVIDING A SAFE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT A PLACE OF
INCLUSION THAT IS SO NECESSARY
WERE YOU ARE EMPOWERING
STUDENTS- BUT NOT JUST STUDENTS
BUT YOU'RE UNLOCKING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FAMILIES AND
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AND THAT
ALONE IS SO EMPOWERING SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU HI THIS IS
NEEDED SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
ON WALKING IN OPPORTUNITIES AND
DREAMS. AND SYNC DOES JUST THAT
AND IT'S LIFE. TRANSFORMING SAID
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY- AND BRING IN
THESE- ISSUES FORWARD- WITH THE
TRAVEL COLLEGES AND SYNC. AND OF
COURSE- HONORABLE- THERESA MIKE
FOR HER TESTIMONY OF HOW THINGS
HAVE EVOLVED- CERTAINLY AND HER
HOME AREA OF WASHINGTON STATE
WITH ALARMING- INDIAN
RESERVATION IN THE NORTHWESTERN
COLLEGES AND HOW IT JUST GREW TO
THAT. AND THEN SOME THINK THAT
THOSE THINGS JUST HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT BUT THEY DAHLE IT
STARTS WITH THOSE THAT ARE
RESILIENT TO CONTINUE TO FOLLOW
THE DREAM OF EMPOWERING ALL OF
A- NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE HERE
IN THE NATION AND SPECIFICALLY
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
AND I'M GLAD YOU POINTED OUT
THAT IT'S A LONG PROCESS BECAUSE
WE HAVE- PEOPLE. THAT JUST WANT
MORE AND SO MUCH MORE AT A
FASTER PACE AND SO WE KNOW
THERE'S A NEED WE KNOW THERE'S A
NEED NOT JUST FOR CALIFORNIA
INDONESIANS COLLEGE BUT- FOR CDC
INCOMING I'D TO BE ACCREDITED
AND MANY MORE. WITH EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND NATIVE
AMERICANS IN OUR STATE. AND ONLY
THREE WHO ARE TRYING TO EMERGE
THE OTHER TWO HAVE BEEN TRYING
FOR OVER TEN YEARS. YOU KNOW AND
TO KNOW THAT THAT WE HAVE THIS
BLOCK. OF FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
EVEN GET STARTED AND THEN THE
MISCONCEPTION MISUNDERSTANDING
THAT ALL TYPES OF MONEY YOU KNOW
THERE'S FREE EDUCATION OR YOU
KNOW THEY CAN GIVE YOU MANY.
IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE THAT WE FACED
WE CAN'T MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT
MONEY WE CAN'T GET IN MANY
BECAUSE OF THE TRUST OF
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS. NO THERE
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND HIGHLIGHT
IN THAT I MEAN A LOT OF TIMES-
AND PART OF THIS THESE HEARINGS
ARE TO BREAK DOWN MISCONCEPTIONS
AND A LOT OF THOSE
MISCONCEPTIONS THAT. ARE THE
THAT EVERY TRIBE IN IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY IS
DOING WELL WITHIN THE GAMING
ASPECT AND WE KNOW ALL. AS
LEADERS THAT'S NOT THE CASE IT
IS JUST A HANDFUL OF TRIBES THAT
ARE BEING SUCCESSFUL THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN PEOPLE. STILL NEED THOSE
RESOURCES STILL NEED THE
RESOURCES TO GET AN EDUCATION
STILL NEEDS THOSE RESOURCES TO
MAKE SURE THE TRUE HISTORY AND
CULTURE. IS BEING TOLD WITHIN
OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS AND STANDING
UP. WHEN WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT VOICE IS BEING HEARD SORT
OF THANK YOU FOR THAT AND OPEN
IT UP TO- ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HERE. THAT WOULD HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. ON THE PANELS THAT
WERE DISCUSSED HERE TODAY. THAT
THAT MR THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY- JUSTICE MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS OBVIOUSLY VERY
IMPORTANT SUBJECTS THAT. WERE
DISCUSSED TODAY I WAS ABLE TO
WALK INTO TELLIN OF THE- SECOND
PALACE OF TALKING ABOUT UC
HASTINGS AND REALLY. KIND OF AT
THE CORE OF. YOU KNOW THE IDEA
OF A RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. AND TO
HAVING TRIBES- IN AROUND A
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES.
PARTICIPATE IN THAT DIALOGUE-
AND- I KNOW THAT THAT- PROCESS
WILL- END UP WITH A FRUITFUL
OUTCOME. THAT WOULD BE
REFLECTIVE OF. ALL PEOPLE'S
INPUT. A PARTICULARLY THE
NATIVES OF THE REGION IN SAN
FRANCISCO. AS IT RELATES TO THE
PRESENTATION THAT WE JUST GOT TO
SEE IN HERE. TO ME THIS IS
EXTREMELY EXCITING. BUT JUST
BECAUSE IT'S IN MY BACKYARD. I
JUST BECAUSE OF THE AFFILIATION
TO COLLEGE OF THE DESERT UC
RIVERSIDE WHICH OUR- OUR- OUR
ALMA MATERS BUT BECAUSE WE'VE
SEEN THE PARTICIPATION. OF
TRIBAL AND NON TRIBAL- MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMUNITY IN ROLE AT THE
SCHOOL- I WAS DRIVING TO LOS
ANGELES IN EARLY DECEMBER WHILE-THE GATHERING TOOK PLACE. LED BY
OUR COLLEAGUE HERE IN THE
DESERT. TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE- BY HIM IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND OUR COLLEAGUES.
BUT ALSO WHERE THE SPOTLIGHT WAS
PUT ON THE COLLEGE. AND THE
GREAT WORK THAT YOU'VE JUST
HIGHLIGHTED THE GREAT WORK THAT
IS YET TO. COME ABOUT BUT THE
NEED FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO PUT ITS BEST FOOT FORWARD.
AND ALSO SUPPORT THE
ACCREDITATION PROCESS AND
SUPPORT THE FINANCIAL. ASPECTS
OF CONTINUING TO LAND- A VOICE
TO INDIAN COUNTRY IN THE
EDUCATIONAL SPACE. IN CALIFORNIA
AND SO I'M VERY PROUD TO BE ABLE%
TO SUPPORT THAT EFFORT- THAT IS
BEING LED BY OUR COLLEAGUES. I'M
ALSO REALLY EXCITED THAT- YOU
KNOW AGAIN THE LOCAL TRIBES
LIKE. THE TWENTY NINE PALMS
BAND. OF INDIANS IS FOCUSED AND
COME MID BY NOW. YOU KNOW I.
COMMENDED CHAIRMAN DARRELL MIKE-
FOR HIS WORK IN HIS VISION FOR
OUR COMMUNITY TO ENSURE THAT THE
TRIBE HAS A PRESENCE NOT JUST ON
THE RESERVATION BUT OUTSIDE THE
RESERVATION. AND THIS IS ONE OF
THE AREAS WHERE THAT THEY'VE
DONE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
SCHOOL- TO GET THIS UP AND GOING
TO WORK HERE TO BE HELPFUL- I
KNOW FIRST HAND A NUMBER OF
STUDENTS. THAT HAVE- ENROLLED AT
THE AT THE COLLEGE AND- THEY'RE
EXTREMELY EXCITED THEY ARE IN
THE SAFEST PLACE. TO LEARN. AND
TO BE WHO THEY ARE AND WHO ARE
THEY WANT TO BE- AND- MAYBE NOT
EVERY EDUCATIONAL SETTING IS FOR
EVERYONE. BUT I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE FOUND AT A SPECIAL PLACE
HERE WITH THE COLLEGE IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY FOR THE
STUDENTS. AT BOTH NON A TRIBE-
AND TRIBAL STUDENTS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE BEEN ROLES
I JUST WANNA MAKE THOSE COMMENTS
AND THANK THE- THE CHAIR HERE
FOR- BRINGING. YOU ALL AND THE
OTHER PRESENTERS TODAY TO THE
STATE CAPITOL. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA ANY ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS. I JUST WANNA A
REMARKS AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR CONVENING TODAY SELECT
COMMITTEE. BELIEVE THIS IS A
GREAT STAR AS WE HEAD INTO THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
AND WE TOOK SO MANY TOPICS- FOR
MANY- YOU TALKING ABOUT THE ON
BOARDING SCHOOLS AND WE HAD
REPRESENTATION HERE FROM
SHERMAN. IT IN HIGH SCHOOL I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THAT'S
ALSO WITHIN- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES IS DISTRICT. BUT IT IS
A TRUE HISTORY RIGHT THE HISTORY
OF INDIAN PEOPLE TELLING THOSE.
THOSE DIFFERENT AREAS OF. OF
LIFE OF THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
THAT MANY MIGHT NOT EVEN
UNDERSTAND THAT TOOK PLACE. IN
AS WELL AS THE LARGEST UP
DISCUSSION. ON HASTINGS LAW
SCHOOL AND- THE TRUSTEES
GENOCIDES INFLICTED AND HAVING-
THE DESCENDANTS ANCESTORS. I'M
IN THEIR VOICES BEING HEARD HERE
IN THIS DÍAS IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. MEANS SO MUCH OF
THANK YOU- MONA AND THE PEOPLE
FOR BRINGING THAT FORWARD. AND
OF COURSE- THE PRESIDENT RUSS
BRING FORWARD. FULL CIRCLE THE-
ISSUES THAT ARE FACING- ROUND
VALLEY- TRIBES IT THAT YOU
REPRESENT- EVEN THIS- AND THE
TRIAL SHOULD HAPPEN BUT ASO-
BROADBAND. AND OTHER ISSUES-
THAT CONTINUE TO PLAGUE. OUR
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE
HEALTHCARE BEING ONE OF THOSE
AND AYE DEAN AYE AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR A PARTICIPATING. AND
BRINGING FORWARD THE WILLINGNESS
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON- DIALOGUE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IN THOSE
COMPONENTS THAT ARE THERE. AND
THE COLLEGES AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE KEEPING IN THE
FOREFRONT. THOSE THAT.
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT OTHER
STATES HAVE MOVED FORWARD-
BEYOND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT HAVE NOW FULLY ACCREDITED-
COLLEGES. WERE FOR INDIAN PEOPLE
BUT YET. OF THE STATE WITH A
LARGE POPULATION OF NATIVE
AMERICANS HAS NOTHING. AND I
THINK THAT'S THE STATEMENT THAT
NEEDS TO BE SAD. AND FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THOSE THAT ARE
ON THE STYLIZED TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND SO WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE AND REYES
THAT THA VOICE. FORWARD I WANT
AT THIS POINT OPEN IT UP TO-
PUBLIC COMMENT IF ANYBODY IN
THE- CHAMBERS WOULD HAVE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY OF THE
PANEL DISCUSSIONS- ANY ISSUES
THAT WE WERE DISCUSSING. IF YOU
WOULD HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
HERE. IN THE CHAMBERS.
IT'S MONEY CINEMA IN HERE HAVE.
DEGREE YOU TODAY MY NAME IS THE
CALL WITH PAUL AND GREETING YOU
IN THREE OF MY LANGUAGES. THAT
I'M- TO THAT I'M FAMILIAR WITH.
I HATE NINETY AS A GREETING AND
BY DO. THE MOST BELOVED SAID.
SINCE MONICA IS A GREETING IN
PALMA. AND HAIL HAIL THE
GREETING THAT WHILE I'VE LEARNED
AND HEARD THE OTHER TO GROWING
UP WHERE MY GRANDFATHER WHO WAS
SPOKEN OF WILLIAM NYE DENNISON
KNIGHT. WHO WAS PART OF- VERY
STRONG MOTIVATOR OF- INDIAN
EDUCATION CREATING THAT I TO
PROGRAM EACH ISSUE. NATIVE
RIGHTS AND YOU KINDA MENDOCINO
COUNTY. HE SPOKE FLUENTLY. HIS
LANGUAGE AND I OVER HEARD IT MY
GRANDMA WHO IS NORMAL I CAN'T
MIGHT YOU BE HEARD BITS AND
PIECES OF OUR MIGHTY LANGUAGE.
THOSE ARE MY MATERNAL-
GRANDPARENTS AS FAR AS MY
PATERNAL PARENTS MY GRANDPARENTS
MY A MY GRANDMOTHER WAS LITTLE
LIKE POMA. MY FATHER IS YUKI.
NOT UNTIL JOINING THE U. P.
COMMITTEE HI I AM A MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE. WAS I EVER
EXPOSED. ARE PROVIDED ANY OF MY
U. Q. LANGUAGE. THANKFULLY TO
THESE WOMEN HI HAVE LEARNED BEEN
ABLE TO LEARN MY HISTORY WHICH
WAS TAKEN FROM MY FATHER. WE'RE
YOU KNOW WE LEARNT GROWING UP I
WAS THE YOUNGEST. I HAD TO LEARN
FROM MY OLDER RELATIVES. WHY AND
MY FATHER DIDN'T WANT TO SHARE
AND SHIELDED ME PROTECTED ME
FROM THE HISTORY OF THAT HE
ENTERED BEING A YOU CAN MAN. OF
BEING IN THE IN INDIAN SCHOOLS
BOARDING SCHOOLS FORCED TO GO TO
THE- MILITARY WHICH HE SERVED
PROUDLY- SO I'M HERE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO SHARE THAT YOU
KNOW THIS IS WHY. YOU KNOW IT'S
I'M FORTY TWO YEARS OLD. PUT IT
OUT THERE AND I HAVE JUST LEARNT
. ARE YOU CAN LANGUAGE JUST
SIMPLY TO SAY HELLO. THIS SO I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT THE NAME CHANGE
AND I APPRECIATE ALL THAT ARE
HERE. TO HELP SUPPORT THAT AS
WELL AND YOU KNOW REALLY PUT OUT
THERE THAT THE IMPORTANCE OF
REVITALIZING ARE YOU KILLING
WHICH AND- ALLOWING US TO NAME
UC HASTINGS COLLEGE IN AND YOU
CAN NAME. OVER THE YEARS I HAVE
WORKED WITH- YOU KNOW AGAIN NOT
HAVING ANY CONNECTION AT ALL
WITH MY YOU CUTE PEOPLE AND
LANGUAGE PEOPLE WHO CAN SPEAK
AND TEACH. I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
WORK WITH- PALMO COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND ONE OF THE- ONE OF
MY DEAR FRIENDS WHO IS A HIGH
SCHOOL YOU KNOW THAT I MET IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL SHE IS A MEMBER OF
THE ROUNDUP OF THE REDWOOD
VALLEY RANCHERIA. BAND OF POMO
INDIANS SHE HAS ONE OF THE ONLY
CREDIT ATIONS TO TEACH COMMON
LANGUAGE IN OUR COMMUNITY. SHE
TOUCHED MY HEART- WHEN SHE
SHARED THAT THE REASON WHY SHE
NAMED HER CHILDREN POMO NAMES
WAS SO THAT EVERY DAY WHEN HER
KIDS ARE SENT TO INSTITUTIONS
BECAUSE I'M NOT GOING TO
REITERATE THE HISTORY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION. AND THE
WAY THAT WE WERE IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM WHICH IS YOU
KNOW MOVING IN A POSITIVE
DIRECTION. WAS NOT GOOD FOR US
AS NATIVE PEOPLE IT WASN'T MEANT
FOR US TO BE WHERE WE ARE TODAY
. BUT SHE POINTED OUT THAT WAS
HER PERSONAL WAY TO ENCOURAGE TO
DO TO CHANGE HER RESTORED THIS
DEFICIT JUSTICE EFFORTS IN HER
OWN WAY TO. ENCOURAGE EVERY
INSTITUTION EVERY PLACE SHE WENT
WHEN THEY SAID HER CHILDREN'S
NAMES THEY WERE SPEAKING POMO
LANGUAGE BECAUSE OUR LANGUAGE.
HAS PUT IN PALMA WAS ALSO
SOMETHING THAT WAS TAKEN FROM.
SO WITHOUT THOUGHT THAT'S WHERE
I SUPPORT YOU KNOW HI. A. LIKE
THROUGH THE WEEK YOU KNOW I
AGREE WITH THE OTHER ASSEMBLY
PERSON THAT YOU KNOW IT I LOVE
THAT HE POINTED OUT YOU KNOW
THESE. THE IN FAGAN POINTED OUT
ALL OF THESE OTHER- MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE INTERNEES AND- WITH
KAMILLA HARRIS. AND HOW WE NEED
TO UPHOLD THEIR- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE RIGHT TO BE GRADUATES OF
THIS COLLEGE BUT FOR ME I LOVE
THE WAY THAT HE SPOKE UP ON
THEIR BEHALF BECAUSE THERE ARE
THEY ARE FROM THERE ARE
GRADUATES WHO ARE FROM OTHER
ETHNICITIES. WHO ARE DO YOU KNOW
THEY DIDN'T THE REASON WHY THEY
GOT THEIR EDUCATION WAS TO DO
THE SAME TO RE WRITE HISTORY.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE TO
DO. AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
SHARE WITH YOU THAT. THE NAME
USE SAN FRANCISCO. YOU KNOW I
OPPOSE IT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
BECAUSE I HAVE ANY HATRED OR ANY
FEEL LIKE I'M BEING DISRESPECTED
IN ANY WAY WITH THAT NAME JUST
TO CONTINUE TO SHARE THE
KNOWLEDGE. I HAVE SPOKE BEEN I
AM ON OTHER COMMITTEES WHERE WE-
EMPAT COMMITTEE WITH MANY MANY
TRIBES AND ORGANIZATIONS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ONE OF OUR
LEADERS AND ELDERS MISTER THOMAS
BROWN FROM LAKE COUNTY. HE
STUDIES- YOU KNOW THESE-
GENERATIONAL TRAUMAS AND HE
SHARED WHEN WE WERE WRITING A
POLICY. THAT THE NURSE THE NAME
IN ITSELF MISSION MEANS MEANT
WAS BRITAIN TO EXTERMINATE
NATIVE AMERICANS HE ASKED IN OUR
COMMUNITY THAT WE REFRAIN FROM
WRITING OUR POLICY IS A MISSION
STATEMENT BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THE TERM MEANT. AND THAT WE
CHANGE IT TO A VISION STATEMENT
. THAT KNOWLEDGE IS SO POWERFUL
BECAUSE- SAN FRANCISCO WAS BASED
ON A MISSION. THE NAME SAN
FRANCISCO COMES FROM A
MISSIONARY WHO WE HAVE LEARNT
TODAY THAT MISSIONARY YOU KNOW
THE MISSION SYSTEM WAS TO TAKE
AWAY OUR CULTURE AND POSE
ANOTHER- SO. AGAIN THE
IMPORTANCE IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
PROVIDING RESTORATIVE JUSTICE TO
OUR PEOPLE. LOOKING AT ONLY
CHANGING THE NAME OF HASTINGS IS
LIKE CUTTING OFF YOU KNOW WE'VE
TALKED YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT.
POINTING OUT THE HISTORY IF WE
DO ONLY CHANGE THE NAME FACING
WERE ACTING AS IF EVERYTHING WAS
PERFECT SINCE THEN. AND THAT
NOTHING STOPPED BUT FROM THAT
CASE FROM NOT THOSE ORDERS OF
HASTING THEN CAME THE MISSIONS
THEN CAME THE RAPING STAN CAME
THIS YEAR. ALL OF THESE
ATROCITIES GENOCIDE THAT CAME
UPON US AND TODAY WE ARE WELL
AWARE THAT. LOOK AT ALL OF THE
CHILDREN THAT HAVE BEEN FOUND
NATIONALLY. IN THE BOARDING
SCHOOL SYSTEMS THOSE ARE THE
SAME MISSION STYLE EDUCATION
SYSTEMS THAT OF. CONCORD AND
COMMUNITIES GENOCIDES TOWARDS
PEOPLE SO THAT WITH THAT I JUST
GRACIOUSLY ASK YOU TO CONSIDER.
ALLOWING US TO REVITALIZE THEIR
LANGUAGE WITH THE POPE ARE YOU
KIDDING ME. EVERY FROM REPEATING
HERE WHEN WE DON'T PUT IT OUT
THERE YOU'RE RIGHT WE REPEAT.
GOING FROM HASTINGS TO SAN
FRANCISCO IS THE EXACTLY
REPEATING YOU KNOW THE SAME.
HISTORY OF JUST RENAMING FOR THE
SAME IT MAY BE WORSE BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW WE GET A HASTINGS
WHETHER TACK ON US. THE
MISSION'S ATTACKED. ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS ANY
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT OF THOSE
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS. WE DID
READ OUT- THE PUBLIC LINE FOR
THE PHONE DO WE HAVE ANY ON THE
PHONE LINES THAT WOULD. OFFER
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE DO WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WITH ME. CORRECT OKAY
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND ALSO
CHAIRING THIS MY NAME IS. OUR
STATE THE BLOCKER AND LYFT
TRIBAL MEMBER OF THE CHEROKEE
NATION. AND SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT WORK THAT I DO IN MY
CAREER IS TO HONOR THE LIFE OF
MY MOTHER WHO COMMITTED OVER
FORTY EIGHT YEARS OF SERVICE
FOR. AMERICAN INDIAN EDUCATOR
AND ADVOCATE- AND THE TURKS
COUNTY AND TO HONOR THE TRIBAL
HISTORY OF MY ANCESTORS I'M ALSO
A BOARD MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
UNIFICATION OF ALL AND CURRENTLY
WORK AT SAN DIEGO COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION OF THE NEXT DECADE
OF LEADERSHIP. COACH AND A MULTI
LINGUAL EDUCATION A GLOBAL IT
SHOULD NOT DEPARTMENT- I SERVED
AS A BOARD MEMBER ON THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF THAT
AMERICAN INDIAN EDUCATION
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE. AND WORK
WITH OUR FORTY FOUR DISTRICTS IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND TRIBAL
EDUCATION CENTERS TO SUPPORT
CULTURALLY. RESPONSIVE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING. I JUST
WANT TO SPEAK FOR A FEW MINUTES
ABOUT THE WORK THAT WOULD BE THE
AND ADDITIONAL SUPPORT THAT WE
NEED IN OUR TRY COME. NEED ONLY
THE- COURT OF ROUGHLY. FROM THE
COMMITTEE. A LARGE PART OF THE
ACT WORK VALUE CAL OFFICE OF
THAT CHAMPION. THAT SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA INDIAN STUDENT AND
POPULATE. HE EFFORTS INCLUDE AND
FOR ME. ON OUR EQUITY GROUP
PRESS ROCK. THAT ADDRESS THAT
NEED AMERICA COMMUNE AND- A YEAR
LONG I'M LOOKING FOR THAT WE DID
WITH OUR TRIBAL- COMMITTEE. AND
SAN DIEGO OFFICE ABOUT PUBLIC
AND YOU- CULTURAL. AND CAL AND
CULTURE AND POVERTY CENTER
PARTNER TO CREATE AND YOU KNOW
FOR ALL. AGES CA NGA NG FOR ALL
ABOUT COM. OR ON TO WORK WITH DR
PROFIT THE COLD ON MEYER.
ADDITION WE PARK OUR DOCTORS
RODRIGUEZ COULD I CALL AND
HONORED TO WORK WITH PALOMAR
COLLEGE AND ALSO COUNTY IN A SAM
. THIS AMERICAN AND STUDY
DEPARTMENT OUR EFFORTS ARE
REALLY FOR AROUND HELPING AND
EDUCATE STUDENTS ABOUT THE DRIVE
CONTRIBUTION HAS. AND CALL OF
NATIVE PEOPLE AND EVERYTHING WE
DO IS FOCUSED ON LOOKING AT WAYS
TO PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
AND WE'VE LOOKED AT AND EVITA
WAYS TO DO THAT ON A VERY
LIMITED. BUDGET ON SOME OF THE
THING CLUSE NATIVE WAYS OF
KNOWING PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OFFERINGS AND RESOURCES.
TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO HELP
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS- ENCOURAGE
NATIVE AMERICAN FAMILY AND
TRIBAL COMMUNITY AGENCY EMPLOYEE
AND SUPPORTING WITH TRIBAL
EDUCATION. CONSULTATION
EVERYTHING THREE ARE REALLY A
STATE PLACE FOR THE HEALING AND
REALIZE. BUILDING MOST RECENTLY
WE HAVE THE WEBINARS WITH AND
CRIED. AUTHOR AND ON MY FOLLOW
W. WE THE FOUNDER OF MERIT
INDIAN CHAU FOR THEIR- WHERE
WERE LOOK AT MAYBE A PLACE TO
KNOWING. UNDER THE QUESTION.
WE'VE HAD OVER HUNDRED AND TRIED
AND YOU- PROFESSIONALS THAT HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN LESS THAN WE'RE
JUST HONORED TO DO THAT FOR. ON
A AGAIN WE ALWAYS ON WHO STORY
TO EACH TO COME AND- HOW DO ON
BATTLE YOU KNOW COLONIAL PERSON
OF HISTORY. AND ALL G. COLON.
AND WHAT WAIT WE DESIGN PRO ON
NATIVE PLAYS AND NOW. TOPICS
INCLUDE TEACHING CAL MEASURE.
TRADITIONAL EQUAL KNOWLEDGE.
THROUGH THE GOLDEN. CALIFORNIA
AND JUMBO SCHOOL AND MADE
AMERICA ACTOR THE AND CHANGE
RIGHT. WE ARE HONORED TO OFFER
THAT'S OFFERED MY COURSE THAT
FOCUSED ON NATIVE. AND
INNOVATION. THANK LEARNING
NUMBER DIVINE COOPER. FROM
AUTHORED. I MADE OF AMERICANS.
AND TRIED AT LEADER. I REALLY
WANNA SEE TO YOU TODAY BECAUSE-
WERE ASKING THE STATE
REPRESENTATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR ESPECIALLY
WITH THE MAY REVIVE IT SUPPORTED
DECISIONAL FUNDING DESIGN HONOR
AND PROPERLY COMPENSATE TROUBLE
EDUCATION ACT BURKE. THE VINE
QUALITY NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES
. WE KNOW THAT OTHER STATES LIKE
MONTANA MONTANA AND WASHINGTON
HAVE HAD ALLOCATED AT LEAST TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE EFFORT.
CURRENTLY WE ARE THEN SHARED
WITH THE AUDIENCE COUNTY OFFICE
OF THAT IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY
OFFICE OF THAT THAT MOST LIKE
GREEN WE WILL HAVE APPROXIMATELY
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONLY. FOR THIRTY EIGHT
MONTHS OF WORK THE DESIGN MADE
OF AMERICAN STUDIES MODEL
CURRICULUM. AND THE CURRICULUM
THAT WILL INCLUDE THE HISTORY OF
TWO HUNDRED FEDERALLY AND I'M
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES ALL
OF THE AUTHORED WITH TRIBAL
EDUCATION LEADERS AND NATIVE
AMERICAN AUTHORS. HONESTLY WHEN
WE DEVELOP THE BUDGET FOR A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IT'S A LITTLE TO NO
MONEY REALLY GOING TO. THE VAST
AMOUNT OF ACT WE NEED TO WORK
WITH FROM OUR TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
IF YOU IF YOU ADD THREE AS WELL-
WE CAN WE CAN- WRAP IT UP BUT IF
THERE'S CERTAIN BUDGET ITEMS
THAT YOU'RE- REFERRING TO YOU
COULD GET A HOLD OF OUR OFFICE.
AND WE CAN LOOK DEEPLY INTO IT
DEEPER INTO THOSE ISSUES
THEMSELVES- SO I KNOW WE HAVE
OTHER COLORS TOO SO IF YOU
COULD- WRAPPED UP IN A CONTACT
OUR OFFICE WITH FOLLOW UP ON THE
BUDGET REQUEST. AREAS THAT ARE
THERE- JUST WANNA WRAP IT UP AND
SAY THAT WE ALSO HEARD THAT
THERE'S TWO MILLION- DOLLARS OF
MULTICULTURAL CURRICULUM. JUST
WANTING TO KNOW THIRDS EARMARKED
FOR A NATIVE AMERICAN. AUTHORED
ON AN INDIGENOUS VOICE-
CURRICULUM FOR THAT. AND I THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR LISTENING AND
AGAIN FIVE WERE ADVOCATING FOR
TEN MILLION DOLLARS A FUNDING
FOR. NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES-
MODEL CURRICULUM TO FIND HELLO
EDUCATION ACT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS TO HAVE
ANY OTHER ON THE PHONE LINES
INTO THE PUBLIC COMMENT. YES
WILL. THANK YOU LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO- THIS
IS DANA HERE THE SAUDI CALLING
IN FROM SHERMAN IN HIGH SCHOOL.
GOOD AFTERNOON- I HAVE BEEN
HAVING MY HISTORY STUDENTS-
WATCHED- THIS SESSION ALL DAY
LONG. AND THIS IS MY CLASS AFTER
LUNCH I HAVE ONE STUDENT WHO IS
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN THIS
TOPIC SHE'S FROM NORTH DAKOTA
HAS WORKED ON A SIMILAR ISSUE IN
HER HOME STATE AND THIS YOU HAVE
IF YOU WERE TO LIKE TO SAY AND-
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY HELLO TO
PHILIPSTOWN THEM BECAUSE WE WERE
TOGETHER FOR MANY YEARS THE HIGH
SET. THE LAST. GOOD WORK YOU'RE
DOING. I'M I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND- PASSED THE PHONE OVER NOW
TO MY STUDENT AND SHE'S GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND ARE JUST YOURSELF
AND MAKE A FEW COMMENTS IF YOU
DON'T MIND. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS ARE WE TALKED THE
MEDICINE I AM FROM THE CHEYENNE
RIVER SIOUX TRIBE IN SOUTH
DAKOTA AND I LIVE IN STANDING
ROCK WITH MY AUNTIE COLLETTE
MEDICINE AND SHE IS THE EDUCATOR
AT THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND-
LAST APRIL WE WORKED- WITH GROUP
GROUP BUFFALO FOR THE
REPRESENTATIVE ARTICLE TO HELP
PASS THE SB TWENTY THREE OH FOR
LONG. AND IT IT JUST REMINDED ME
SO MUCH OF WHICH IS WHAT YOU
GUYS ARE TALKING ABOUT AND HOW
MUCH THAT OUR KIDS ARE UNDER
EDUCATED. AND EVEN IF ALL PEOPLE
JUST NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT OUR
PAST NEEDS TO BE TALKED ABOUT.
AN OFF YOU GUYS WERE TALKING
ABOUT HOW- THE MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN RATES
ARE LIKE EXTREMELY HIGH AND DID
NOT TALK ABOUT. THAT WE HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT IT LIKE THIS LIKE WHY
DOES IT HAVE TO BE BROUGHT UP IN
A COURT ROOM IN ORDER TO BE
TALKED ABOUT. AND ALSO HOW ARE
CUTER POORLY TREATED. AND THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM FOR LIKE. LAKE
I DON'T. THINK LIKE THIS BECAUSE
NEEDED LIKE YOU. JUST UNDER MY
IT BE YOU YOU JUST HAVE BEEN. TO
PEOPLE THAT MAKE NATIVE PEOPLE
SEEM LIKE. AND ALSO JUST HEARING
ABOUT THE CAL. INDIAN COLLEGE
ARE THE CALIFORNIA AND IN NEED
OF TO JUST REALLY IT'S. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
. IS THERE ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PHONE LINES. YES
THANK YOU- LINE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ARE YOU ABLE
TO HEAR ME. YES. WONDERFUL THANK
YOU SO MUCH I COULDN'T HELP
ASSEMBLY OUT ONLY ON THE PHONE
ON THANK YOU SO MUCH- TO THE
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR CONDUCTING
THIS GATHERING AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU MY
NAME IS RATE HE LEANED EXPELLED
R. E. I. T. H. I AND MY LAST
NAME IS LEE L. E. E. I GRADUATED
FROM UC HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE
LAW IN TWO THOUSAND AND THREE-
I'M THE CHILD ADVOCATE AND
EDUCATOR A COMMISSIONER ON THE
CITY OF BERKELEY'S PEACE AND
JACKETS COMMISSION AND A
CANDIDATE FOR BERKELEY SCHOOL
BOARD THIS YEAR. I SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY HOWEVER AS A CONCERNED
CITIZEN AND NOTTHE MOTHER TO A
TEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER AND AN.
EIGHT YEAR OLD SON IN PUBLIC
SCHOOL. NOW WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
HIS IT IS CLEAR THAT OR IF YOU
HAVE FAILED TO. THE TRUTH IS
NEVER IN. AND IF IT WASN'T
COMPLETE IT WAS NEVER THE TRUTH.
THE FACT THAT NONE OF US KNEW
ABOUT THE UC PEOPLE. AND THE
ACTORS INCLUDING IRAN IF HE'S
SAYING WHOSE LEVERAGE A
PERFECTLY LEGAL DEMOCRATIC
SYSTEM OF LAWS IN ELECTORATE.
KERRY OUT IN GENOCIDE FONG BY
THE GOVERNMENT IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF MANY OF HOW WE'VE
BEEN TOTALLY FAILED. NOW IT
SEEMS LIKE A NO BRAINER TO SAID
A NAME SYNONYMOUS WITH GENOCIDE
AND HATE BASED ON OUR DISCUSSION
TODAY BUT I JUST WANT TO REMIND
YOU THAT JUST LESS THAN A YEAR
AGO BEFORE THE NEW YORK TIMES
ARTICLE HIT THE PRESS. YOUR
GRANTED HE THINK WAS STILL ABLE
TO YOU CAME SUPPORT BY MANY
DECISION MAKERS AND THOSE WITH
POWER TO KEEP HIS NAME ON OUR
BUILDINGS AND DIPLOMATIC. I
THINK THERE'S ONLY TO REMIND US
LEST WE GET TOO COMPLACENT OR
COMFORTABLE JUST HOW POWERFUL
AND PERVASIVE THE TENTACLES OF
PREJUDICE POWER AND PRIVILEGE IN
THIS COUNTRY CAN BE. BECAUSE
SOMETIMES THERE ARE HIDDEN AND
THEY'RE NOT OBVIOUSLY I'D- AND
IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT. TO
UNTANGLE AND DESTROY THEM. A THE
TIME ANTI IN DESTROY HAVE. COME
BUT NAME MOSCOW DOWN NO QUESTION
. THE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
MEASURES FOUGHT BY THE U. P.
PEOPLE MUST BE GIVEN FULL
CONSIDERATION AND SUPPORT AND
THIS INCLUDES A REPLACEMENT NAME
SELECTED BY THE UCBCP PAUL WHO
ARE THE MOST IMPACTED IN THIS
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCE. BECAUSE
WE KNOW YOUR SITTING IN IN THESE
SEATS OF DECISION MAKING YOU
KNOW BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE
THAT VISIBILITY MATTER. BECAUSE
REPRESENTATION MATTERS BECAUSE
TRUTH MATTERS ON BUILDING WE
DON'T NEED ANOTHER SCHOOL NAME
SAN FRANCISCO WE HAVE SO MANY OF
THEM ALREADY. NOW IS A MADE UP
NAME MAKE PEOPLE UNCOMFORTABLE
WE AS AMERICANS NEED COULD LOOK
WITHIN OURSELVES AND ASK WHY IT
IS ONLY BY STEPPING INTO THAT
DISCOMFORT CAN WE HOPE FOR ANY
REAL CHANGE IN THIS COUNTRY. AND
I SINCERELY HOPE WE CAN MODEL
THAT CHANGE FOR OUR CHILDREN. AT
A BARE MINIMUM THE MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITY YOU KEEP PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE THAT INCLUDES
MYSELF MY FAMILY AND MANY
OTHERS. DESERVE A FAIR
TRANSPARENT AND INCLUSIVE
PROCESS BUT THE NAME SELECTION
THAT IS NOT DRIVEN BY THOSE WITH
MONEY POWER IN STATUS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY I APPRECIATE
YOUR HARD WORK THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS- DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER A PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE PHONE LINES. YES LINE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEN RAMOS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CONDUCTING
THESE HEARINGS TODAY THIS WAS AN
EXTREMELY HISTORIC AND IMPORTANT
EVENT AND I COMMEND YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR IT MY NAME IS
GEORGE BISHARAT I AM AN EMERITUS
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW WHERE I HAVE
TAUGHT FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS. I WANT TO SEE VERY
QUICKLY THAT I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SHOWING STRONG DEFERENCE TO THE
DESIRES OF THE U. P. SURVIVING
YOU KEY MEMBERS TO OFFERED THE
NEW NAME FOR THE COLLEGE. THIS
WILL. EDUCATE CALIFORNIANS AND
INDEED ALL AMERICANS AS TO THE
TRUE HISTORY OF THE STATE END OF
THE RELATIONSHIP OF THE SCHOOL
TO THE YOU KEEP PEOPLE. IF THE
NAME DOESN'T ROLL EASILY OFF OF
OUR TONGUES WILL LEARN WE CAN WE
CAN DO THAT MUCH I ALSO WANT TO
JUST COMMENT BRIEFLY ON
SOMETHING SAID BY MY DEAN AND
CHANCELLOR DAVID SEGMENT. HE
ASPECT OF THE OF SOVEREIGNTY IS
THE POWER TO SELL FROM THE I
WILL POINT OUT THAT THE
SOVEREIGN THAT MEANS HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW INITIALLY WAS
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THIS THROUGH
THIS LEGISLATURE. AND AND THAT
IS THE SOVEREIGN THAT WILL
RENAME THE SCHOOL. SO IT IS NOT
BEING FAKE MAN IT IS NT MY
FACULTY IT IS NOT EVEN OUR BOARD
OF GOVERNORS. DOT NET OUR OUR
OUR OUR BOARD THAT IS THE
SOVEREIGN IN THIS IN THIS
SITUATION HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
THE LAW IS A PUBLIC INSTITUTION
IT IS THE- ENTITY. OF THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
HOPE THAT THIS LEGISLATURE WILL
YOU IN IN THIS COMMITTEE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST WILL SHOW
LEADERSHIP NOT ONLY WITHIN THE
STATE BUT TO THE COUNTRY AS A
WHOLE. THAT THIS KIND OF
RENAMING CAN HAPPEN SHOULD
HAPPEN AND WILL HAPPEN THANKS
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND ANY OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE PHONE
LINES. YES THANK YOU LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD- GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
NORMA PAZ GARCIA THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TEST MATCH
TESTIFIED I AM IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO GRADUATE OF UC
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAW AND
THE PUBLIC INTEREST ATTORNEY IN
SAN FRANCISCO. MY PARENTS ARE
FROM MEXICO AND I'M PROUD TO SAY
THAT MY ANCESTORS INCLUDE THE
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF SOUTHERN
HOW DIFFICULT AND MICHOACAN
MEXICO SADLY I CAN SAY NO MORE
ABOUT MY INDIGENOUS ANCESTORS
BECAUSE THAT HISTORY. HAS BEEN
RAISED. FOR FORTY YEARS I'VE
USED MY LEGAL TRAINING TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE RIGHTS OF THOSE
WHO THE DOMINANT CULTURE HAS
CONSIDERED AND TREATED AS
INFERIOR. I'M NO STRANGER TO THE
PHENOMENA OF CULTURAL ERASURE.
AT IMMIGRANT IN THIS COUNTRY MY
OWN FAMILY EXPERIENCES IN
VARIOUS FORMS. AND WHILE
LISTENING TO TODAY'S TESTIMONY I
RECALLED MY OWN FAMILY'S HISTORY
OF BEING BEATEN FOR SPEAKING
SPANISH AND OF HAVING YOUR MOUTH
WASHED OUT WITH SOAP. FOR
SPEAKING THEIR LANGUAGE. BUT
IT'S ALSO ADDS THIS IS. NOTHING
PREPARED ME FOR WHAT I LEARNED
ABOUT IRAN IS FACING AND HIS
TREATMENT OF THE YOU KEEP PEOPLE
. I WAS SHOCKED I WAS APPALLED
AND I WITH THE SAME. I WOULD BE
STAYING BECAUSE THE DIPLOMA THAT
HANG ON MY WALL THAT I WORKED SO
HARD FOR AS THE FIRST PERSON IN
MY FAMILY TO GO TO COLLEGE LET
ALONE LAW SCHOOL. THAT DIPLOMA
BEARS THE NAME OF A MAN THAT
EXPLOITED OUR SACRED THE SCENT
OF DEMOCRACY TO TRY TO
EXTINGUISH EIGHT PEOPLE. AND THE
SORROW OF THE VICTIMS AND THEIR
ANCESTORS TO ME IT'S AN
IMAGINABLE. AND THE SHAME THAT
WE SHOULD ALL FEEL SHOULD BE THE
IMPETUS TO ENSURE THAT JUSTICE
BE DONE AND THAT THE UK FOLKS BE
THE DRIVERS OF WHAT THAT SHOULD
LOOK LIKE. CLEARLY THE RIGHT
COURSE. IF YOU REMOVE THE
HASTINGS NAME THAT IS NOT IN
DISPUTE. BUT THE NAME GOING
FORWARD WHO GETS TO DECIDE AND
WHAT DID YOU GET A CHANCE YOU. I
SUPPORT UP COMMITTEE AND
DEFINING WHAT THAT SHOULD BE AND
I URGE THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
RESPECT THE- EVEN IF IT MAKES
THEM UNCOMFORTABLE. I APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS ALREADY MADE BY YOU
SEE WHO CALLED IT A LOT AND
THERE IS MORE TO DO. WHAT IS
SIMPLE A NAME TAG THE SCORE OF
YOUR GRAPHIC LOCATION UPER
SIMPLE BUT IT DOES NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HISTORY IT DOES
NOT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
MOMENT TO MAKE THIS RIGHT AND
WHAT DO YOU KEEP PEOPLE AND THE
TRIBAL LEADERS WANT. I'D SAY THE
AT NIEDERSACHSEN CISCO AND LYFT
LANCASTER AT THE STATE CITY I
STILL BELIEVE WE CAN AND SHOULD
FOLLOW THE LEAD OF THE U. P.
COMMITTEE AND I SUPPORT THE
RENAMING OF UC TAKING CALLS OF
LAW MY ALMA MATER. WITH THE NAME
AND THE UC. LANGUAGE LET'S BE
COURAGEOUS HERE. LET'S NOT OUR-
ON WHAT CAN AND SHOULD DO IN
FAVOR OF WHAT IT'S EASY DO IF
YOU CAN WRAP UP A FAMILY. GETS
ALL. IT YES IT'S TIME REWRITE A
NEW NARRATIVE HISTORY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR PACKAGING WHICH
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH HAVE ANY
OF PUBLIC ON THE PHONE LINES.
THE YES LINE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LAW IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLYMEN RAMA THIS IS JULIE
AT MY ESTAS CALLING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL COLLEGE I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A QUICK COMMENT AND
THANK YOU AND THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE. FOR ALL THREE PANELS
TODAY I TOTALLY SUPPORT THE NAME
CHANGE ALSO FOR YOU UC HASTINGS
AND I JUST AGAIN WANT TO SEND MY
THANKS AND REGARDS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING IN THE FUTURE
FOR CALIFORNIA TRIBAL COLLEGES.
FOR OUR TRIBAL PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CALMEST WE HAVE ANYMORE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PHONE LINES. LINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AND- AND
EVERYONE PRESENT MY NAME IS
JONATHAN CORDERO I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF RAMAKRISHNA LONI
. I AM ALSO THE CHAIR OF OUR
TRIBAL ORGANIZATION I'M A
VISITING SCHOLAR IN THE
INDIGENOUS LAWCENTER AT UC
HASTINGS I AM A VISITING SCHOLAR
AT USC- I'VE BEEN- A CO PI ON-
THEN THE CRITICAL MISSION
STUDIES GRANT. WITH UC SAN DIEGO
UC RIVERSIDE- UCLA AND UC SANTA
CRUZ. I AM CALLING TO JUST OFFER
SOME INFORMATION IN REGARDS TO
THE OFFER- CHANGING THE NAME TO-
OF THE LAW SCHOOL- TO A U.
KEENAY. PRIOR TO THE FOUNDING OF
UC HASTINGS THAT WAS FUNDED BY
THE- THE MONIES FROM SERENITY
THANKS. PRIOR TO THE ATROCITIES
OF THE YOU KEEP PEOPLE. WAS THE
GENOCIDE OF MY ANCESTORS IN THE
END IN OUR ANCESTRAL HOMELAND.
IN THE CITY PRESENT CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
INDEED ALONG THE ENTIRE SAN
FRANCISCO PENINSULA. ARE PEOPLE
WERE NEARLY ENTIRELY DECIMATED
BY THE GENOCIDE ON THE SPANISH
COLONISTS. AND WE EXPERIENCED
AGAINST AND WHAT KIND OF
ATROCITIES WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM YOU CAN. WE ARE THE
ATROCITY OF OUR PEOPLE RESEEDED
AND MADE POSSIBLE THE FOUNDING
OF UC HASTINGS ON OUR ANCESTRAL
HOMELAND IN OTHER WORDS BEFORE
THE U. K. ACROSS THE THERE IS
THE ATROCITY THAT AFFECTED OUR
PEOPLE. AND I AM OPPOSING THE
NAME CHANGED TO- TO A YOU CAN
NAME BECAUSE IT WOULD OFFEND OUR
PEOPLE'S. NO I AM FULL SUPPORT A
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE FOR THE YOU
KEEP PEOPLE'S BUT I SPECIFICALLY
OPPOSED THE NAME CHANGE TO A YOU
CAN NAME ON OUR ANCESTRAL
HOMELAND AND I HOPE THE UT WITH
UNDERSTAND TOO THAT THAT WOULD
BE ENTIRELY INAPPROPRIATE AND A
VIOLATION OF INDIGENOUS PROTOCOL
TO DO SO AND YOU WRAP UP YOUR-
ONE. ONE I WILL ONE FINAL
COMMENT MOST OF THE PRESENTERS
TODAY HAVE BEEN MEMBERS OF
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES IF
NOT ALL AND WE WOULD APPRECIATE
IT IF- NON RECOGNIZED CALIFORNIA
INDIANS WOULD BE INCLUDED AND-
DISCUSSIONS LIKE THIS WITH THE
STATE THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS IS THERE
ANYMORE PUBLIC COMMENT WE ARE
RUNNING OUT OF TIME SO WE MIGHT
HAVE TO CUT THE PUBLIC
COMMENTATORS HOW MANY MORE DO WE
HAVE ON THE PHONE LINES. THERE
IS NO MORE IN THE QUEUE. ASK FOR
MORE TIME IS OR ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PHONE LINES. ONLY
ONE FOLLOW UP WOULD YOU LIKE TO
. IT KNOWLEDGE THAT S. LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THOMAS AND SELECT COMMITTEE ON
NATIVE AMERICAN. ERIC COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NADIA
DOMINGUEZ I'M CALLING FROM THE
WALK LAND COLONIALLY KNOWN AS
CONCORD CALIFORNIA. I WAS BORN
AND RAISED ON A LONEY LAN
COLONIALLY KNOWN AS OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND MY ANCESTORS RPP
FROM AVAILABLE WHAT THE COLONIAL
NAME GIVEN TO THEM AND ALSO
CORNER THE COLONIAL NAME GIVEN
TO THE PEOPLE FROM MY ANY
MEDICAL I'M AN ALUMNA OF YOUR
HASTINGS FROM THE CLASS OF
TWENTY THIRTEEN. AND AT UC
HASTINGS I WAS PART OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN LAW STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION NAFA AND DURING MY
TIME AT UC HASTINGS NAFA HOSTED
A PANEL ON THE HISTORY OF THE
FOUNDER OF HE THINKS AND WE
TALKED ABOUT THE GENOCIDAL
ATROCITIES COMMITTED. AGAINST
THE PEOPLE OF NATIVE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA I AM GLAD THAT STERN
MAN MORE INFORMATION HAS COME TO
LIGHT AND PUBLICATIONS AND OTHER
MEDIA. SO THAT THIS HISTORY
COULD BE KNOWN BY OTHER PEOPLE
INCLUDING THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR
SCHOOL AND I AM HERE TO SAY THAT
I SUPPORT AN OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS THAT
INCLUDES OUR LEGISLATURE THAT
INCLUDES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO SPEAK ON THIS MATTER.
AND TO EXPRESS ALL THE DIFFERENT
CONCERNS AND VOICES AND
ESPECIALLY UP LEFT THE VOICE TO
BETTER MOST MARGINALIZED I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING WHERE IT'S
EASIER TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND LETTERS AND OTHER
WAYS TO BRING IT THE DIFFERENT
OPINIONS AND I ALSO A MASTER
CLOSE. I WANT TO UPLIFT ISSUE
THAT BROUGHT UP ABOUT RENAMING
THE SCHOOL TO ADD SOMETHING THAT
IS ASSOCIATED WITH OF THE
GENOCIDAL PAST THE MISSION
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA- IT WOULD
BE SUCH A- MISSED OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO REALLY THINK ABOUT
WHAT IT MEANS TO RENAME SCHOOLS-
TO- JUST GIVE IT ANOTHER. NAME
THAT ALSO REPRESENTS SUCH IN AN
- AND THAT WOULD BE DOUBLE JUST
AND JUST BECAUSE IT TOUGH STATE
WELL FOR BRANDING AND MARK
PURPOSES THANK YOU SOME. FOR
YOUR- TO MORNING AFTERNOON AND I
LOOK FORWARD AGAINST HOPEFULLY
STAYING MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR
FURTHER PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS IS VERY MORE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PHONE LINES.
HEARING NONE IS ANOTHER ONE-
LINE WE DO HAVE ONE MORE. THIRTY
TWO POINT THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO OF THE DANA FARBER
CALLING AGAIN- THIS TIME I AM
CALLING IN AS AS A MOM OF
CHILDREN THAT ARE IN THE
RIVERSIDE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT- I'M ENROLLED MEMBER OF
THE CHEROKEE NATION ABOVE THE
DESCENT OF THE CHOCTAW CADDO
NATION- AND WITH SIX CHILDREN
AND I'VE GONE THROUGH IT- R. U.
S. T. LOS TUTOR STILL ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL. I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
SEE- GET INVOLVED WITH A
POSSIBLE A CHANGE IN OUR
CURRICULUM TO REALLY REPRESENT A
TRUE- HISTORY OF OUR PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA IN OUR NATION AS A
WHOLE AND I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH OUR LOCAL HISTORY
TO HELP OUR LOCAL MATH TEACHER
THE FATHER TELL US. YOU KNOW
AFTER FIVE IN HER CLASSROOM AND
REALLY BROUGHT THINGS TO LIGHT
BUT IT'S NOT BECAUSE THAT'S AND
THAT AND THAT IS THE ISSUE HERE.
AND I HAD BROUGHT OVER THE MANY
YEARS MY KIDS OF AN RSD YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING'S GIVING EVERY
HALLOWEEN EVERY HOLIDAY
ASSOCIATED WITH NATIVE PEOPLE NO
GUN THE PRINCIPALS AND TEACHERS
ON PLEASE DON'T SEND MY KIDS
SOME LITTLE- STRUCTURE HAVE MADE
A REAL CREEK FEATHERS AND- NOT
PAY OF THING FOR SMOG OF I WOULD
LIKE TO ADD A MOM ALSO THE-
TEACHER- I'D LIKE TO INVOLVED
THAT THAT CURRICULUM. FAR APART
KIDS FOR ALL OF OUR KIDS. THANK
THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THOSE COME. NEVER BEEN- TACKLING
THAT IS DOWN AND RE. MOVE BUT
SOME. AMERICAN INDIAN IS. TO
FORCE AND SOMEBODY TO LOOK. SO
THANK YOU FOR THOSE. DO WE HAVE
ANY PUBLIC. ON THE FOR LINES. NO
PUBLIC. THANK YOU MUCH OF
COMMENT IN THE CHAIN. I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR ENGAGING ALL
THE DIFFERENT PANELISTS THAT WE
HEAR RAISING THESE DISCUSSIONS
THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORICALLY- FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
HAVE THE HEARING HERE TODAY. AND
TOUCH ON THE ISSUES AND WHAT'S
MORE IMPORTANT IS WE WERE ABLE
TO HEAR FROM THE ACTUAL- INDIAN
PEOPLE THEMSELVES OF HOW THESE
ISSUES DRASTICALLY AFFECT THEM.
SO MANY THANK YOU ALL FOR
ATTENDING THIS HEARING IS NOW.
CONCLUDED